Aussi.
Salut à tous et bienvenue
pour ce dernier épisode disponible
sur la chaîne de Gauthier G.
Au spoil, ça rigole un peu
parce qu'on n'est pas prêts du tout.
Ils sont en train de faire
les touches de poste.
Il y a Claudine
qui est dans un coin de la pièce.
Vous voilà donc si vous suivez la chaîne.
Du coup, moi,
c'est pas la Gauthier, j'ose pas.
Moi, c'est Zowie, Lou et Gauthier.
Je bosse pas. Du coup, il est juste ici.
Mais il y un temps de présenter.
Savez comment ça va son portable ?
Ça va très bien. OK.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter rapidement
s'il y en a deux ou trois
avions ?
Pas suivi Gautier Delplace,
elle qui a joué
au spoil sur elle sur le web.
Donc je suis, je suis quoi ?
On s'en fout.
J'ai une chaîne ou je parle de géologie,
d'environnement
et de plein d'autres sujets.
Voilà une chaîne YouTube
et une chaîne Twitch.
Ici, vous êtes dessus.
Voilà, ou apparemment c'est
du JDR scientifique, c'est incroyable.
Ouais, mais pas que. Mais pas.
Mais on en parlera à la fin de l'émission.
Il y a des commandes pour aller voir
ces autres réseaux.
Du coup, pour Exclamation Gautier
pour la déclamation gospel,
pour l'exclamation Fredo.
Exactement.
Je jouais Fredo Frédéric dans le Tchad
et on vous balance des liens.
Et si jamais vous n'arrivez pas
à vous demander un mot d'eau
à chaque partie, voilà
quelqu'un qui vous dira
Il y a qu'il doit dire
oui. Valentine,
j'avais le nom de ton personnage.
Eglantine Non, non. Valentine.
Comment tu vas ?
Très bien, très bien. Et toi, ça va
tranquille.
Est ce que tu peux te présenter aussi pour
si on a deux,
ce n'est pas suivi
au fond ? Oui, tout à fait.
Bonjour, je suis Valentine
à la science de comptoir sur YouTube
ou je parle de caillou et ici
je suis Eglantine Bidan
et je suis donc signaux de la start
up Flappy
qui fait de la prospection
minières et pétrolières.
Ça va énorme.
Il y a des commandes
pour aller voir ces réseaux. Du coup, oui.
Exclamation Valentine pour exclamation
Églantine pour notre formation.
Pétrole.
De WE destruction de la planète par qui ?
Ça tombe bien.
On a Clotilde qui est revenue de son coin.
Envoyer des tweets, des photos.
Je ne sais pas. De la source d'énergie.
Comment ça va. Ça va bien.
Ben oui bonsoir tout le monde, donc
moi je suis petite chamussy de la chaîne.
Passer sauvage, c'est une chaîne.
On parle de sciences
humaines et sociales,
donc archéologie, anthropologie, histoire.
Voilà.
Et puis ce soir, je incarnerait
Gloria coupe Ross, une archéologue
perdue dans le futur et qui essaye
de retrouver son chantier abandonné.
Exactement.
Je vais découvrir un truc
un peu bizarre dans ton futur.
La dernière fois que tu te rappelles, non.
C'est sur moi tout ce que veut
l'archéologue.
Ce que le. Passé j'ai oublié.
C'est dans les. Temps et j'ai des notes.
Après sculpte cette image,
j'ai quand même dessiné
un spermatozoïde sur mon carnet.
Là, le scénario qui est en train
de s'effondrer dans un tourbillon
ne pose pas de problème.
Je rappelle pas ad hoc.
Je te dis que ça va revenir.
Mais la petite secte souterraine ?
Non mais oui, bien sûr.
Et ça, on s'en souvient.
Mais je pensais que la
Lune s'attendait à un objet.
J'ai cru
qu'il allait arriver quelque chose.
Là, oui, mais non.
Il est arrivé, voilà.
Dans un site à des commandes,
on tombe dans le château
pour l'excavation, Clotilde pour
l'exclamation, Gloria pour exclamation
Pas si sauvage, voilà.
Et le dernier, du coup, Arnaud.
Arnaud de stupide économie X
donc une chaîne de journalisme économique
ou on parle de sujets, de sujets, de.
Société ?
Oui, là, ça arrive et c'est ça
le. Sujet de société,
de problématique.
Économique.
C'est deux choses, deux choses du genre
ou ça se passe très bien.
Je bégaye relativement peu.
Oui, je vois, je peux, je prends mon temps
pour refléter j'vas tout, tout va bien.
Heureusement qu'on peut couper les choses,
faire un montage.
En direct. Comme ça.
Et ce soir, j'incarne Alain, Pierre, Alain
Chiche, potiche,
président de Cci, qui maintenant n'existe
plus malheureusement dans le futur.
Et mon but est bien tout simplement
de développer l'économie d'horizon et
de faire preuve d'humanisme.
Ça a toujours
mes commandes pendant un bon point
d'exclamation.
Arnaud. Point d'exclamation.
Pierre-Alain Chiche fortiche.
Comme ça, c'est.
Et point d'exclamation.
Stupide. Économique.
Voilà, c'est bien joué.
On remercie le CNC qui nous aide
à financer ce projet,
le Quai des savoirs qui nous prête
le studio et qui nous aide beaucoup.
Un petit remerciement de toute l'équipe
à la fin de l'émission.
Vous,
si jamais vous avez des questions sur
des notions qu'on a abordé dans l'épisode,
gardez les vous en tête et à la fin
on vous dira Allez maintenant,
donnez nous les questions.
Et à ce moment là, distribué
dans le chat Twitch, on les reprendra
et on discutera autour de la table.
Tous ensemble,
vous allez avoir des sondages
et des cookies dans le château
qui vont se passer à certains moments.
Surveillez bien,
ce sera marqué sur l'écran ou leurs yeux.
Surveiller le château concrètement,
les sondages, ça va vous
permettre d'influer
sur ce qui se passe dans l'aventure ?
Les cookies ?
Si vous avez juste à vous permettre
de donner des bonus malus
pour changer des joueurs.
Pour voilà, voilà.
Ou bien
on est prêt pour lancer ce dernier épisode
des braises de ce podium générique.
On n'a pas.
Notre groupe. Est.
Arrivé au syndic IE10 en début de journée.
Un village paisible d'apparence mais qui
est le siège de nombreux jeux de pouvoir.
Après une journée
bien remplie dans laquelle ils ont trouvé
la recette de la synthèse de ce podium
et affirmé leur désaccord
avec les Aigles rouges auprès du maire,
ils ont été forcés de payer leurs dettes
envers Lara,
la baronne de la pègre locale.
Cette dernière
leur avait proposé de l'aider
à retrouver une certaine Mélissa,
qui lui devait beaucoup d'argent.
En échange,
elle effacerait la dette qu'il lui doit.
Après quelques
recherches, ils sont tombés sur Mélissa,
prisonnière d'une secte
qui a pris possession des ruines Sélénite.
Ils ont donc décidé de libérer elle
et sa fille avant de la livrer à Lara.
Les voici donc au beau milieu du village
d'Iris, en début de soirée.
Ils avaient rendez vous avec un marchand
qui vous amènera à Marigny demain.
D'ici là, qu'est ce que vous faites.
Bien ma foi,
toute cette lutte
contre les dérives sectaires
des releases m'a fatigué.
Je ne l'ai pas compris,
mais moi aussi, je suis fatigué.
Et du coup, je suggère au groupe.
Souhaitez vous, chers compagnons
compagnons, que nous allions à l'hôtel.
Puis en avait payé ?
Vous lancez un référendum ?
C'est tout à fait
un RIP.
Référendum d'initiative partagée.
Populaire celui là, il est partagé
par tous. Non, mais c'est une chance.
Pour la. Sémantique.
Ça me va ? Oui, oui, oui.
Très bien.
Vous avez pensé ? Il est un peu tôt
quand même. Oui, mais lesquels ?
On a compris la grande histoire.
De 2 h. Le biorythme.
Ah bah oui, non. Mais moi, moi je vais.
Je ne vais pas me coucher tout de suite.
D'accord.
Tu veux faire quelque chose à la place ?
Bah oui.
Plus tôt,
je vais aller me balader au marché.
Attends deux secondes.
Faut mute, Nico, s'il vous plaît.
Mais toi,
quand tu parles aux gens dans la merci.
Ce n'est pas du courage qui est.
En train de me dire.
Je vais retourner au marché. OK,
ça marche.
Je retourne au marché.
Parce qu'il
y avait un petit stand d'artisanat
qui m'a plu
et j'ai pas eu le temps de tout regarder.
Face au marché, tu viens faire un petit,
c'est en train de remballer.
Mais il y a quand même
encore quelques trucs comme ça.
C'est pas. Mon style.
Un petit jeu
d'intelligence et d'intelligence.
Tranché.
Googlez vous l'intelligence ?
Eh bien Ebenezer,
eh bien si non, comment on fait ?
Si je ne suis pas
persuadé.
Tu additionne les deux.
Oui mais là les design c'est zéro.
OK, donc. Six sur 70.
Donc tu n'es pas du tout obligé
d'acheter Costco.
Oh ben oui, mais je veux
que ça non.
Les objets n'arrivant jamais
six 60, je veux, je promets.
Et du désir.
D'accord, je suis pas obligé
d'acheter quelque chose comme ça.
Je crois que j'ai pas beaucoup de sous.
J'ai une pile, une machette qui m'a pas
bien servi.
Il y avait le grand feu. Non,
moi je veux retourner voir.
Non, l'arc en ciel, c'est
les lumières de la ruelle, c'est ça.
Et il y a un feu au bout.
OK, il y a le grand feu de la place.
Au milieu de la place. OK.
Eh bien, je demande pas.
Je suis autour du feu.
Puis je croise une femme
et je lui demande comment on part.
Par la route.
Ouais, mais par quel ?
Comment on nous amène ?
Attends
un chat, Marie-Lys,
c'est là qu'on va aller.
Oui, c'est vrai, on y va demain.
Mais oui, on y va demain.
On, c'est déjà prévu.
L'itinéraire est déjà. Tracé.
Je ferai tout et surtout.
On est, on est calé. Oui,
c'est valable.
Tu peux nous retrouver.
Mais c'est le feu de joie.
Voilà, vous, vous avez mangé ?
Non, mais un peu plus.
On n'est pas censé être là,
donc ça, c'est pareil.
Non mais faites la conversation
comme si on était son.
Ben non.
En fait, je discute pas
parce que je suis pas très sociable.
Du coup, elle continue son chemin.
Ou alors on fait
ce suivi.
Il est maintenant 0 h. Et.
Je fais juste un tour.
De magie.
Dessus.
Oui, je sais pas. Qu'est ce que.
Nous on dort ?
Vous vous. Dormez, nous. Inondant ?
Vous êtes nerveux ?
Si tu savais.
Mais très bien.
Je ne sais pas.
Je rentre à l'hôtel, du coup,
je vais me coucher plus tard.
Je ne sais pas.
Je peux juste un petit tour.
Voilà. C'est encore une couche.
Un peu plus tard, très bien
dormi, passé une nuit bien reposante.
Si vous manque un point,
je vais pouvoir récupérer.
Ah oui.
Moi j'ai pris des risques, donc
j'ai tous mes prix.
Y compris les transports.
Nous voilà.
On fait gaffe avec ça.
On la joue.
C'est compliqué de perdre deux points
de vue nous passer une bonne nuit.
Vous vous levez le lendemain
relativement tôt,
puis vous êtes vers 8 h du matin
et vous avez rendez vous à 10 h.
Parfait à la sortie ouest avec le marchand
que vous aviez rencontré la veille.
Mais du
coup, Gloria, est ce que tu arrives
à travailler à 8 h du matin ?
Ah non. Je peux. J'ai déjà fait ça, non ?
Je me suis déjà parlé,
donc je peux pas louper le trajet.
Par contre, pour une question, je pensais.
Ah oui, ça a lancé.
OK, c'est
pas par les chevaux.
OK, ça lançait de quoi ?
Rythme décalé.
Je crois. Ah oui, pardon ?
OK. 50 à 86.
Tu dors ?
Je dors à portée.
Donc on a l'habitude maintenant.
Donc moi, j'attends qu'elle apporte.
Nous, on va au petit dej.
Gloria
me porter. OK.
L'opération Sauvez Gloria.
Vous savez comment ça se passe
maintenant ?
On a l'habitude.
Je suis tel un pavé.
Une fois hors.
Vous,
je pense qu'on prend juste notre pavé.
Nous, on mange tranquille.
Et puis, et puis on l'emmène avec nous.
Oui, oui, c'est ça.
Je prends les jambes
parce que je suis sportive.
Du coup,
je cale sur les épaules et j'aime.
Les gens d'avoir fait. Remarquer.
Du coup,
les gens vont rentrer bizarrement.
Vous inquiétez
pas, tout juste une vieille.
Femme qui est endormie
sur, c'est la grand mère.
Oui, dommage que. Les.
Autres qui dépendent a l'habitude de.
Circuler et.
Qui au lieu de rendez vous.
OK, vous arrivez,
vous rencontrez le marchand avec qui
vous avez donné rendez vous.
Il ne pose pas de questions
corps.
Vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'on a payé des gens.
Qui a la boucle d'oreille ?
Si on a payé, n'est ce pas monsieur ?
Chez le sportif qui est très habile.
C'est vrai qu'on a déjà payé.
Mais alors là, mais attendez comment ?
C'est possible qu'on a déjà payé ?
Alors que j'ai le souvenir
d'avoir vu ma main
tendue vers la vôtre.
Sans se serrer la main
pour se mettre d'accord.
Peut être ?
Oui, et de l'argent a été échangé.
Je n'ai pas reçu d'argent.
Mais si.
Vous êtes un roublard.
S'était mis d'accord et vous aviez
même dit Je viendrai avec votre.
Je vous ai dit non gentiment.
En ce moment.
Vous êtes contre les collègues.
Ecoutez, j'ai quinze.
Les bons comptes font les bons amis.
Vous nous amener à un. Marie-Lys
Quand on entend le compte de journées. De.
La moitié du chemin.
Si vous m'abandonner.
C'est qu'elle le distance.
Mon brave, en voiture, une bonne heure.
Non mais c'est bon.
Alors en voiture, un peu.
Vous aviez dit combien en 20 ?
C'est ça ? 30, 30 ans.
L'inflation, c'est terrible chez vous,
ça ne pardonne pas en une journée.
25 Et puis comme ça,
les vont contrôler vos amis.
Ce genre de marchandises.
À manger en marchant, les.
Marchands de ces petits.
Fruits, je me souviens pas.
34 Boum, boum, boum, ça.
J'accepte à 25.
Parfait.
Moi, j'ai dix.
Vous avez combien ?
Vous et moi ? J'ai 320 en poche.
J'ai rien. Je passe.
Et si jamais à la banque,
peut être parce que j'ai des dollars ?
Oui, oui, peut être ça, on peut.
Y a une banque.
Eh ben, je serais peut être en train.
J'ai gymnase 10€.
Ouais, on présente tout ce qu'on a.
Donc treize plus dix sous une machette.
Vous prenez. L'ancienne monnaie.
Vous avez que ça.
Dans la caisse. On a des objets.
Oui, il y a des ordinateurs magnétiques
ou si on a un splendide
microscope électronique à balayage
jamais utilisé aussi bien, on dirait.
C'est une suite du passé.
Voilà, c'est identique.
Après, c'est moins.
C'est
moins surprenant que tu viens du futur car
ça vient du passé.
Seulement. Avec moi même.
Parce que je.
Suis à 60
45, ça veut dire quoi ?
C'est bon, ça passe.
J'ai dit OK, j'accepte.
Un an, mais pour ce tarif là, par contre,
vous nous emmener là bas
et vous nous attendez sur place
et vous nous ramener après à l'Insee.
Et il nous offre le café avec un café.
Et. En blonde aussi.
Je veux bien vous faire
le trajet jusqu'à Adixia à 15€
si vous avez un nouveau besoin
que je vous transporte.
Ah oui.
Donc là, c'est qu'on me paye un microscope
pour aller à 12 h et à prix
prendre à quinze pour aller.
Alexia dans les quinze.
D'accord,
c'est bon.
Ok, mais on verra à Gaillard
ce qu'on fait.
Moi aussi
vous êtes pas là. Moi je fais mon plan.
Vous attendez
combien de temps par ailleurs,
vous repartez quand ?
Ça dépend quand j'ai écouler les stocks.
D'accord, donc on revient vous voir.
Et si jamais vous repartez
partir ensemble.
Ça va plus vite.
Là, on se serre.
La main, c'est l'heure d'y aller ou
moi je vais partir pour. Aller.
Qui récupère Toronto sur son stop.
Qui fait le fou dans son. Coffre ?
Prenez en soi.
Je lui file quelques la mince, sans plus.
Ça sert toujours.
C'est
parce que c'est pas moi non plus dans. Le.
Train en mode super,
un truc balayage machin.
Mais il sait pas ce que c'est que moi
non plus.
Mais là, convaincu que c'est
quelque chose qui me convient.
Mais ça marche. Déjouer d'avoir volé ça.
Par contre,
on laisse des traces de notre passage
chaque fois depuis le début.
Les archéologues sont jamais contents,
mais quand on laisse des traces, faut pas.
Faut pas casser le vase.
Terrible que ça va jouer.
OK, vous prenez la route vers six.
Heures, juste.
Pour vous écarter
du village. Pour trouver.
Vous connaissez un peu ça maintenant ?
Vous êtes dans le véhicule.
Vous vous y voyez vraiment ?
Pas grand chose.
Juste le véhicule
qui éclaire la route devant vous.
Le reste, moi, moi.
Et au bout d'un moment, vous vous
mettez en ronde des bruits
et vous vous faites arrêter assez vite.
Finalement,
une dizaine de minutes de trajet défini,
vous vous faites arrêter par un groupe
d'hommes
qui arrêtent le véhicule.
Le marchand qui vous a appelé comment vous
voulez qui s'appelle le marchand.
Sablier commandant le sablier.
Sablier le.
Surnom qu'on lui donne.
Le sablier baisse la fenêtre
et il y a un homme
qui s'avance vers le véhicule
qui dit bonjour, c'est pour la taxe,
c'est je regarde les gars
comment il est comme Google en terme
d'agressivité.
Pas très serein, mais ça va.
Moi je regarde Monsieur Chiche, fortiche
et à l'énonciation du mot taxe
pour voir comment il réagit
plutôt bien. Mais
oui, c'est vrai pour l'instant.
On verra bien.
Moi je regarde le sablier.
Comment ?
Parce que c'est pas moi qui vais la payer.
La taxe, c'est lui
qui va payer ce sablier.
Qu'est ce qu'il fait, monsieur sablier ?
Il sort, c'est son argent.
D'accord, il verse la taxe.
Très bien.
OK. Est ce qu'on peut regarder
à quoi ressemblent les gens qui demandent
les taxes ?
Oui, je. Sais.
À quoi. Je peux. Utiliser
plein de fois un jet. Nom.
Mais est ce
qu'ils ont un signe distinctif ?
Est ce qu'ils ont un habit ?
Quelque chose qui ressemble un peu aux
partisans de l'horreur dans leur façon de
s'habiller ?
Qui vous avez chopé en ville
pour la conquête des migrants ?
Oui, je voulais dire.
C'est sûr.
Qu'ils payent la taxe
et ils vous laissent.
Passer.
Ils ont regardé dans le véhicule ou
ils ont juste fait rire dans le véhicule.
Voilà, c'est un péage.
OK, ok, c'est un sablier.
Qu'est ce que c'est que cette taxe ?
C'est pour avoir la protection de là
même en partant de l'iris.
C'est elle
pour une taxe sur elle, sur l'utilisation
de tout le transit commercial.
Donc je vais m'en sortir.
Je pars pour aller vendre ma ville.
Pour d'accord, c'est
aussi votre problème ?
C'est un problème là ?
Moi, je suis là, au contraire.
On est les amis de l'orgue Hammond.
J'avais 20 ans.
On s'entend bien qu'on avait pas de
trois, une de plus.
C'est bizarre, regardez la.
Route.
Je suis juste de la conversation.
Très bien.
Vous continuez votre chemin jusqu'à
la mairie, vous finissez par arriver
au village en vous.
Vous arrivez à Marigny.
C'est un petit village qui est construit
sur le versant du mont Evens,
donc à l'opposé
de ton site de fouille de Gloria. Et.
C'est magnifique.
Tu peux me réveiller,
j'ai envie de me réveiller
entre temps. Oui. Je sais que.
C'est pas.
1 h de trajet en voiture.
C'est le temps de finir. Avec
très bien.
Et le village est entouré de gigantesques
champs et vergers
en tout genre
et au milieu de tout et de tous.
Cette vie paysanne. C'est pittoresque.
Je cherchais le mot.
Je suis atypique, je.
Suis curieux de tout autant que le podium
comme ça, très bien éclairé tout.
À son.
Oui, on voit que dalle.
Nous sommes allés voir
Hélène de Gaïa pour lui dire
que Céline a envie de la rejoindre.
Donc vous arrivez à l'entrée de
Dammarie Morel.
Vous vous rendez compte que le village,
une fois que vous
vous êtes un peu approché,
il est plus petit ?
Quirinus Il y a beaucoup moins de monde
dans les rues.
Est ce que ce n'est pas un peu le spa,
le point névralgique du commerce ?
Donc, forcément,
il y a juste les habitants qui
les habitent.
Les bâtiments ont tous
une allure très étrange,
un mix de vieilles bâtisses
améliorées avec nouvelles technologies
liées au podium.
Énormément de verdure
et des parterres de fleurs
jonchent les rues
et les murs des bâtiments,
ce qui donne un look très accueillant.
De manière générale,
les rues sont bordées de commerces
et d'ateliers d'artisanat
ou les habitants vendent les produits
qu'ils ont fabriqués eux mêmes.
Ça va vous plaire, ça ?
Il y a un groupe de garde,
c'est que des femmes qui vous arrêtent
ce qui arrête le véhicule qui demande un
laissez passer et ça vous dit
Bon bah moi, du coup, je vous laisse là,
je veux vendre des marchandises.
Et puis voilà qui vous fait
descendre du véhicule,
lui montrer un papier
et il continue son chemin.
Ah oui, ça
pouvait nous lâcher après.
Qu'il est bizarre.
Ce samedi. Il est parti.
Il vendait quoi ? Au fait ?
Est ce qu'on a su que le sablier ?
Retard pour demander le.
Bon. On avance
vers le groupe de personnes.
OK. Bonjour, bonjour.
Une belle journée n'est ce pas ?
Moi, ça va.
Il fait chaud, il fait chaud.
On vient,
on vient visiter un petit peu Amaryllis,
tout ça, voir comment ça se passe.
Quant à. Vous, la famille, ça.
N'est pas ici ?
Non, là, on est en train de faire le tour
du tour du monde niveau a pas de raison.
Un tour d'horizon.
Un tour d'horizon, c'est ça ?
Vous avez un
laissez passer pour entrer au village.
Un laissez passer de quel ordre ?
Avec l'autorisation des dirigeants ?
Non, mais c'est du tourisme, vous savez.
On est pas là, on est de passage,
c'est sur la route, on s'est arrêté.
C'est
pas possible de faire du tourisme ici.
Vous pouvez visiter les champs
si vous le souhaitez.
Mais si vous voulez
rentrer dans le village,
il vous faut un
laissez passer des dirigeants.
Est ce qu'on peut le dire ?
Comme on est souvent.
Il faut remplir un formulaire
est une demande,
ça prend quelques jours à être.
Est ce que vous ayez un rendez vous ?
Sauf si c'est une demande urgente.
C'est urgent. Oui, c'est vraiment pas.
Parce qu'on a entendu parler
du petit fromage de chèvre
de type roulé qui est vraiment
une spécialité de Marieville.
Et on avait très, très envie, urgemment
de le déguster, celui Cendré,
avec les braises de son chien.
Dans deux jours, il y en aura toujours.
Si je tourne, c'est
que je me tourne vers mes camarades.
Je leur dis Et sinon peut être,
on va visiter les champs,
on rencontre des paysans, on essaye de
prendre comme ça.
Les paysans et au.
Lieu d'intimider des gardes.
On se glisse dans leurs bottes de foin.
Et voilà, par exemple.
Sinon, on peut aller voir Gaïa
si on nous laisse pas rentrer un.
Peu, goûter à. Manger.
Et puis on va parler à. Hélène. Hélène.
Voilà. Parfait. Ouais, ouais.
Alors je me retrouve dans un lieu
et excusez moi,
il faut passer par le village.
Pour la guerre,
il faut forcément laisser passer
une autorisation spécifique.
En plastique parce qu'on
peut aller voir les dirigeants.
Du coup.
Les nouveaux dirigeants.
Si vous voulez demander une audience,
moi je peux vous prendre un rendez vous,
mais ça va prendre quelques jours.
C'est pas pratique.
Que ça veut dire qu'ils. Sont occupés.
Et mais sur le terrain sans force.
Et ils nous arrêtent.
L'année de prison.
On habile. Pas, on appelle time.
Tank.
Est ce qu'on n'aurait
pas un objet de négociations, dis je ?
Ah oui, des gens, il faut les acheter
en vrai.
On est beau chien, malade, s'il
vous plaît,
c'est urgent.
Regardez le pauvre bête Gégé,
je l'étrangle de la laisse
ou fouine, qu'est ce qu'on veut ?
Qu'est ce qu'on peut pouvoir faire
à cette pauvre bête ?
Mais je le sais pas,
c'est bien pour ça que je suis là.
J'aimerais voir abréger une vétérinaire
ou quelqu'un quoi.
Oui, je comprends bien,
mais vous allez devoir forcément passer
par les gardiennes, par les dirigeants,
mais très bien.
Mais que ça aille vite coiffé, comprenez,
je vais voir ce que je peux faire.
Merci.
Elles sont quand il y en a
une qui s'en va.
Les autres vous empêche de passer.
Vous êtes mis sur le côté.
Et puis il y a
le contrôle, le reste des
personnes qui rentrent et qui sortent
du village au bout de d'un petit moment.
Sauf si vous voulez faire
un truc entre temps.
Ici, qu'est ce qui rentre dans le village
de paysans, de paysans, travailleurs ?
Quelques véhicules, rien de particulier.
Pas entre eux,
donc on ne peut plus aller voir autour.
Tu prends un sablier, il aurait pu nous.
Prévenir. Tout ça.
Vous savez qu'il
y a des gardes à l'entrée de Marigny.
C'est qu'ils
vous le laisseront pas entrer.
Voilà, du coup c'est pas pratique. Qui.
Les gouvernent les comment s'appellent.
Dirigeants. Dirigeantes ?
Ils connaissent l'argent.
On peut peut être tenter ça de dire
en fait
on est en mission par le rouge
et attendez.
Mais si six hommes
pas en bons termes, c'est à Pierrier.
Vous voyez. Mais là, tout ça.
Il faut tenter le coup.
Vous connaissez ? Vous connaissez ?
Qu'est ce que vous ?
Ou alors est ce qu'il
y aurait pas des inspecteurs
qui pourraient inspecter à Marieville ?
Mais on est déjà arrivé
en disant les touristes.
Donc oui, mais. Attendant, c'est le chien.
On va tenter le chien,
on va voir ce que ça.
Donne, le chien, le chien du chien.
Je veux dire. C'est pas le sport.
Le seul truc qu'on peut faire, c'est
aller voir des paysans dans les champs.
Ben oui, c'est vraiment la dernière idée,
mais c'est comme ça.
Et on leur demande comment eux, ils ?
S'il n'y a pas un circuit
officiel ?
Ou alors sachez que je fais très bien
la morte.
Auquel cas ça pourrait être une urgence.
Si le chien normalement.
Après la vitesse qui vont bien
parce qu'ils ont l'air très très bizarre.
Formulaire.
Ça ce je n'en ai pas le formulaire.
La tuile
le chien club
Églantine et blanc,
c'est le circuit parallèle.
Paysages et plan D.
On creuse un tunnel. Creusé un trou. De.
Elle finit par revenir.
Elle vous dit.
Bon, visiblement, les dirigeants
ont déjà entendu parler de vous.
En tout cas, ont très bien décrites.
Enfin très très bien décrit.
Donc vous êtes convié tout de suite
et pour votre chien
vous allez devoir entendre,
de même. Que.
Je vais le surveiller.
Mais merci quand.
Même, c'était le voyage.
Oui, c'est très émotif.
C'est animal.
D'accord.
Mais merci de vous être renseigné.
C'est gentil.
Une déshydratation.
Elle vous emmène
à travers les rues de Marigny.
Le village, il est construit
sur le versant de la jument.
Oui, ça monte un petit peu,
surtout pour vous.
De là, ça va jouer aux bornes
en bonne forme encore.
Je vais quand même tordre
le bras de ce chantier.
Un Mettez votre montre sur Cardio et oui.
Ça aurait été utile. Et avec le sourire.
Parce qu'on est jamais aussi beau
que quand on fait du sport.
Et c'est vrai, c'est vrai que vous.
Prenez beaucoup.
De leçons.
De vie comme ça, qu'on s'attaque à 60 ans
plus encore à apprendre à cet âge là.
Mais si ça vous dit merci.
Une visite arrivée
tout en haut du village.
Il y a un espèce, l'hôtel de ville,
donc la gardienne vous fait rentrer
et vous amène dans une salle ou il y a
cinq femmes qui vous accueillent.
Bonjour et soyez le bienvenu
dans notre village à Paris
et merci de recevoir.
Un superbe merci.
Je fais une révérence bien bas.
On a déjà entendu parler de tout.
Ce petit monde.
Petit club.
L'absence, donc, c'est ce qu'on a compris.
Vous faites partie des Aigles Rouges ou.
Alors pas du tout et. Pas plus loin du.
Compte médecin. Si et voir.
Les gens que.
Je suis.
Vous n'aviez.
Plus ça chez vous
à 10 h, il y a eu ça d'informateur et.
Cette litterature vous entendez par régle
rouge de votre point de vue avant.
Cela ? d'Horizon.
Non mais nous,
on est des colombes blanches.
Oui. Nous, on est affilié à personne.
Des free et cinq jeux.
On les a ou on les a rencontrés sur mes.
C'est juste qu'on est dans une mission
un peu particulière qui est
qui verse vers le sauvetage de monde.
C'est top secret,
donc c'est une mission
que les éloges vous ont donné ?
Pas du tout.
Non, on ne.
Peut pas dire qu'il y a eu de
qui nous l'a donné, malheureusement.
Donc, à partir du principe, non.
Mais on est seul, on est seul
selon mission.
On est seul au monde.
Réellement et il faut qu'on le sauve.
C'est trop pour nos épaules.
24 Mais oui, oui.
Oui. Mais attends.
Ce n'est pas seul on.
Ils veulent pas sauver le monde.
Ils veulent juste vivre avec.
J'oubliais,
c'est là, c'était pas écrit ça.
Oui, c'est eux
qui voulait vendre, nous là.
Oui. Oui, c'est ici
qu'ils cherchent des solutions.
C'est des.
Scientifiques, j'imagine la nous.
C'est le truc.
Ils vont se retourner, ils iront le.
Jour. De fête.
Il faut continuer.
Nous sommes. Là, il a raison et.
On adore la médecine.
Si vous voulez.
On aime beaucoup ce que vous faites
ici, votre ville attachée aux conditions.
Et nous, c'est vraiment
ce qu'on cherche à faire parce qu'en fait.
On en peu pleine.
Céline, tout ça, Hélène ?
Hélène. Non, non,
ça c'est pour plus tard. En fait,
nous, on vient du monde avant qu'il y ça.
Est ce qu'on aimerait pouvoir faciliter
l'adaptation de la société ?
Alors attendez ! Lundi promet.
Ce jeu. C'est l'arme. Secrète botanique.
Voilà, c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire.
C'est bien botanique.
C'est mission secrète, botanique.
Botanique.
Et m'a confié C'est une MCB.
On m'a confié
la mission spéciale botaniste
de venir
apprendre de vous, de vos pratiques.
C'est bien simple pour.
Vous divulguer vos secrets.
Profiter des fins positives.
Mais je ne peux pas vous en dire plus
que les Aigles rouges.
Arrêtez avec les Aigles rouges !
Savez, je suis bien sûr.
Jamais en rouge.
Le voyant vert, je fais c'est rouge,
ça c'est vert.
On est les crapauds verts.
Nous aussi.
Moi, je fais le.
27 sur 40,
les crapauds vers le crapaud vert.
Mais après, tu crois.
Ne dites pas trop bien avec
ça. Vous venez d'ou ?
Je ne peux pas vous dévoiler
cette information.
Vous connaissez. Pas ?
Je ne souhaite pas répondre
à toutes vos questions.
Souhaitez
faire un partenariat avec notre village ?
Ha ben on en a pas de cinq dodos
un minimum.
Ah non, c'est pour notre sécurité.
Sans parler de partenariat.
Bah si vous voulez venir prendre.
Notre bébé,
vous voulez nous enfin vous donner ?
Oui, c'est pas donnant donnant.
Si vous êtes nos muse.
Nous fait de la prospection.
On vient toujours.
De prospection botanique.
Prospection positive.
On va référencer.
On sûr se nourrir.
De votre corps, de votre. Sagesse, de.
Votre, de votre adaptation,
de penser que vous, les crapauds
vert, n'avaient rien à offrir au monde.
Mais il y a désormais.
Des expositions magnifiques.
On veut.
Savoir, mais vous, justement,
on a tout. Essayé.
La MSB est un stade trop précoce.
Peut être que ce que nous verrons
chez vous, peut être que.
Voilà,
on pourra. Partager des choses avec vous.
Mais pour l'instant,
je préfère être honnête.
Je préfère ne pas vous mentir
et vous promettre la lune.
Vous voyez peut être pas ce que c'est
la lune.
Je ne veux pas vous promettre
le bout de la
ruelle, mais peut être que voilà.
Peut être que la collaboration officieuse.
Et après ?
Peut être que.
Est ce que vous pouvez nous exposer
un petit peu votre situation ?
Et peut être qu'on peut comprendre
parce qu'on est ouvert, on est des.
Messagers, on a.
Différentes expertises qui peuvent aider
quoi ?
Voilà, on est un petit peu.
Comment s'appelle cette émission là ?
Avoir
un mix entre les parents et les parents.
et les gens qui.
S'en. Viennent, qui peut très bien ?
Est il aussi la saison de. Gens qui.
Sont liés à l'émission
et l'équipe tous risques dont l'agence ?
Le risque ?
Ça ne fait de l'agence TV.
Voilà.
On a plein de compétences.
S'agrandir.
Comprenez que l'écran couvert,
on a une comedy.
Mon collègue, une expertise
dans de nombreux domaines et que.
Télévision.
Évidemment, n'est prêt à partager.
Mais à ce stade de la MSB,
on ne peut pas vous promettre
des choses
que vous êtes ici pour fonder
un partenariat de long terme.
Oui, vu, mais oui.
C'est très très très confus.
Je passe pour un con.
D'accord avec qu'est ce que,
qu'est ce que Maurice pouvait faire
pour vous dans ce cas ?
Ou faire confiance ?
C'est
comment
vous avez pu développer
une agriculture aussi florissante ?
Premier point de la MSB et ensuite
on nous a parlé de complexe scientifique
souterrain
et je peux pas vous en dire trop.
Mais c'est des choses qui pourraient
qui pourraient aller
avec nos propres projets
et sur lesquels on pourrait changer
et bâtir des relations
en autonomie.
Et puis sinon,
on a la recette du spatial ?
Merci. Oui.
Accessoirement.
On pourrait aussi
peut être.
Qu'on va peut être. Peut être peut être.
Faire un échange d'informations.
Mais peut être. Pas dire que ça. Va mal.
C'est un peu tard.
Non, non.
Et là, on parle de fossé entre vous.
Ça, il faut qu'on marchande. Petit
et c'est vrai.
C'est vrai que également
on a poussé nos recherches passer
de la recherche fondamentale sur
mais qu'est ce que le podium ?
Et nous avons des conclusions
assez avancées
qui pourraient éventuellement intéresser
un village aussi pittoresque et magnifique
et productif que le vôtre.
Disons qu'on n'est pas d'agrochimie, quoi.
Je fais un clin d'œil.
Avec.
De rigueur bizarre.
Si on pouvait rentrer en contact
avec vos scientifiques,
nous serions en mesure de vous donner
un peu.
Ce que vous m'avez dit.
Le laboratoire souterrain,
c'était une ancienne annexe
du complexe Gayant,
mais qui a été complètement abandonné.
Donc plus personne ne s'y risque.
Je me doute, mais c'est encore une fois,
je ne peux pas trop vous le dire.
Mais à des fins archéologiques, voilà,
on aimerait bien jeter un oeil.
C'est ça ?
On essaye de comprendre un peu
tout ce qui est processus
d'abandon.
Et de colonisation.
Recolonisation de la terre.
Ce fut un conseil de scientifiques,
un vieux bâtiment ?
Non, je pose la question tout de non.
Mais si on va à la lettre, on. Pourrait
peut être de Jean-Marie.
Messier. Non, mais je posais la question.
Je ne sais pas.
Moi, je réponds oui, sinon on pourra.
Vous s'emballe.
Des gens peuvent nous expliquer des trucs.
Voilà pourquoi vous dites,
vous disent pour nous,
ça va être compliqué de vous accompagner.
On a quand même
beaucoup de choses à faire.
On le faisait un.
Petit village, même.
Pas cinq, mais.
Peut être pas quatre.
On est non plus
d'accord, je trouve, pour aller se faire
une petite salade, vous comprenez ?
Mais c'est une même.
Par contre, si vous voulez
que quelqu'un vous accompagne
jusqu'à l'entrée de guerre,
c'est possible.
Ah bah oui,
ce serait charmant.
Mais c'est ça on là,
on est vraiment dans le cadre du tourisme.
Et j'ai l'impression.
Au moment ou vous dites ça,
il y a des ça, des cloches qui commencent
à sonner à l'extérieur du village.
Pittoresque enfoui dans. L'air.
Et ça résonne beaucoup. À. S'y pencher.
Non ? Beaucoup. C'est ça.
Et ça commence à un peu
s'agiter à l'extérieur.
Et les dirigeants commencent à un peu
un peu stresser et élever la voix, non ?
Ouais, ouais. C'est le.
Sénat, la, cela se.
Passe. S'il vous plaît.
Je ne sais pas plus que vous.
Je savais pas.
Stéphane Bern Il y a des cloches,
c'est l'alarme. Ah !
Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Mais je vais vous demander de sortir
et on continue cette discussion
un peu plus tard.
On va rester derrière vous ?
Oui, vous partez deux ans.
J'ai passé devant vous, je suis juste
bon. Bref.
Vous êtes libre de tout faire rapidement.
Un laissez passer.
Ça donne envie.
Vous êtes installé dans le village,
mais nous, on va travailler sur tout.
C'est très bien, merci.
Ah bah, on sent aussi et on regarde d'ou
vient l'agitation.
Alors, au moment ou vous sortez du village
à la ferme pour vous faire discuter
avec les gens, vous voyez que ça s'agite
beaucoup dans la rue,
qu'il y a des plus villageois qui courent
presque, qui se réfugient chez eux
sans faire mystère.
Certains, dans des bâtiments publics,
donnent une tornade.
C'est chez eux.
L'atmosphère est très bizarre,
ça sent le brûlé, c'est pittoresque.
Il y a des cendres qui tombent du ciel.
Je regarde, je.
Vois un. Bâtiment public le 1ᵉʳ mai.
Que vois je ?
Qu'est ce que tu veux voir ?
Une bibliothèque. Un cirque avec ?
Je vois une bibliothèque, pas
une bibliothèque, non.
Ça serait plus vers quelle bibliothèque ?
Alors je vois des écoles.
Un coin, ce serait bien, un bar, un bar.
La mise en jeu.
Des cloches que. Je vois.
Je vois une école, une école,
je vois une école.
Je dis allons nous réfugier dans l'école,
c'est pas scolarisés,
c'est dégueulasse ça, et on y va pas.
Moi, je suis dans l'école.
OK, il y a des enfants du coup
qui vous regardent un peu bizarrement.
Oui, mais ils vont cramer du
c'est super.
Est ce qu'on peut demander aux professeurs
ce qui se passe ?
Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
La maîtresse ? Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Et tenez vous tous
vos livres éducatifs sur.
Histoire qui
vous ignorez ?
Vous êtes comme. Ça.
On a laissé passer.
Du tourisme.
Mais d'une année professionnelle.
C'est à dire qu'on.
Met en valeur,
si on est en valeur, le village.
Choulika, ON et l'office. Du tourisme.
En les écoutant là.
Mais vous avez pas vu là
la pluie de son refuge chez.
Nous c'est pareil.
Mais c'est quoi vous ?
Vous n'avez pas un endroit ou allez.
Encore nous voir, donc. Pas.
Travailler,
nous expliquer. Ce qui se passe.
Qu'est ce qui se. Passe ? Je ne sais pas.
Vous, ce.
N'est jamais arrivé.
C'est. Non. Et les gens à ne pas paniquer.
S'ils sont enfermés chez eux.
Genre c'est mon pays.
Mais si oui.
Choisissez votre pause.
Je regarde par la fenêtre,
je regarde par les fenêtres.
Qu'est ce que je vois ?
Comment ça évolue, la situation ?
Je vois qu'il y a des gardiennes du cours.
Commence un volcan.
Un peu partout, un
gardien.
Qui court.
Suite à son mot de fin
à ce qu'il disait sur Pompéi
je regarde par une fenêtre
et je regarde le sommet du niveau.
Tu peux pas le voir ?
Bah non.
Mais écoutez, ils vont pas mettre
un générateur dans le cœur d'un volcan.
J'espère comme
ça se fait mal.
Tu sais.
C'est ouais, c'est
comme ça.
Il y a de la cendre
bien douce et de cendres.
Je sors le truc,
c'est pas possible, je suis un volcan.
Soit c'est une usine qui entre en jeu,
je mets la tête par la fenêtre
et je fais comme avec la neige.
Je sors la langue, j'essaie de Chopin.
Un flocon, est ce que ce serait pas
un méga feu ?
Ouais.
Du coup, je rentre
scène.
Merci Eglantine.
Je me suis senti.
Est ce que. Avez vous vu un méga feu ?
Ça fait feu !
Ce film est tout à fait vu, se fait.
Je pourrais jamais en parler.
Je pense que j'ai vu une.
Exposition dans mon passé.
Effectivement, c'était OK.
Les savoir
super exposition sur le feu, feu méga feu.
Et qui parlait justement
de toutes ces problématiques du feu
qui vont être d'actualité ?
C'était des souvenirs. Des uniformes
des pompiers.
Des uniformes de pompiers.
C'est un sacré délire.
Voilà, désolé de ça, clame t on.
Mais oui. C'est
comme si on ne savait. Rien.
Ces vêtements de pompiers protégés.
Est ce que je me tourne
vers les maîtresses ?
Qu'est ce que c'est de madame
maman ?
Un hibou qui retourne au retour
du domicile ?
Merci.
Je peux tourner.
Vers les enseignantes et je leur dis
vous auriez pas par hasard
une tenue de protection ?
Le tour de chauffe, monsieur Petit feu.
Elles ont 30
6 h, madame tout chaud.
Qui débarque sous le préau.
Du chien. OK.
Elle est un hub.
Qui va le retaper avant qu'ils causent
plus d'inconfort.
Bien sûr qu'on ne laisse. Pas
faire du fait qu'il est facile.
Non, mais c'est la fatigue,
la fatigue nerveuse, ça.
Est ce qu'on peut vous aider
pour faire quoi.
Que ce soit ?
Vous ? C'est bon.
Sauf si vous avez une idée de qu'est
ce que ça peut être le problème.
Connaissez, même si environnement.
C'est peut être que soi disant parce.
Que ça peut être le volcan
parce. Qu'il est actif.
Le volcan ou la montagne.
D'ailleurs.
Si ça fait 45, ça brûle pas une montagne.
Avec un balai, voici le volcan
ou que c'est pas le volcan.
Il y a peut être un film,
pas de volcan, peut être plus.
Les volcans endormis, les plaques, c'est
Clermont-Ferrand de partout.
Oui et maintenant il y.
De mettre de la géologie.
Des plaques tectoniques, y
une faille ouverte
par la chaleur.
Pour.
Regarder.
Les affleurements
et voir quels types de rochers apporte.
Une intensité sismique.
De dire que des nuages,
des nuées ardentes, il y en a,
on n'est pas là dedans, non sans mourir.
Non, mais autant c'est la forêt,
les craft, ils sont morts comme ça.
Est ce que de quoi les craft,
le couple n'ont pas la ?
Si les vols les amènent dans.
Le monde, c'est la vie. Et pour. Que ça
cesse, il y a. Tellement longtemps.
C'est la jeunesse.
Qu'est ce qu'il faut que ?
Qu'est ce qu'on.
Va. Rattraper par la nuit ?
Que peut occuper les enfants
en leur apprenant
les programmes de la télévision en 2030 ?
Et qu'on peut faire plein de.
Trucs et leur parler de motus.
Mais je sais pas, c'est vous le géologue.
Là, ça, vous parle pas ainsi. Moi je.
Tout juste une femme qui craint.
Autant les champs qui crament
à côté de pas des manifestations.
Ça à manifestation. Aussi.
Ouais, c'est beaucoup de fumée.
Est ce que de Wannehain on voit jusqu'ou
les gardiennes elle court.
Rament.
Parce qu'on voit un attroupement
de gardiennes, une grosse lumière ?
Vous voyez que, lorsque tu regardes
les gardiennes,
elles commencent à demander de l'aide
aux habitants.
À faire quoi ?
Mais vous, vous savez,
vous voyez juste que les gardiennes.
Va demande.
Ou va aider.
On y va et.
On a. Besoin d'aide.
Moi je dis sens chaîne humaine.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, c'est un incendie.
C'est un incendie. Pas oui.
Et puis il y a les pompiers, peut être
pas les pompiers dans
un si petit village
qui commande des services de base.
Le seul problème, c'est
qu'on ne sait pas ouvrir le feu.
Est ce qu'on peut passer un coup de fil ?
Il y a plus de sel.
Je vais demander à l'audience.
Je cherche un commissaire.
Ce que c'est comment ?
Comment ?
On ne peut pas joindre un autre village.
Donc, est ce qu'il
y a un nombre de fontaines quelque part,
un bassin, une bassine d'eau,
quelque chose ? Il y a un puits ?
Je comprends bien. Plus. Mais est ce.
Qu'on peut prendre le chien
appuyé dessus dans le met dans le puits ?
Et comme ça.
C'est un puits d'eau et un tremplin.
En tube juste.
En dessous.
Et ce qui s'est passé.
Dans les champs,
ils font des chaînes humaines ou pas.
Est ce qu'on voit ?
Ils ne voient pas l'incendie,
mais les champs, ils sont bien éclairés.
Les champs, ça va.
Les champs
Montjoie c'est pas les champs. En fait.
On voit que ce n'est pas vrai. Nous,
on peut courir partout avec nos torches.
Et si tout vient, l'incendie s'est emballé
tandis qu'il n'a pas besoin de lumière.
Personne. Oui.
Bien sûr.
C'est du chat. Le feu. Il ne fait pas
de lumière.
Il y a que le cyclisme
qui fait la lumière. Ouais.
Ouais, mais c'est vrai.
Aurait on peut être le feu ?
Tu ne vois pas à quoi ?
Mais la chaleur. Oui.
Ah oui, oui, mon petit train proche.
Comment vous faites
pour trouver ces incendies là ?
Je ne fais pas de lumière,
je parle à la garde.
C'est Est ce que vous voulez
pas faire le. Chien.
Chercher à la chaleur chaud froid ?
J'ai aussi froid, mais le chien peut être.
Ceci a fait très chaud.
Ça produit,
ça produit du vent normalement,
sans la chaleur,
elle fait des déplacements d'air.
Mais alors pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? C'est moi qui parle de ça ?
Je sais pas.
Quoi.
Il y a l'odeur, il y a la sensation
chaud et il y a les cendres.
Dans une direction parce que.
Mieux, ce chien de la peur.
Bon. Est ce qu'on vous coloriage ?
Je fais un jeu de perception
pour trouver le feu.
C'est quoi la méthode ?
Du coup, je prends la torche,
je regarde voir si je vois
du carbone
du carbone, du carbone,
des signes de calcination, quoi.
Sur les choses du gaz ?
Ouais, de la suie, quoi.
Tu sors quoi sur nous ?
Tu sors de la zone éclairée ?
En bref,
je prends Eglantine avec moi.
Allez, viens !
OK, fais un perception, mais
on lève toi
le corps couvert.
Une perception. Années 40 et je. Me lève.
Il n'y a pas que le défi.
Qui. Est là.
94 Oh yes !
Tu es persuadé
que tu vas dans le bon sens, mais
t'es sûr et certain
que tu as trouvé la source et tu avances.
Il est là le feu et il est là.
Regardez ce roi, il est là le feu.
Moi je partir avec Eglantine
à toute vitesse dans une direction du feu.
Il y a quelques gardiennes qui te suivent.
Il est là.
Bas le feu.
Est ce que les gardiennes ou est
ce qu'on court après ?
Il faut l'éteindre.
Y a pas moyen de se.
Regarder en. Soi.
Il y a de la suie. De ce qu'on a.
Mais parce que chercher va.
Chercher le silence un peu de vie là,
et on sent la chaleur.
Je sens une chaleur au sol.
Non ?
Oui, prenez.
Votre grande surface chaude,
mais qu'est ce qui peut prendre feu ?
C'est
un endroit ou il y a une activité de feu.
C'est un an, il fait chaud,
ça fait très chaud,
ça peut être la sécheresse, ça peut être.
Il y a des, il y a des forêts pas loin.
Vous êtes dans la forêt ?
Oui, surtout dans la forêt.
On est dans la forêt.
Mais oui, il y a plein.
Est ce que les gardes,
les gardiennes, on peut pas leur parler,
pas leur demander ?
Il n'y a personne qui crée le feu.
Là, il y a déjà des incendies
dans le coin. Non.
On ne peut pas envoyer les enfants du.
Bâtiment ou quoi, mais c'était là.
Il n'y a pas de bâtiment dans le coin
qu'on sache.
Là, dans la forêt, il n'y a pas ça.
Ou alors on peut pas aller en long
en haut du mont.
Oui, oui, tranquillement.
Mais je sais pas je.
Qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
Est ce que moi je peux ?
Là, j'ai compris que le feu n'est
pas là, a priori avec moi.
Je regarde ça des personnes,
mais les autres, il commence à douter.
Les gardiens me disent non.
Est ce qu'il
y a des animaux qui je regarde ?
Il y a des animaux qui courent, genre
des petits mulots, des trucs.
Vu que vous êtes dedans dans une zone
très petite.
C'est très bruyant.
En fait, il vous y en a,
ils vont, vous éviter quoi qu'il arrive.
Ils ont peur de vous ? Oui,
mais ils fuient les flammes.
Si je suis les flammes, ils vont
s'en foutre de passer entre vos jambes.
Non mais ils vont faire un petit décalage
pour éviter quoi ?
Du coup, tu as vu que toi
tu vois que à deux mètres de toi ?
Ah oui ok, avec la torche.
Est ce que je peux entendre le feu
et changer de perception ? Ils trouvaient.
Toi t'as fait un échec critique,
donc meurtre.
Christophe est persuadé que c'est
dans une direction et c'est raté.
Les autres, il peut faire des choses.
Je peux faire un
jeu de perception, c'est ça.
Il faut le faire.
C'est quoi ta méthode ?
Non, ce serait le son,
je pense.
Ou l'odeur, on sent ça sans nom.
Mais. Moi, je pense qu'on leur.
Dit non, ça étouffe.
Du trouver le feu.
Et le problème il réagit pas au feu.
Ce c'est du gaz.
C'est de la combustion, réagit pas.
Au feu. Ici.
Il nous fait une flèche,
mais peut être ça.
Sur la façade.
Franchement, si le faire
c'est de l'oxygène, ils vont à moi, je.
Divise après 20 te8 alors que là chui.
Ok. J'ai une idée complémentaire.
C'est quoi ton idée ?
Complètement,
c'est que le feu ça consomme de l'oxygène.
Oui, le podium ça brûle.
Donc potentiellement,
ça consomme de l'oxygène aussi.
Si, si, ça brûle comme ça.
Donc mon idée, c'est d'aller
donne des directions et de voir
quand la flamme de nos torches,
elle, commence à baisser.
Ça veut dire qu'il
y a moins d'oxygène dans.
L'air,
mais ça veut dire que tuer dans le feu.
Son. Approche du feu, quoi.
Je pense
qu'on sentira a ce moment là. Oui.
Oui, c'est oui, c'est ça.
Je suis en feu maintenant.
Sais que je suis concierge. Moi
je suis pas validé, mais je pense que
je pense pas que ça
consomme à ce point de l'oxygène.
Je sais pas, j'avais entendu
un premier message dans un couloir.
Du coup, tu t'écoutes bien malgré
Pierre-Alain qui dit maison, c'est par.
Là, je t'assure, c'est pas la balle.
Il faut.
Juste l'impression
d'entendre des bruits crépitement au loin,
mais pas du tout dans la.
Direction que vous allez par là, là.
Et voilà. OK.
C'est parce que tu vois à peu près
dans quelle direction il y a du feu,
mais c'est pas au.
Petit va du coup
là bas, non, non, non,
on va pas aller vers le feu.
Tu peux, tu peux nous indiquer.
Ben moi,
j'ai l'impression que ça vient de par là.
Quoi,
tu peux
qu'on s'appelle vers le générateur.
Moi, j'irais vers un endroit qui
fait quelque chose.
Mais là, le générateur, c'est super
et c'est loin.
Le générateur. De. Bombe
qui vient de Gaïa.
Le feu vient de Gaïa, non ?
Gaïa, quand c'est abandonné.
Oh non. Non,
il y a une annexe de Gaïa qui abandonne.
C'est pas Gaïa qui crame comme moi je.
Sais pas ou Gaïa.
On demande à la gardienne
elles sont Sandra et les gardiennes,
on dit c'était n'importe quoi,
ce qui est. Reste dans.
Écouter parce que si c'est Gaïa, c'est
pas aussi Gaïa.
Si elles nous disaient à part le large
avec que la direction.
Elle a trouvé le feu ou pas, pas.
Compris la direction du feu.
Ouais,
mais vous n'êtes pas obligé d'y aller.
C'est la
ce que vous faites dans votre base.
Le film tourné,
ça crépite comme des arbres, quoi.
Ce serait comme une forêt qui qui brûle.
C'est pas un manteau de forêt,
c'est dans quelle direction ?
Et si c'est pas les champs ?
Vous vous référez pas spécialement.
À ce que
tandis que la direction, moi j'y vais, moi
je dis qu'il faut aller vers Gaïa, mais.
Qu'est ce qu'on va faire ?
Mais par contre je sais pas,
je sais pas ce qu'on fait là.
Je serais d'avis
de retourner vers le village.
Sinon on se protège, on se protège,
on est en crise.
On peut peut être juste leur dire
ou a le feu.
Du coup, si t'es sûr que.
Oui, on revient au. Village.
OK, le feu est là. Bah oui,
je pense pas une décision.
Vous êtes les gens
qui crient au feu, au feu
et puis il n'y a pas de feu,
mais c'est pas grave.
Moi je refais tout le trajet
inverse de Pierre-Alain.
Du coup, c'est
quand même marcher loin dans une direction
parce qu'il avait l'air très sûr de lui.
Après,
vous faites tout
le trajet inverse
et vous voyez, en rentrant dans la zone
éclairée de Dammarie, qu'en fait le feu.
Il est en train de s'attaquer aux gens,
que c'est bon ou là en fait, maintenant
on voit visionner le feu effectivement
de la forêt de la direction que tu voyais.
C'était jusque là
et il a commencé à se propager.
Nous allons dans des bassines,
on arrose le feu.
Ouais, faisons quelque chose.
Il sait pourquoi vous êtes pompier.
C'est quoi votre méthode ? Si moi. Avons.
D'autres méthodes, c'est de leur demander.
Elles sont les lances à eau ça.
Mais vous êtes pas préparés.
Est ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut faire
de l'abattage de végétal préventif là ?
Est ce qu'on peut être préventif ?
Du coup, pendant qu'ils réfléchissent,
moi je prends une bassine, je suis.
Il faut la faire à la maison
qu'il faut abattre toute la ville.
Alors il y en a toujours qui font pareil
que toi.
Petit à petit,
vous éteignez, mais c'est un peu long.
Et Jaro aussi les façades des maisons
qui sont les plus proches de feu.
Ah ouais, si c'est
pas bête ça que tu faisais ça.
À l'époque, il.
Faut fermer les fenêtres,
mettre des torchons
et des serpillère mouillé en bas.
Merci.
Je le sais,
je le. Répète en criant aux habitants.
C'est 100 fois
là, torchon mouillé sur les vitres.
Vite.
Mais normalement,
il faudrait abattre toute la ville.
Ça je leur dis pas si.
C'est ça, je.
Le garde pour moi, il pour sauver la vie.
Voilà, j'en profite. C'est un paradoxe.
J'en profite aussi pour mouiller le chien.
Une fois que vous allez.
Trempés évacuer, appelez moi.
Mais si jamais
il va dans les flammes comme ça.
Oui, si je suis fou.
Qu'est ce qu'on fait, nous ?
Du moins, sinon ça ? Du coup,
elle est en train de déteindre.
Pendant. Dix ans.
C'est donner des informations aux gens.
Est ce que toi t'as
envie de faire quelque chose ?
Non, je fais rien, on attend.
Tu surveille pas ?
Oui, sinon, mais je.
Suis là en réserve
car tu sais combien les arbres.
Il y a plus de réserves.
Là, on est en urgence. OK.
Ça marche bien cette opération.
Bassines, ça, ça a été un doucement.
Ils sont beaux, voilà.
Alors que tu as une bassine au vide le le.
Puis ok.
Bon, si vous faites rien de plus au bout
d'un an, finissez par
pas réussir à contenir le feu.
Donc ils veulent juste continuer
à se propager un peu dans la forêt.
Ne plus pour ça, ils ont au moins réussi
à sauver les champs
ou une grande partie de ceux là.
Les gens vous remercient.
Ce que vous êtes comme des étrangers
vous dis
merci
quand même d'avoir mis la main à la pâte.
Nous, on a juste gueulé pour dire
vous étiez pas obligés,
vous auriez pu vous cacher
ou ils n'ont jamais fait ça.
On est un petit peu.
Y avait de ça, on a couru.
Vers le danger.
Et du coup on peut discuter avec les.
Habitants.
Ils sont sympa maintenant. Ouais.
Et on peut. Vous savez d'ou ça vient.
C'est ce qui a provoqué le feu.
Une idée chez Super chaud à défaut
d'attendre
que la chose du passé
c'est jamais arrivé ? Non.
Il fait jamais aussi chaud.
C'est vrai
que c'est particulièrement chaud.
Comment ça se fait, vous savez ?
Non, c'est bizarre parce que.
Vous avez entendu parler du réchauffement
climatique ?
Pas spécialement.
Vous êtes
notre problème
que le réchauffement climatique.
C'est vrai. Que fait une.
Serviette.
Avec un peu plus chiant que.
Vous et.
Longue.
Mais vrai que ceci ne reflète pas la vie
de toute l'équipe.
Dans le voyage.
Mais c'est vrai que qu'il fasse tout noir
tout le temps, c'est vrai que ça va être
un peu dur. Surtout au début.
Surtout si, en plus du réchauffement.
Climatique, oui, c'est vrai
que ça marche.
Va guérir.
Du coup on ira vers Gaïa. Oui.
Mais on se fait accompagner par des.
Il y a déjà bien des villageois
qui vont nous accompagner ici.
On dit on va aller. Ah bah oui, génial.
Ils ont rien d'autre à faire.
Vous vous discutez. Tout.
Et puis il y a une gardienne qui vous dit
Ah bah moi je voulais faire un rapport
pour leur dire que c'est bon,
c'est confus.
Donc si vous voulez vous poser
deux questions.
Venez donc.
Pendant qu'on marche. Pourquoi il y a ?
Pourquoi il y a que des bonnes femmes
à la direction et dans l'armée ?
Je demande si vraiment bonne femme, oui,
je dis bonne femme, oui, ça l'énerve
vraiment.
Si ça vous pose un problème ?
Pas du tout.
Ah, je peux vous dire que moi, Joséphine,
elle aurait adoré faire votre travail.
C'est ma femme,
Joséphine.
Bon, d'accord,
mais je suis curieux, je trouve ça bien.
Il faut passer.
Préfet de montagne.
Mais bon, c'est pas ça le débat.
Pas sûr que votre avis compte beaucoup.
Non, pas du tout.
Mais du coup, pourquoi ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Je vous le dis.
Pas d'accord,
il n'y a pas de raison particulière.
Si un homme voulait devenir gardien,
c'est possible, non ?
Donc c'est il y a une loi et c'est tout.
C'est comme ça,
on ferait bien des lois areas.
Avant de vous poser.
Pas de problème à l'époque.
Alors c'est quoi les camps ?
Quand on est à Rome, on est à Rome.
Il y a un dicton un peu comme ça.
Il faut les chemin maintenant.
C'est pas celui là, c'est le truc.
Quand tu arrives dans une ville,
tu viens quand tu arrives dans une.
Moment comme. Un Romain.
Voilà, ça c'est du genre
je vois que c'est normal,
on pose pas de questions,
on fait comme ils font et c'est parti.
Moi, je fais ça, je dis ça.
C'est bien chez.
Moi, comme à Rome.
Comme à Rome.
Et. D'accord.
Mais vous voyez quand même
que, comme dit, c'est un peu comme
s'il y avait eu des hommes.
Moi je serais
à Rome.
Oui, mais s'il y a eu des gardiens, voilà,
je dis ça.
Je dirai.
On lui tire la manche, peut être.
Sur la mer, vous avez pas besoin
de retrouver votre chemin.
Alors sachez pour votre gouverne que j'ai
de très beaux sens de l'orientation
pour vous rendre.
À des endroits que vous ne connaissez.
Puisque j'ai été exclu exprès
il y a un. Mois de révérence.
Mais il n'y a pas d'animosité.
Allez, on le. Prend tous les jours parce.
Qu'il y a un moment.
Sinon 26.
Moi dis.
Je sais de quoi vous poser question.
Et l'édition qui va.
Ça va pour des scientifiques,
vous n'êtes pas très curieux.
Que plus rien dire. C'est
un petit peu.
Pas trop compris.
Alors moi je trouve. Ça
très bien ce qui. Arrive.
À là ou pas.
Vous finissez par arriver en Guyane.
Après maintes discussions.
D'abord, juste sur le chemin,
vous croisez une espèce de bâtisse, ouais
ou d'ailleurs.
La gardienne,
elle trouve ça bizarre parce que
d'habitude, elle prend pas seulement deux
Amaryllis jusqu'à Gaïa.
Là, vous avez pris un espèce de raccourci,
vous êtes tombés devant une bâtisse
et en fait, devant cette bâtisse,
il y a un groupe de gardiennes
qui sont en train de sortir des gens de.
Gentiment, violemment.
Un peu violemment ou qui sont attachés en
train de les embarquer dans un véhicule.
Alors que vous remarquez.
Que tous les gens qui se font embarquer
ont une boucle d'oreille en forme de.
S'appliquer
à. Alors là, surtout ne rien dire.
Oui, bonjour, mais bonjour mesdames.
Il ne faut pas se faire poser des
questions.
J'ai posé avec un.
Question là.
Bas, je pense que là, il faut observer.
Et quand tu.
Le fais debout. OK,
tu approche proche d'elle ?
Oui, elle vous dit.
Les gardiens disent
circulez, c'est pas votre problème.
Pas d'accord.
Et il y en a un de ceux qui sont
en train de se faire remarquer.
Quand ils vous voient, ils se figent.
C'est celui que vous allez croiser ça ?
Oui, la.
Personne qui dit c'est eux, c'est eux
qui font qui faut arrêter.
C'est eux qui vont détruire le monde.
Ils vont créer un paradoxe.
Et au moment ou il dit ça,
il y a une gardienne qui lui remet
une et qu'il le balance dans le véhicule.
Elle ferme les portes
et elles sont complètement taré ce type.
Il est toc, toc.
Toc toc !
Mais vous faites bien de le dire.
Et j'en profite pour me remettre
le bandeau en place et en même temps
je fais un doigt d'honneur à la voiture
qu'ils sont.
Pourquoi ils ont tous
déshabillé dans l'oreille
quelqu'un ?
Est ce que quelqu'un veut faire
changer de perception ?
Une seule personne.
Qui sait, qui est perspicace. Qui est moi.
Je suis perspicace.
70 de perspicacité, 40 perceptions.
80 aille. En disant.
Quelqu'un d'autre peut faire 60. 5%.
Mais j'avais dit une seule personne à. 89.
Qui. Est perception.
Bon moi
j'ai un super, même si je suis le perso.
Percepteur, je ne vois rien.
Non, au moment ou en fait elles
vont refermer la porte de la bâtisse,
il y a Clotilde Gloria
qui a jeté un coup d'œil dans la bâtisse,
dans la bâtisse, mais elle n'a
pas eu le temps de voir quoi que ce soit.
Pas très habile avec ces gens.
Je prends,
je m'adresse à une des gardiennes.
On se rapproche du bâtiment.
Je leur dis
vous avez bien fait de vous arrêter.
Cela,
vous les connaissez vaguement.
Je n'ai entendu parler.
Mais quand ?
Et qu'est ce qui s'est fait de mal ?
Le clan des sangliers, les petits.
Le clan des sabliers a fait.
Tuer les. Gens.
Je connais pas beaucoup mais j'ai entendu
dire qu'ils faisaient des trucs
comme le clan des Sabliers.
C'est comme ça que Didier les appelle
après Didier ?
Oui, oui.
Qu'est ce qui est ce que Didier
pourrait répondre à nos questions ?
Pose Valls.
Vous savez, Didier trois,
il a souvent un coup dans le pif.
Oui mais si Didier a l'air
de connaître ce clan des sabliers, alors.
Je pense que c'est héréditaire
et qu'il faut aller voir un.
Cerveau. Pour vous pencher sur. Nous.
On vient de Syrie dix.
Janvier,
mais bon, on a et il les appelle le clone.
Tout ça, je veux dire.
Le lendemain, il les appellerait
Henri, le Saint Germain, quoi ?
Il n'est pas
d'accord, mais.
Il se trouve qu'ils ont un sablier.
Mais apparemment ils sont.
C'est bien le bon boulot, d'accord. Bon.
Bonne journée
à vous aussi.
Et c'est bien.
Ok, continuons.
Alors on va Yehia.
Ok, vous continuez le chemin.
Attends, juste avant de continuer,
je demande.
Je me retourne vers l'une des gardiennes.
Je dis Excusez moi, est ce que je peux
juste un petit coup
d'œil à l'intérieur de la bâtisse ?
Parce que vous voyez, je cherche un T3
et je voulais savoir
si ce sera assez spacieux
parce que je trouve ça
vraiment, vraiment charmant
et pittoresque par chez vous.
Vous êtes sûr que. Pour l'instant.
Pourtant, j'ai plein de choses
qui pourraient vous intéresser ?
Peut être que c'est là,
ce n'est pas pour votre entreprise.
Vous cherchez des locaux ?
Oui, vous aviez. Dit Voilà le dit. Pour.
Le développement économique de la région.
Je saute un petit peu comme ça
rapidement pour voir un peu
la superficie des locaux, les dirigeants.
Les dirigeants.
Elle est là.
Elle avait 18.
Bâtisses par là bas
qui pourraient peut être un mentir.
Pour moi.
Je suis à 75,
78. Ha.
Est ce qu'on vient appuyer son propos ?
Elle refuse, elle dit non, désolé.
Pour l'instant, ça,
c'est potentiellement électrique.
Ah d'accord, plus ça m'intéresse.
Le cri des gens qui est familier.
Non, monsieur.
Vous faites un crime de la pensée,
c'est juste.
Oui, enfin, on est quand même là
pour le tourisme. Oui.
Ah si.
C'est pour le tourisme macabre, on.
Doit l'indiquer dans notre guide.
Ah oui, c'est vide.
Une bâtisse avec des crimes.
Combien d'être fou,
combien de fois pour un.
Crime sur cinq ?
Vous voulez pas voir la superficie du
des locaux pour votre guide ?
Ça que si on pouvait avoir un petit récit
à se mettre sous la dent.
Ah bah oui.
Donner envie.
Comment des héroïnes ?
On a arrêté le clan des sabliers
qui terrorisait la région
et qui mettaient le feu.
Le gang des gardiennes, un.
Gang des gardiens. De John Ridley.
Les, les.
Les héroïques gardiens.
Les héroïques gardiennes.
Voilà.
Dites moi tout, c'est le journaliste.
Alors plus que ça, notre.
Guide touristique
qui va vous amener beaucoup
de retombées économiques dans votre.
Région de proximité.
Dans ce cas, si ça vous intéresse,
je vous invite à venir
discuter à la caserne tout à l'heure.
Mais pour l'instant, il faut qu'on
s'occupe de elle se trouve la caserne,
dans le village, dans le village.
OK, ce.
Temps là.
Est bon boulot.
Merci. OK.
Vous suivez le chemin jusqu'à Gaillard.
Une fois que vous arrivez à Gaillard,
c'est juste ce grand bâtiment en fer.
La porte est fermée.
Évidemment.
Et en tant que numéro.
54 zéro zéro zéro zéro.
Ça frappe à la porte la là.
Perso il y a des gardiennes qui arrêtent,
qui accueillent la personne qui touche
gardienne, qui est avec vous,
qui vous dit bonjour.
Qui jour. A nous ? Oui.
Le SAMU.
Nous venons pour une MSB.
Une mission secrète au Botanique.
Voilà, nous avons un
laissez passer de la part des dirigeants
pour peut être établir
un partenariat en terme de recherche
britannico agricole.
L'eau economico est qu'il
ne faut pas aller au couteau,
abandonnant au bâti souterrain
ce qui arrive au prix
de ce que vous avez laissé passer
le montrer. Bien sûr.
Il n'a pas brûlé. Si je
je serai.
OK, d'accord.
Bon bah bienvenue à Gaïa.
Peut être il y aurait un.
Sens de l'accueil me laisse.
Pantois. Peut être est ce que oui.
Alors oui, ça c'est
une vieille connaissance.
Mais est ce que se souviendra ?
Excusez moi peut être une Hélène,
ça vous parle ?
Une copine fac, quoi ?
Une copine de fac, vous madame ? Oui, oui.
Et juste
au dessus, c'est pas grave,
on ne va. Pas à.
L'école. C'est vous ?
C'est
l'école, ça ? Oui. Centre de formation.
Bien sûr.
Ce que vous lui dites ? Quitter
son bureau, peut être.
Ou lui dire qu'on est là ?
Oui, bien sûr. Nous a dit,
lui, qu'on vient de la part.
Non, non, non. On va y aller.
Non, pas de la part de rien.
Non, non, de rien du tout, de nous.
Auquel vous amène
vous passez un peu dans les couloirs.
Toi, tu remarques que ça,
il y a la construction.
Elle ressemble un peu à Adixia,
l'air de rien, c'est vrai.
Genre c'est un peu structuré
de la même façon, c'est juste quand même
sur le même tracteur, on s'est fait autour
d'un grand jardin central.
Et oui, c'est pour les plantes.
Est ce qu'on le voit le jardin
éclairé ?
J'aimerais bien aller voir le jardin pour
plus tard.
Tu peux voir, mais ce que tu voulais,
vous le voyez à travers des vitres.
Moi, j'ai eu plus tard
je me dire putain.
C'est leur source de spoliant, mais
en fait c'est vert, c'est leur recette.
Bah oui, amaryllis, oui non.
Mais eux c'est des scientifiques
qui ont une autre méthode, ça ?
Une autre.
Ouais mais je.
Suis peut être.
OK en.
Espérant arriver auprès d'Hélène.
Du coup, qui vous accueille ? Qui vous dit
bonjour ?
Bonjour Hélène.
Hélène, ma petite Hélène,
ça fait plaisir de voir.
Enfin non de la part de celle ci.
Mais pourquoi est ce que je dis
que c'est la bagarre ?
C'était pas secret ?
Non, c'était une histoire d'amour,
s'entend.
Mais je suis parti à Paris.
On est juste avec elle, non ?
En fait, au début, non.
Mais en fait, quand vous commencez
à chuchoter, ça fait un signe.
Regardez qui avec vous ?
Qui s'en va du coup ?
OK et tu parles de la radio ?
Je donne le micro.
Tu fais ça,
tu vas te dire si
ça se.
Peut que je suis shooté.
Votre ami.
Là dedans, c'est sais la.
Glace. En plus, il est un peu limité.
Il faut pas trop lui.
Donc ça vient de la part de Céline.
En fait, on était,
on était à Alexia et Céline.
Vous connaissez Céline ?
Oui, oui, et bien
vous le volume qui est les malheureuses
et vous les manquez beaucoup.
Et on l'a trouvé en train
d'admirer sa bague, une belle bague
quand j'ai pas noté en quoi c'est.
Juste un. Rouge ou une pierre rouge.
En rubis.
D'accord.
Et et elle voulait que qu'on vous dise
de sa part que
elle est très malheureuse
et qu'elle a très envie de vous rejoindre.
De me rejoindre. Elle a fait son choix.
On part après,
on ne peut pas parler pour elle.
Oui, oui, comprenez la position délicate
dans laquelle nous sommes.
Oui, mais je sommes juste des messagers,
c'est non.
Je ne sais. Pas
qu'elle. A sûrement fait son choix,
sinon elle aurait envoyé personne.
Oui, oui, on l'a rencontrée, c'est tout.
Nono Noël, c'est envoyé
et elle nous a demandé
de vous demander
de nous accompagner dans le complexe.
Et dans l'escalier.
Vous pouvez enfin enfin nous aider.
C'est une vieille connaissance de madame.
Elle aimerait vous rejoindre,
mais elle veut s'assurer que le complexe,
il est hors norme.
Il n'y a pas de danger
et donc elle nous a dit ça, c'est tout.
Ben oui.
Oui, oui, je la connais.
Pas dans mes films ici.
C'est
un sacré.
Frédo.
Je vous confie la tâche de vous assurer
que le complexe il est hors normes,
que la RT2012 est respectée,
que les normes
ISO 9712 elles sont en place.
Dans ce cas, j'accepte de.
Quitter vos sentiments.
Par contre on s'en fout.
Monde c'est Céline, c'est Céline.
Il y a le travail, le travail.
C'est un bourreau de travail.
Du coup, on avait.
J'aimerais commencer par les souterrains
parce que c'est toujours les
faiblesses des bâtiments, les souterrains.
Vous voulez parler de l'annexe
de l'annexe ?
C'est pourquoi elle a abandonné.
Je demande parce qu'elle est
un peu construite, un peu trop loin
et que ça ne servait pas à grand chose
pour les recherches sur les plantes.
Mais allons y et vous allez vous raconter
sur moi je suis tout rentre dedans.
Ce que c'est, c'est
complètement désaffecté,
c'est super dangereux
pour accompagner vous ? Bof.
Je ne suis pas si utile
qu'on y est vraiment tous.
Parce que si vous voulez y aller vraiment
pour vérifier, vous pouvez m'aider.
Oui, moi je t'envoie ici.
Sinon, on fait la balade.
Normal, quoi ?
Céline m'a confié de vraiment bien être.
Ça m'a dit C'est, c'est de l'ennui.
Elle m'a dit.
Vous. Frédo. Que vous soyez.
Frédo, Beastie
Boys ou si vous voulez qu'on aille,
qu'on aille à cette annexe
à 20 minutes à pied.
Ben on peut y aller si n'est pas.
Obligé d'y aller tout de suite
après, on peut faire.
Je pense que ça peut être important
quand même.
Oui, je veux dire que ce soit 20 minutes
tout de suite
ou 20 minutes dans 30 minutes.
Si on se sépare,
c'est chacun notre aventure
et on se donne rendez vous dans 1 h.
Ici, quand.
Je parle à l'abri à mes camarades,
c'est
qui étiez attendu dans les souterrains ?
Oui, après, vous allez ou vous voulez,
mais théoriquement,
la lettre était c'était.
Ainsi de l'histoire.
C'est
vous savez, moi j'ai des absences
d'y aller.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Ecoutez, Alain
propose de changer complètement.
On ne peut. Passer par le jardin,
peut être.
Et puis.
C'est faut qu'on.
Écoute les petits jeunes
parce que nous, on assure plus.
Vrai, c'est vrai.
Peut être que vous pouvez m'accompagner.
Ou alors Eglantine vous m'accompagner,
vous qui, qui donc qui de droit.
Mais vous allez y aller tous
parce que ça va.
Être ok avec.
Les deux qui vont pas jouer.
Eh bien allons y, on va passer
par les jardins, mais avant tout le monde.
Est ce qu'on peut juste demander ?
Est ce que vous pouvez nous faire un topo
de Comment ça marche tout ça ?
Votre projet ?
En allant au jardin, en marchant.
En marchant, vous.
Vous posez par le jardin,
le tout le monde dans un grand jardin.
Oui, il y a juste des plantes
qui se développent tranquilles.
Je peux regarder un peu.
Ouais, ouais, il y en a beaucoup
que tu connais, même si tu serais pas ici
dans fun, elle meurt, mais
mes grands parents agriculteurs,
je connais bien les plantes,
donc pas mon truc par exemple.
Ouais je c'est quoi ?
C'est un hibiscus ?
Connaissance de la nature, plus
d'une carotte.
J'ai pas un hibiscus, oui une carotte.
Car oui, c'est
sûr, c'est le village spolié comme ça. Me.
Tue. Popo c'est ça fausse la vision.
Mais oui, c'est évident.
Du coup, tu vois qu'il y a.
En fait,
il y a des endroits ou ça pousse un peu
en dehors, c'est libre.
Oui, c'est un jardin à l'anglaise
que vous à d'autres endroits
ou c'est un peu plus rangé ?
Tu vois qu'il y a un peu plus des études
qui sont faits sur un truc notamment.
Il y en a certes, y a des serres
qui sont entièrement éteintes.
Mais dites moi, Hélène,
pourquoi tout cet arrangement là ?
On fait plein de tests sur comment
évolue la nature dans ce nouveau monde.
Ah oui, donc
la lumière, c'est pour simuler ?
Ça donne quoi ?
En ce qu'on a vu, il y a y
une partie des plantes qui ont disparu.
Il y en a une bonne partie
qui sont restées en été
un peu de stase,
un peu comme une hibernation.
Et au final, elles réagissent assez bien
à l'éclairage de podium
qui a l'air
de déclencher leur photosynthèse
normalement, c'est plein de trucs
follicules, elles ont besoin d'être non.
Non, c'est une carotte. Encore une fois.
C'est ce qu'il me semblait, j'allais dire.
C'est
les 40 follicules ne sont pas concernés
parce qu'au printemps, elles ont besoin
d'avoir un éclairage assez fort.
C'est pour ça que vous avez vu
que les champs sont très bien exposés ?
C'est beau, ça fait.
Et il y en a d'autres du coup qui ont muté
et qui maintenant utilisent
un nouveau système
appelé la thermo synthèse.
J'utilise chaleur au lieu
d'utiliser la lumière simplement
et donc on fait plein de tests,
on voit comment ils réagissent
aux particules noires etc Pour eux,
pour s'assurer d'être prospère.
La chaleur, elle vient d'ou
cette chaleur ?
Peut être d'un feu.
Du soleil et. Du sol.
Et du sol.
Et donc il y a eu feu hier.
Ça vous a plaidé hier dans.
Cette séquence
policière ? C'est vraiment un
peu fun le
générique Eiffel.
C'est assez.
Sympa.
Enfin, j'imagine
qu'elle a des potes a Gaillac.
Enfin
oui, mais entre
la gardienne
qui devait les mettre au courant
vous a accompagné, donc je doute que
l'info elle est pas encore.
Et votre spoliant
vous vous le procurer ou.
On l'achète.
Pour que
dans ce.
Cas très bien
d'autres questions.
Ecoutez, j'ai l'impression
qu'on devrait en avoir fini.
Ouais, j'aimerais bien faire
jeter un œil à cet hibiscus.
Ce que. J'aimerais.
Je fais.
Toujours pas un. Virgule un des deux.
Côtés, j'en prends un autre.
Oui, ça c'est bien,
mais là, c'est gros blanc.
Là, c'est pas de l'hibiscus, je crois.
Ça, c'est de l'hibiscus, c'est
le fait 30.
Qu'on.
A du mal.
À trouver.
Est ce que Amaryllis. Ressemble à l'être ?
Et c'est oui.
D'ailleurs, je vais te laisser
quelques mots si tu fais ça.
Moi, je suis la descendante.
Retrouve moi dans ce laboratoire secret,
tu débrouiller seul pour le trouver.
Malheureusement, afin
qu'on trouve de toute façon, il
va devoir
se débrouiller tout seul
et pas seul au monde.
Bah on continue vers.
Oui, vers l'annexe
OK ou vous sortez de Gaïa ?
Fait. Vous marchez sur un espèce de.
Réflexion sur la. Terre
et vous finissez par arriver donc vous.
Et qui arrive torche dans le trajet ?
J'ai une belle torche.
Est ce que pour.
La torche alors là je l'ai laissé bleu,
je peux la mettre en verte ?
Petite question est
ce qu'on est encore avec le drapeau vert ?
Allez, je la mets en vert, allez.
Est ce qu'on est encore avec Hélène ?
Oui, elle vous accompagne.
D'accord, sont les oui, oui, peut être.
S'il y en a.
La relation adressée à Gaïa et Elikia.
Est un truc tout.
Va bien ici à Gaïa et quand elle voit.
Voilà pourquoi vous voulez
parler à Alexia.
Pourquoi vous voulez pas la rejoindre ?
Je suis partie d'élixir.
Oui, mais pourquoi ?
Parce que ça ne sert à rien.
Ce qui ça.
Les recherches sur le podium.
On ne pourra pas régler ce problème
par une recherche sur les particules.
Ne pourra pas régler ce problème.
Et qu'est ce que ça vous apporte
d'aller ailleurs ?
Qu'est ce que ça nous apporte ici ?
On apprend à vivre dans ce monde
plutôt d'essayer
de régler un problème qui résolve
comment je sers à la société.
D'accord,
un point de vue qui est justifié.
Oui, vous n'auriez pas une bague précieuse
à nous à nous confier pour
et pourquoi ?
Est ce que vous pensez
que parce qu'il n'y
a pas de futur dans la démarche d'Alexia,
d'essayer de trouver une solution ?
Parce que vos recherches
qui vous indiquent que
oui, il n'y a pas d'espoir là.
Dedans de toutes les recherches
qu'on a fait.
En fait, ce qu'on a compris, c'est que
les particules noires viennent d'une.
Réaction qui est due
aux émissions de
l'atmosphère.
De bagnole
pendant l'oral.
On l'avait vu à.
L'école,
mais je me souviens plus moi, c'est ça.
C'est écrit comme un.
Air et pour RTL c'est.
Pas normal, c'est.
Pas de. PH. Air pas normal.
Pas, ça n'aura pas.
d'Oral viennent les passionnants
viennent de la combustion.
C'est ça ? C'est
une réaction qui est due à ça.
De ce qu'on a compris.
Pour nous, c'est limpide, c'est ça.
Et donc la production de ce podium
relâche de ça dans l'atmosphère.
Donc c'est un cercle.
Au bout d'un moment,
sur une fois que ça a été un peu
trop saturé dans l'atmosphère,
ça a créé une réaction de Landolt.
Du coup,
on se retrouve avec les particules noires
et maintenant c'est trop tard.
Maintenant,
le podium est vital, c'est comme ça.
Donc on ne va pas faire le.
Ce moyen, ce serait ça
malheureusement une réaction de Landolt.
On ne peut pas l'inverser,
sauf en réinjectant
une des deux matières originelles.
Sauf que
si on a une des deux, c'est l'atmosphère
et l'atmosphère,
on ne va pas pouvoir en réinjecter.
Donc, soit il faut vivre dans le noir
très longtemps en espérant que ça change.
Mais il n'y a pas de changement.
Soit il faut utiliser du polonium
pour vivre.
Et du coup, ça continue, ça exactement.
C'est dramatique.
Sauf que c'est tellement vital
qu'on se dit pas.
Tant pis. D'accord. Vous savez,
on va apprendre à vivre comme ça.
Depuis quelques.
Juste pour moi,
c'est une philosophie de vie.
Vous avez dit une réaction de loup ?
R Mais quand vous.
Avez vu la résilience.
D'accord. Et donc vous avez dit
pour l'inverser, il faudrait.
Déjà ce
que font tout ce qu'on
a, de ce qu'on apprend avec la chimie.
C'est quelque chose de temporaire,
seulement l'inverser.
C'est à dire que si on brise l'équilibre,
ça renverse la réaction
de notre gouvernement.
L'équilibre
finit par se retrouver lui même.
Donc, quoi qu'il arrive, c'est bon.
C'est pour ça que du coup,
quand on fait brûler du podium,
en fait, ça renverse localement
la réaction de l'autre.
Du coup, on y voit, mais c'est encore.
La réaction de quoi ?
Je comprends pas le mot Landolt,
landolt quoi.
Le long de l'axe. Landolt, d'accord.
J'avais entendu dans un écrit.
Un très joli. Sourire.
Moi j'ai découvert ça.
Je ne pense pas que ça va être.
C'est qui Landolt ?
Un scientifique, je suppose.
Mais il vient d'ou
il vient ? d'Alexa ou il vient de Gaïa ?
Ou c'est une réaction.
D'accord. De culture générale ?
J'ai une question qui est.
Comme.
Si on allait changer quelque chose
pour ne pas finir dans cette situation.
Et voilà.
Pas produire de spoilers à la baisse.
Ben oui, pas produire de parabole.
Mais ça ne servait même servait
à quoi le paranormal ?
C'était juste.
Un effet servait à quoi le spoliant
avant qu'il fasse tout noir partout.
De ce que les livres en disent ?
C'était
une source d'énergie
très propre, sans soucis à polluer.
Très peu parce que le Pernois semblait pas
dangereux.
D'accord à l'époque des tests
et c'était le seul rejet.
Donc rien de bien grave.
Et en plus de ça,
la combustion est très lente.
Du coup, il n'y a pas besoin.
Produire beaucoup
pour faire beaucoup d'énergie donc,
mais pratique comme source d'énergie.
C'est pour ça que ça s'est développé
très fort.
Puis après, il y a eu un club de Rome,
comme un Romain qui a dit Ah oui,
mais non.
En fait, il y a du paranormal,
ce n'est pas bon et personne n'est écouté.
Ils sont sérieux.
En tout cas.
Moi je pense.
Que ça on connait un peu un cas de figure.
Donc en fait,
il faudrait revenir dans le passé
et dire aux gens que stop ne crée pas du
podium en créant qu'ils sont irréalistes.
Mais oui mais.
J'aime ce délire.
J'aimerais m'aider dans le grand délire.
Est ce que vous savez
faire des voyages dans le temps ?
Non, mais je.
Je sais qu'il y a des fous, du complexé,
qui disent que ça ne
passera pas,
des gens qui ne sont pas d'accepter
le championnat.
Et ça.
C'est pas d'accord,
mais juste dans une visée,
c'est sais pas,
juste fictionnelle, c'est à dire naturel.
C'est sûr que si on pouvait renvoyer
quelqu'un, dire
c'est pas du sport comme ça. Regrettable.
Mais ça ne sert à rien.
Il y aurait pas de problème.
Il faudrait qu'il y aille avec une preuve.
Parce que qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
leur dire, même pour des rigolos.
Ça serait le scénario de l'action.
Qu'est que ?
Qu'est
ce qui prouverait aux gens finalement ?
Je ne sais pas.
Peut être faire des tests plus approfondis
sur le paranormal
dans des environnements plus fermés.
Ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir qu'on soit lanceur d'alerte. Oh
quelle horreur !
J'ai eu. Car.
Pour vous, il y a quelques siècles,
qu'on croit au voyage dans le temps.
En tout, je connais pas beaucoup d'autres
villages.
Peut être qu'ailleurs dans le monde,
oui aussi.
Mais on a croisé des rigolos sur la route
avec un sablier dans l'oreille.
Et ce que tu dis, c'était juste curieux.
Ça, c'était vraiment étonnant, original.
Ils sont partis dans un bus,
peut être que c'était une fanfare,
ce sont des saltimbanques.
Vous devez être statiques.
Néanmoins.
On voit tout ici.
Il y aussi en Palestine une batucada.
Vous finissez par arriver
devant une espèce
de grande trappe sur le sol,
donc câline, elle vous dit
bon ben voilà, c'est ici.
À ma merci.
Il y a un cadenas mais.
Mais en fait c'est ouvert à la merci.
C'est bizarre, la dernière personne n'a
pas dû remettre la chaîne, mais c'est pas
très grave.
Peut elle ouvre, ça vous dit ?
Voilà. Bon,
moi je préfère pas descendre parce que
j'ai pas envie de prendre de risque.
Mais c'est quoi les risques ?
C'est qu'il
y a un truc qui nous tombe dessus.
Vous vous doutez bien qu'un laboratoire
souterrain désaffecté depuis, plus rien.
Non, non, mais il n'y a pas de vie.
Vous n'auriez pas un casque
24 casque sur vous parce.
Que c'est un peu tard ?
Censé avant peut être.
Ça, c'est souvent chez nous.
C'est
comme. Ça.
Merci Hélène.
Ils se retrouvent pour le café.
Ça marche.
Faites attention à vous !
Le succès.
Attendu nous attend au. Moins
vous attendent.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Tu te plait.
Comme. Ça.
C'est autre chose.
Ouais, mais les gentils.
Ouais, mais je viens d'apprendre
que je n'ai pas pris une pile de rechange
pour ma journée.
On passera là, non, non,
on en a marre dehors.
Réfléchis
quand même aux voyages dans le temps.
Voilà ce que je.
Nous offre.
Le mieux la veille.
La dernière image de quelle voie ? C'est
grotesque.
Il est 12 h.
Réfléchis au voyage temps
et on ferme la trappe.
Québec se fait un petit grain de tunes.
Cool.
Super !
Super impression et c'est
l'effet d'annonce.
Et qu'on prend le train
ok en régie, ça me rappelle un truc
complètement oublié.
Potentiel de pause.
Est ce que ça. Doit être juste ?
Très soif et malgré David.
J'ai pas de cours.
De chez Orange.
Que comptez. Vous faire ?
Après la pause Yes.
Last minute, finalement un même problème.
Pas juste le temps d'aller boire un coup.
Et voilà.
Il est dans la dernière ligne droite.
Là est de prendre une trappe de 212.
Refermer derrière vous
et vous arrivez dans
un espèce de complexe souterrain
qui est allumé.
Il est alimenté au podium.
Que par les économies.
Que fait Eglantine.
Et pour l'instant, il y a.
Un autre workshop. Je me
couché.
En long couloir qui mène à une porte.
Que fait Eglantine ?
Un Nicolas Gougain.
De temps en temps, je le regarde du fait
que ça va tout à fait descendre.
Comment d'ailleurs, dans votre amour,
comme je l'ai pris au concierge de ce.
Couloir, je me accroupie
et je pose la main sur le sol.
De quelle nature est il ?
Comme comme lors d'un méga feu ?
Faire faire, c'est à dire. Son.
Siège, c'est du métal.
C'est de la toge, quoi.
Enfin, c'est quoi ? Non,
mais ces jours ci.
Il s'est. Construit
quoi ? Qui s'est construit ?
Et s'il y a pas un petit caillou
qui traîne un truc comme ça dans.
Dans ce temps.
Là, je. Vais jouer
et je prends des agitateurs magnétiques
qui sont dedans depuis le début
et je l'ai fait sur le sol pour qu'il
avance.
C'est comme ça.
Si jamais il y a des mines antipersonnel.
Ça en jette un autre.
Oui, c'est
en principe scientifique.
Les hommes
de l'équipe de qui ?
Là, c'est la preuve qu'il. Est.
Casser métallique.
Voilà le petit poucet pour avoir.
La. Bombe en laisse.
La ravine à terre. Ok, on continue à vous.
Dire qui tient debout.
Ouais.
Ce qu'on peut faire, c'est à priori.
Moi, j'ai des amis ici,
je veux dire c'est oui.
Ma naissance, mon cas.
C'est passé devant le. Juge parti.
Chez fiche.
Ça résonne, mais y'a pas de réponse.
Alors peut être qu'il y a une soirée,
une porcherie.
Je propose qu'on avance vers la porte.
Avançons.
Il faut qu'on avance en général en.
Ce que ca marche.
Parce que le coin est
ce que le couloir est suffisamment serré
pour que on puisse mettre par exemple
une jambe d'un côté,
une jambe de l'autre sur les cloisons,
sans toucher le parcours, le sol.
Même.
Par moment,
tant pis, je marche normalement.
Afin.
D'arriver à la porte est fermée.
Il y a un espèce de bouton
en appui dessus. Ça vous a planté ?
Vous ne. Pensez.
Pas ce que je veux faire ?
Si un de mes. Pas avait été fait.
Je veux m'appuyer sur les murs
pour éviter les mines.
Ah, j'appuie sur un bouton rouge.
Et ça montre quel est.
Votre avis dans une espèce de salle
qui est
un peu circulaire. Sale salle sale.
Ça ressemble grande, ça ressemble à ce que
je connais pas du tout, pas du tout.
Par contre,
faites moi un objet d'intelligence.
Ouais, mon préféré.
Cinq. Sur.
Truc.
Cinq sur.
Six quatre un.
Quatre. Un homme sans tout ça
qui est jeune ?
Vous vous engagez ou ça vous dit rien ?
Vous étiez un tout toi.
Vous vous rendez
compte qu'en fait il y a des machines
au milieu de cette salle.
Ils sont branchés
un peu n'importe comment et elle ressemble
énormément aux installations de Gaston.
Ça ne vous rappelle pas quelque chose ?
Fredo Ça me rappelle ce qu'il
y avait dans le labo de Gaston.
C'est la même machine
vachement lourde.
On meurt avec. Ça.
Vous dit ça ?
Vous diriez ça.
Vu les murs ?
C'est un tout en métal.
Et déjà cette. Peinture au plomb
alors que c'était pas bon pour la santé,
pour les voies respiratoires,
c'était pas joignable,
non ?
Pourtant va être quoi
les petits jeunes donc.
Se disaient que ça ressemblait
étrangement aux machines de Gaston ?
Oh les machines !
Oui Gaston, c'était qui son.
Gaston ? C'était notre ami.
Des débuts, c'est l'homme.
Qui nous a porté la poste pas. Un ami.
Si vous
voulez mon avis, c'était pas un ami.
Ah oui, oui, kidnapper.
Qui vous allez vous ?
Quand il faut.
Passer par des étapes,
débloquer des choses.
On essaye de regarder autour, voir
si vous n'avez pas compris tous les mots,
ça ressemble.
Du coup à cette salle
avec plein d'installations au milieu
des installations, comme chez Gaston,
il y a une porte,
il y a quatre portes sur les quatre côtés.
De. Chaque donc il y en a une.
C'est celle de vous trouver
une allée fermée
et vous avez pas l'air de pouvoir
l'ouvrir.
Et des autres, c'est des chèvres derrière.
Il y en a une
qui mène à une grande salle sombre.
Vous vous y voyez rien ?
Votre sens.
Et les.
Murs qui donnent sur une salle ou il y a
une radio qui joue une petite musique.
Pas vous entendez une petite mélodie.
Qu'est ce qu'on entend ?
Ce ne serait pas
le générique de Mathieu, ça.
Mais ce qu'on entend, c'est le musicien.
Oui, qu'est ce que je me soule ? Bah
si tu sais que c'est fini, c'est Francis.
Cabrel. Qui dit non, jamais.
Ça vous dit pas quelque chose
cette chanson ?
Ouais.
Incroyable
on peut faire un karaoké de bois,
mais attiré comme.
Des mouches
avec. Généralement on dit.
Que mon n'attire pas les mouches
avec du vinaigre.
C'est ça.
Ça, c'est la merde.
C'est ça le caca.
Ouais ben voilà, on va sur la. Radio.
Cheap.
Du coup, vous vous avancez pour me dire
que c'est un petit poste
qui m'a l'air de jouer une cassette.
J'ai une.
Cassette, je fais.
Je tourne la torche que j'ai allumé.
Entre temps,
je regarde cette scène à l'éclairage
à la torche
olympique avant.
Bon, y'a rien dans la salle.
On écoute la petite.
Cassette dans la salle.
Du coup, vous avez plein d'écran
sur un mur en deux minutes.
Alors c'est Secret Story.
Ces écrans, vous vous reconnaissez ?
En fait, c'est un peu des sortes
de caméras de surveillance
qui sont reliées à tout le complexe Gaïa
et aussi au couloir et à la salle
dans laquelle vous étiez juste avant
et vous vous voyez vous même sur un écran.
Alors là, c'est creepy, creepy.
Il faudra récupérer la cassette
parce que moi je tremblote un peu.
J'en profite pour me faire un petit sniff
de ma torche
pour se détendre.
Ouais, pour. Le stress. Quand.
Moi je rembobine la cassette d'image ou.
Tu ajoutes cinq d'addictions de plus.
Dans quinze.
Ans, ça va faire beaucoup.
Vous remarquez aussi qu'il
y a beaucoup d'écritures un peu écrites
sur les murs, sur des tableaux etc
mais incompréhensibles.
Ça a l'air d'aider des médecins.
Qui comprenez vous ?
Non mais ça leur donne des L'Oréal,
des équations, un embarras.
Vous savez,
il y a énormément de photos de toi.
Pas si vous êtes curieuse, je.
Crois que on appelle ça.
C'est votre cas.
Vous avez pris un sacré coup de pelle.
Des photos d'archives ?
Ah oui, des photos imitant les.
Photos actuelles
ou des photos du bébé en couches.
Est ce qu'elles sont entourées.
Au sujet de photos d'archives
ou de couteaux de maintenant prise genre
série dix
C. Tu peux, tu sais pas trop en fait.
Une tête de bébé. Ou. De sang.
De bébé.
Ça, ça doit être votre
descendante, Pierre-Alain.
Mais oui, vous l'avez dit.
L'archéologie c'est pas descendance.
Ben oui, mais un peu large. C'est pas dit.
Les machines je fortiche.
Mais maintenant
on est dans un environnement un peu.
Hostile. Hostile.
Ouais,
parce que je ne sais pas, c'est pas.
Chaleureux, mais l'accueil en place,
c'est pas que c'est.
Bien dans une salle
avec des caméras partout.
Non, un portrait de vous.
C'est un cauchemar.
Une moto dans le
désamiantage générale.
De la salle et je vais vers
la Nouvelle-Zélande avec ma.
Torche que j'allume.
Est ce qu'on peut écouter la cassette ?
Est ce qu'on peut parler d'autre ?
Oui, c'est la musique qui introduit.
Je vais dans la pièce à côté.
Y a rien d'autre dans cette salle.
Frédo Il va dans une pièce à côté, mais.
On le regarde.
La pièce, je regarde, mais.
Tu peux par une des photos.
Ci. Claquent.
Du coup, avance.
Et en fait, au bout d'un moment,
vous le voyez plus.
Maintenant il voit toujours
mais avance et il voit plus ma torche.
Il a beaucoup avancé.
Ah oui, c'est une grande scène.
Je me positionne à l'entrée de la porte
et je lui fais. Et quand.
J'entends, je fais oui, mais je fouille.
Est ce que tu ? Oui, je. Tente.
Eh bien, je fouille dans le sol
et je vais pas.
Bon bah je vais la compagnie.
Alors j'ai couru. Avec moi.
Je rejoins Frédo.
Ouais, j'ai la torche magique.
Même si. Sportivement
ils ont plus de temps.
Je pouvais pas lire à voix haute
ce qu'il. Fout.
Ah oui oui.
Ils s'en foutent de lire à voix haute
mon truc, mais moi c'est juste que
j'ai mon nom.
J'ai ma descendante qui m'a dit
Voilà, j'ai,
j'ai J'ai pu créer une brèche
dans l'espace temps
qui m'a permis de voir le passé
le temps d'un instant.
Il faut que je garde cette trouvaille
secrète.
Sinon, les scientifiques du coin vont
vouloir s'en servir pour leur intérêt.
Mais j'ai un meilleur plan.
J'ai entendu parler
d'un ancien laboratoire souterrain.
Ce laboratoire, je vais m'y installer
pour finir mes recherches
et contacter Pierre-Alain.
Bon, d'ailleurs, je vais lui laisser
ses quelques notes notes.
Si tu lis ces mots,
je suis ta descendante.
Retrouve moi dans le laboratoire secret,
tu vas devoir se débrouiller seul
pour le trouver.
Malheureusement. On l'a trouvé.
Donc aller là dedans.
On est dans le Jospin.
Tous les mots nous parlent maintenant.
Donc vous de là,
vous êtes dans la salle tous les deux.
Qu'est ce que vous cherchez
spécifiquement.
À la fibre ?
Je sais pas.
On s'est mis à prendre un mur.
Oui, on ne sait pas
ce qu'il interrupteurs.
Des trucs de spolier un homme, qu'on
peut mettre des piles, que tu peux voir.
Rien, tu en fais une banane,
ça a l'air un peu vide.
Il n'y a pas des étagères, des choses
comme ça, des objets, des bibelots.
J'appelle ce fait, il y a quelque chose.
Tu regardes à quel niveau de la salle,
vers le sol, plutôt vers tous les murs.
OK, ça a l'air
d'être assez discret dans l'ensemble.
D'un coup, pendant que vous deux
vous êtes en train de me parler
d'une main, tu vois une personne
d'un coup se faufiler à tes côtés.
Gloria dans la salle.
Non pas Gloria et.
La porte se. Ferme bien là, mon Dieu.
Oui, et ça s'allume d'un coup.
Oh, je vais glander quand il y a de l'eau
qu'est en train de remplir.
Mais quand il.
Est tout
seul avec une femme de l'autre côté.
Oh Gloria !
À les entendre,
le bruit.
Frédo, est ce que vous savez
nager vraiment ?
Oui, mais
toi, je respire pas sous l'eau.
Par contre, toi. Moi,
est ce que je. Peux avoir.
À part cela ?
Je tape sur la porte, je te fou moi.
Ben moi je pense qu'il
faut ouvrir la porte à la pas.
D'aller ici.
Ça, il faut se retrouver dans la salle,
la pièce centrale.
J'essaie d'enfoncer la porte.
J'ai des p'tits.
La femme te regarde
elle même qui te dit Pierre-Alain,
c'est moi, Lucie, votre descendante.
Lucie. Mais qu'est ce que pourquoi ?
Il y a de l'eau.
Là, mais il n'y a pas d'autre moyen.
Mado Non, c'est nous.
On est dans une salle qui se remplit il ?
Avec mes amis ?
Il a fois n'est pas.
Au courant qu'il y a de. L'eau. Pas
juste vu qu'elle a poussé Gloria
vers la porte, se ferme.
À la sortie, on est Lucie.
Mais qui est pourquoi ?
Vous avez séparé mes amis.
Mes amis
pour discuter cela seul avec vous ?
Je crois que vous n'avez
pas besoin de ces personnes là.
Et là, on tambourine sur la porte.
Oui, c'est moi, à vous de juger. L'eau
qui monte, sauve, nous sauve.
Nous vous autant de temps, nous partons,
il tambourine,
mais voyons pas ce qu'il dit.
Laisser sortir des pieds de biche, nous.
Madame Lucie, s'il vous plaît,
laissez les sortir.
Pourquoi faire ? Mais parce que.
Si nous ont permis, sans eux,
on serait pas arrivé jusqu'ici,
on aura pas pu résoudre.
On a fait beaucoup de team
building ensemble.
Tu comprends
qu'on pourrait changer la face d'horizon ?
On rentre ensemble.
Changer la face de maison
en rentrant ensemble.
Le pied. De biche.
L'attente sera étendue devant
plus je t'explique.
C'est le pied.
Je suis au point sur mon mécanisme
de voyage temporel.
Ah bon. Tu as du temps de pause ?
Quand je suis venu me voir dans le passé,
Marius s'était.
Ensuite totalement rendu compte.
Mon premier test, qui a plutôt bien
marché, même si je n'ai pas pu rester
très longtemps à choix
si on être ensemble.
Moi j'ai pas envie de vivre dans ce monde
pourri à mes compenser,
donc tu me ramène dans le passé,
je reconstruit la technologie
dans le passé.
Ouais, et on se sert de ça
pour voir si t'es choix
en tant que président de la société.
L'horizon ont des impacts bénéfiques
ou négatifs dans le futur.
Mais alors ça veut dire
que je peux
pas seulement devenir président de Cci
mais président
du Monde potentiellement.
Alors là, Lucie,
on a peut être un marché.
Mais Grégory, qu'est ce qu'il faut.
Aussi dire aux questions ?
Qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire là ?
Dites moi tout.
Lucie
Moi, je fais confiance à mon ancêtre.
Mais vous avez raison,
si on se met. D'accord, je suis d'accord.
J'ai l'expérience de la.
Présidence de Cci.
Et on est de la même famille.
Ah ben non mais c'est pas forcément
plus fort.
Là comme on dit,
c'est le sang de Repak alors.
Lucie, Lucie, Lucie.
Tout le monde.
Comment réagissez vous ?
Savez, moi. J'ai le problème parce que
je suis venu avec trois personnes ici.
Oui, mais on en a pas vraiment besoin.
Alors non, non.
Est ce que
est ce qu'on
peut éviter de leur faire trop mal ?
Pour l'instant,
le temps qu'on réfléchisse,
qu'on voit un peu comment se construire.
Et qu'est ce qu'il y a à réfléchir,
on pourra réfléchir une fois.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Et puis si on revient dans le passé,
on les sauve d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Je veux dire live, on.
Se trouve dans la Tasmanie.
C'est trop compliqué,
c'est trop compliqué.
Alors, du coup, qu'est ce qu'on est ?
Est ce qu'on peut voyager dès aujourd'hui,
dès maintenant, dans le temps, là,
tout de suite ?
Eh bien, je pense que le plus simple,
ce serait
d'utiliser la technologie de Gaston
pour passer inaperçue.
Ah ouais, mais Gaston, il est à l'horizon
un problème ? Ah oui !
Vous êtes véhiculé ?
Oui, c'est pratique.
Elle a du mal à circuler.
Donc donc du coup.
Donc, ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on aille
voir Gaston utiliser Gaston.
Cette technologie.
Vous le convainquez
de me renvoyer dans le passé avec.
Vous. Ouais.
Sinon il l'aurait démonté.
Ouais, mais moi je peux encore en quête de
l'or, on est d'accord.
Moi, j'ai juste entendu des tambours.
Oui, mais là,
on. Va essayer de forcer la porte
de la porte, non ?
C'est une porte
un peu sur truc hydraulique.
Y a pas de conduit au plafond d'aération,
il y a des conduits d'aération à
repasser. J'ai une corde.
Il va être compliqué mais c'est faisable.
Bah un cheval c'est faisable.
Moi je continue de parler avec Lucie. OK.
Moi je suis par terre.
Mais c'est un fait.
J'ai une perception de vie, de perception.
De loue.
Pas dans ce qu'il y a peut être un bonus.
Dans 26.
Pas besoin de bonus,
je serais perceptif si.
Tu tournes les yeux
et tu vois sur un des écrans dans la salle
d'à côté.
Et tu vois tes trois camarades
avec de l'eau jusqu'à
la taille qui sont en train de taper
sur la porte et de voir.
Lucie, c'est quoi ?
Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Pourquoi ils sont dans une piscine ?
Parce que c'est plus simple
de les éliminer comme ça.
Les éliminer à
plus un.
C'est pittoresque.
Pittoresque.
Mais comment ? Comment ?
Comment vous dire, Lucie ?
Si sait que
c'est en fait que j'ai pas mal de
pas de vécu, mais juste.
C'est des gens qui sont
partenaires également intéressants
et qui pourraient aider
notre entreprise familiale à prospérer.
Et vous êtes sûr
qu'il serait temps pour moi ?
Ils vont jamais accepter
que je rentre dans le passé.
Mais pourquoi pas ? Ils sont cool.
C'est Gloria, Gloria, couperose,
la s'occupe de sélénite de machin.
Oui, trois mots d'archéologie
OK, Fredo, mon frigo
et Églantine.
Donnez lui un escalope,
une escalope de poulet.
Franchement,
alors ils sont bien dans leur spécialité.
Mais alors
voilà, on peut un peu leur
l'envoyer. Du flan, quoi ?
D'accord.
Et ils sont pas là comme ça,
mais ils sont débrouillards.
Parce que moi, le seul problème c'est que
actuellement c'est moi
qui est le moyen de pression.
Si vous êtes quatre, ce ne sera plus moi.
Mais attendez, c'est moi,
c'est moi qui les contrôle à l'étroit.
Là, je veux dire c'est.
Mais sbire fait un mentir,
convaincre l'autre.
En même temps,
pourquoi je suis convaincu ?
Rien pour convaincre les.
55, c'est
à dire convaincre 75.
Qu'elle te dit. Bon, d'accord.
Ah mais bien vous voulez sortir ?
Bah ça, baisser l'eau
fait en sorte que l'eau ne monte plus.
Si c'est possible.
OK, elle appuie sur un truc
et ça arrête l'eau.
Vous vous voyez juste l'eau
qui arrête de se remplir ?
Vous l'avez à peu près au niveau
du ventre ?
C'est pas un peu dur de se déplacer
les poubelles ?
Oui j'ai pas
envie d'essayer le produit, de l'ouvrir et
regardez ça.
Donc est ce que c'est
est ce que je peux à la.
Fonte ou en haut d'un mur ?
C'est OK.
Je vous fais la courte échelle.
Tu te
bonnes gens veulent ouvrir.
OK, pied de biche, donc courte échelle.
Pied de biche comme gros.
Ouais ok, c'est qui qui soulève qui ?
Je je suis sorti, c'est moi.
Si c'est moi qui va, soulève
Dilemme.
Je vois.
Je tambourine à la porte.
Sur ce pas.
Être conduit à trois.
N'y a pas de problème.
Vous allez faire un aller retour avec.
Ça a été tendance pour voir.
Si on appelle ça un truc.
83 sur 40.
Du coup, je. Retombe dans. L'eau.
Qui te lèves tu bien ?
L'équilibre et tu retrouves.
La. Parce qu'il y a
un micro pour parler
dans la salle de contrôle.
Pas parce que je peux parler.
Est ce que je demande à Lucie
Est ce que je peux parler,
ce que je peux
leur parler dans un petit micro ?
Potentiellement.
Je peux leur parler.
Ça dépend pour dire quoi ?
Pour leur dire de se calmer.
Parce que là, vous voyez bien qu'ils sont
en train, ils vont se faire mal.
C'est plaisir, ils ne sont pas d'accord.
On t'amène dans la salle d'à côté.
Du coup, là, il y a tous les écrans
et elle branche le truc et elle te montre
ce qui ressemble à un micro.
OK alors Cloclo, Fredo.
Oui et gland.
Gland calmez vous.
Oui je suis dans l'eau, profitez en.
Quand tu les entends pas. Bon.
Ouais ouais mais calmez vous,
restez dans l'eau.
Je suis en train de parler avec quelqu'un
qui s'appelle Lucie.
Elle est très sympa.
Franchement, gros délire.
Bien, je vais vous sortir de là
dans deux secondes.
Il n'y a pas, il n'y a pas de problème.
Laissez moi juste finir ça.
Essayez pas de grimper partout parce que
je vous vois franchement c'est ridicule.
J'en profite pour faire quelques brasses.
Mais je pense que c'est
bien de s'entretenir avec moi.
Je prends le bougre dans les bras,
il est obligé
de nager, je projette.
OK, donc
bon, ils ont effectivement l'air
de vous obéir.
Donc je pense que je peux
vous faire confiance là dessus.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Ouais bah oui.
Ça reste bien.
Donc du coup, avec ma petite troupe, là,
ça voudrait dire qu'on va avoir Gaston.
On lui dit quoi ?
On lui dit Salut, c'est nous,
envoie nous dans le passé et c'est tout.
Je suppose qu'il vous a déjà dit
que vous pourriez rentrer dans le passé ?
Ouais, mais. Alors pas.
Un super contact
avec le général Beaulieu, là.
Oui, mais on n'est pas obligé
de passer devant le général Bola.
Vous que vous connaissez,
vous avez vos entrées, quoi ?
Si on va directement au labo ?
Ah oui, ok, donc on va au labo.
Et c'est bon quoi ?
Oui, vous pourrez mentir à Gaston
en disant que c'est bon le général.
Il est assez facile à convaincre,
ça marche avec lui.
Ah bah parfait pour moi
dans ce cas là, on fait ça comme ça.
On retourne tous dans le
passé.
Notre présent, ce serait sympa.
OK bon
on peut libérer mes sbires maintenant
parce que je pense qu'ils se sont assez
assez mouillés.
Je pense que je peux vous faire confiance.
Tenez bon, je vais quand même essayer
d'attenter à leur vie.
Vous comprendrez
que. Non, ils prendront pas mal.
Je vous assure qu'elle. Active
d'autres trucs, vous.
D'un coup, il y a des grilles
en fait qui s'ouvrent au sol
et ça fait couler l'eau très vite.
Donc ça va, puis ça va que.
Tu m'en rends pas compte tout de suite
et je continue.
À faire
dans le.
Je suis descendu
un peu de crawl.
La porte s'ouvre.
OK ok, là je fais
à mes sbires.
Oui oui maître.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
C'est qui ciel ?
Quid et. Ser Frédo ?
C'est pas comme ça qu'on s'exprime, c'est.
Si on le voit.
C'est vous qui. Avez failli.
Se noyer là.
Non, mais là,
vous êtes sous le coup de l'émotion.
Oui, Frédo aussi.
Est ce que vous pouvez
vous occuper de Frédo ?
Parce que là, oui, ça me prend la tête.
Alors la cantine, ça va.
Mais je la. Nage.
Mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
Et c'est elle qui a fait ça ?
Non, non, non, c'est un problème d'eau.
Ça, c'était un problème d'évacuation.
Oui, oui, oui.
Vous êtes entrés dans la salle, mais.
C'était pas vous, donc c'était pas voulu.
Enfin un accident, un bête accident.
Que vous avez,
vous a poussé dedans quand même ?
Qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé ?
Croche patte.
J'ai basculé, mais
ça arrive. Tout va bien.
Faut faire surveiller
votre oreille interne.
Alors oui. Vous êtes jouissives.
Donc je vous présente Lucie Lucie,
enseignante à ma petite petite petite.
Mais il y a un autre famille,
la poussette dans l'arbre tout petit.
Ah oui, oui, oui. Oh les charmantes !
Alors je Chichin, si c'est pour la vie.
Et donc il
chichi à toi.
Et donc la petite bichette, elle a trouvé
un moyen de nous ramener dans le présent.
Gaston aussi.
Qu'est ce que vous apportez de plus ?
Bon, déjà, le 105 semble être
un facteur important, mais.
On ne peut pas ramener des gens du futur
dans le passé, faire.
Un mur.
Il n'est pas question de fermer ? Non,
pas non.
Nous, on va juste.
Lucie, c'est proposer de nous accompagner
dans Voir Gaston.
Et elle.
Si quelqu'un, quelqu'un aide
quelques moyens techniques
pour aider le transfert à se faire.
C'est gentil, mais il faut parfois
s'enfermer par contraintes de temps.
Faire mieux vous même ?
Oui, oui, faire le coup de l'eau
et tout ça va.
C'est quoi ?
C'est cet.
Accident ? Eglantine et accident.
On ne peut le transmettre à Gaston
nous même.
Peut être ?
Non, c'est mon invention.
Non, mais dans mes cours en général.
C'est la société.
Mais c'est le. Sur un autre.
C'est justement ça. Non,
mais ça va bien se passer.
Qu'est ce que ?
Qu'est ce que vous apportez
concrètement à notre programme ?
Je peux vous dire qu'ils sont pas encore.
Ils sont en maison de bulle.
Avec la machette.
Ça fait quoi avec vos machines ici ?
Pas ici.
Je peux donner
avec les machines de Gaston.
Lui peut pas,
mais je. Donne un coup de pied.
Je suis vraiment désolé, mais.
Généralement ils sont pas comme ça.
C'est juste dès qu'ils sont mouillés.
Mais c'est bien ça,
ils deviennent intenables.
Nous allons. Faire. Un.
On y va, on y va.
Donc vous comprenez bien le plan,
les sbires sbires là
on va voir Gaston
pour qu'il nous amène dans le présent.
On attendait Pierre,
on est venu ici voir votre descendance.
Ouais et la conclusion c'est
on va faire ce qu'on
nous avait dit depuis le début,
retourner chez Gaston.
Ou est le problème ?
Elle était d'accord,
mais on n'a pas discuté.
On est, on est resté
dix minutes dans la ludothèque.
Ah oui, est ce que tu te souviens
de la grande tante Chichi ?
Et puis non, à chaque fois, forcément.
On nous entendiez pas.
J'ai vu que j'ai eu entendu
quelques bang bang, mais pas plus.
Euh, on se noyer, quoi ?
Ah oui, je suis vraiment.
Mais non, pas vous m'envoyez. Désolé
mes sincères excuses à Lucie.
C'est pas cool mes sbires.
Oui mais bon moi j'y peux rien, sinon.
Je faut.
Que ça reste un lieu désaffecté.
Dangereux.
Ben oui donc c'est. Surtout
les salles qui sont plus. Alimentées.
On avait même pas de casque,
on arrive là dedans.
À traiter de quoi là ?
Je ne suis pas tout compris.
Il y avait combien de consonnes ce mot
sbire ?
Est ce que je peux faire
un jeu d'intimidation ?
Il se fout nautilus.
Allez, et je donne un coup de pied
dans le tibia Eglantine
pour qu'elle comprenne que
monsieur, voilà.
Eh ben pas du tout.
68 de ceux qui ont eu look, c'est toi.
Tu te donne un petit coup de pied,
mais tu descends à peine.
Tu comprends pas ce que c'était en fait.
Tu la voit qu'elle a son pied contre
ton tibia et tu sais pas ce qu'elle.
Fait. Vraiment
que je travaille en termes de papiers.
Non mais votre oreille interne,
ça va pas du tout.
Lucie,
qu'est ce que vous êtes rentré chez vous ?
Là, on reconnaît que c'est
les mêmes machines que chez toi.
Je travaillais sur les vaches
temporales, j'ai réussi.
Et pourquoi
cette note là pour Pierre-Alain ?
Parce que je veux jouer.
Je suis sûr qu'il aura ma deuxième.
Proposition. Quand. Même.
Mais en quoi ça consiste précisément ?
Vous ne l'êtes. Votre rêve ?
Quel est l'élément que vous apportez
à la machine de Gaston ? Moi.
J'ai inventé le voyage temporel inverse.
Votre intéresse
mon ancêtre Pierre-Alain
peut vous en parler.
D'ailleurs, je pense que
lorsque je suis rentré en contact avec lui
bien avant que vous veniez ici.
AB C'est. Précurseur.
Première nouvelle
oui, oui.
En venant ici, c'est 50. Donc
quand j'étais dans.
Le passé, j'ai vu une personne humanoïde.
C'était réussi à
mais je vous ai dit
Je vous avais raconté tout ça.
Ah ah oui, mais vous croyez pas ?
Oui, c'était ça on laisser.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai
que. Oui. Je pensais que vous étiez sous.
Quelque chose, que.
Je ne vais pas vous mentir.
La Cci, ça tourne aussi.
Il faut être réveillé
quand même par les autres.
Donc simplement
je savais que Pierre-Alain allait finir
par venir ici, donc moi je me proposait
de l'aider à rentrer chez lui.
C'est bien ça ? C'est Pas très chic.
Ça, c'est la famille.
C'est la famille. Parfait.
Allons y.
Non, nous, on a un peu de la famille
maintenant aussi.
Pierre-Alain
Alors j'ai vu que
une part oui, oui, oui, oui, tout à fait.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Eh bien.
Oui. Et oui.
Et d'ailleurs, ça me fait penser
vite qu'on aille dans le présent,
qu'on puisse célébrer tout ça.
Dans le présent.
Mais j'ai ok.
Vous êtes tombés sur ma torche.
J'ai été touché un peu.
Voilà spoiler comme ça.
J'ai pu le faire au moment.
C'est pas pour vous
comme je l'ai, je dis.
C'est trop de famille, trop ouf.
Bon, on va l'air libre un peu parce que
j'étais. Donc si vous êtes.
Véhiculé, on va tous dans le véhicule
et hop, direction horizon.
Un retour dans le présent
et on les empêche de spolier.
Non mais le but c'est juste
nous en retour.
Après vous faites ce que vous voulez
si vous voulez dédier votre vie
à une cause compliquée, faite
moi je ne s'essayer à faire tourner.
Bah moi je suis pas très chaud
que le monde devienne comme ça.
Mais ça, c'est votre combat personnel.
En ayant vu Amélie, je me dis que le monde
est pas mal comme il est fou.
Ceux qui répondent.
Non, mais moi j'ai vu au ciel.
Ce problème.
Alors à l'air libre,
ce sera mieux je pense.
Discutons en
en vous, vous.
Sortez, vous voulez retourner à Gaïa
ou d'abord vous allez directement
choper un véhicule ?
Moi je repasse.
Serais bien voir la caserne.
Ah oui, voir
c'est pour faire du tourisme.
Mais on ne fait pas du tourisme.
Rentre la forme très demandée pour
les diamants, des oreilles, les diamants.
Je pense que.
Ça restera un mystère. Non ?
On va.
À la Casa et moi
si j'avais pu m'en ramener un petit
pour ma collection, un petit. Pas.
Pour m'amuser si on rentre là,
je suis en train de me dire.
D'accord,
on peut faire le service de type du.
Futur. Pour que ça. Marche ici.
Vous voyez bien que mes sbires
ont des besoins
touristiques. D'accord.
On peut faire un dernier petit. Tour tours
je suppose.
Et après on va un horizon parfait
comme ça, on ramène des souvenirs.
Vous allez
vous retourner à ma liste.
Est ce qu'on peut passer à Gaïa avant ?
Et Jeudi, à l'abri de là,
juste à vous deux
pour se renseigner sur cette Lucie.
Savoir si ils ont entendu parler de ça.
Tu sais pas, mais.
Alors est ce que moi je peux s'il le faut,
parler pendant qu'on est bien en face.
On n'a qu'à lui dire.
On va. Voir si elle te colle car.
Moi je pense que Pierre-Alain
il est bloqué et
il peut pas faire sans elle et elle.
Elle n'a pas besoin de nous.
Vous comprenez ?
Non, je suis concierge.
Ça, je pense que j'y fais pas confiance.
Je pense qu'elle ne nous fait pas
confiance.
Ah ben c'est réussi.
Oui, voilà, je vais essayer de nous tuer
tous les trois sur tous les cadrans.
Toujours chez Google, ça fait 4 h.
Maintenant, on retourne voir Alan,
on me dit
qu'on avait, on devait voir
si on peut la voir.
Hélène on doit lui porter un agitateur
magnétique qui a nous avait demandé. Non.
Mais on va.
Une corde.
Non à
Lucie, il faut qu'on
avant de retourner à mon dix,
il faut qu'on repasse par Gaïa
parce que.
Pas l'indice aux. Étages.
Il faut simplement qu'on aille
lui faire un compte rendu.
Elle s'inquiétait pour nous
en fin de tours.
Ça prendra cinq minutes. Oui.
Dépêchez vous, c'est d'ordre
administratif.
D'accord.
Allez, zou,
si vous voulez, vous nous attendez.
Là, on fait juste un aller retour,
on lui dit OK, c'est bon.
Et puis on revient, Pierre,
pour aller faire.
Du coup, on y va tous les deux
ou vous voulez venir avec nous.
Nous ralentir ?
Bon, j'ai vu juste un peu.
Tu vas, on y va en. Foot.
Ou un peu en vitesse ?
Oui, je. Vais faire un petit footing.
OK, vous vous retrouvez
Hélène Rigot, Hélène.
Alors ça s'est bien passé votre visite
alors ?
Bof, en terme de sécurité et boum.
Par contre.
L'annexe n'allait pas abandonner, hein ?
Comment ?
Ça vous dit quelque chose ?
Une Lucie ? Chiche ? Fortiche. Non ?
Et dans les loges ici. Autre chose, non ?
Dans les registres, vous savez, si on peut
regarder des registres quelque part.
Rapidement. Là,
on a pas beaucoup de temps.
Des scientifiques de Gaïa.
La liste du personnel.
Oui, voilà la liste du personnel
des à Noël.
Vous savez,
quand vous faites de grandes cérémonies.
Ça peut être, mais.
On pourrait avoir accès à ça.
Si vous posez une question de vie
ou de mort.
Alors d'accord pour écouter Hélène
et avec quelqu'un dans les souterrains. OK
donc un.
Squatteur un peu dangereux,
un peu plus.
De scientifique
qui peut être a pris un mauvais tournant.
Mais oui mais bon.
Désolé mais le bâtiment est abandonné.
Ben on vous dit que non.
Oui d'accord.
Mais à partir du moment ou nous
on a décidé que le bâtiment,
il n'est plus à nous,
on va pas l'utiliser.
S'il y a quelqu'un qui va dedans,
on n'y peut rien.
Si ça rassure volontaire,
ça reste vos responsabilités.
Revoyez vos cours de droit, quoi ?
Ou alors peut être qu'à la caserne
on demande s'il n'y a pas.
Est ce que la caserne,
ce n'est pas aussi un commissariat
et que peut être aller rechercher
celui ci ?
Du coup, il y a un registre du personnel
sur un dossier.
Lucie Comment vous avez dit ?
Bah si je. Porte ici, je.
Suis parti.
Je cherche Dieu et secours, je cherche.
Il y a pas vraiment de Lucie.
Non, pas tant pis, merci.
Alors bon,
la sécurité, c'est bon.
On s'occupe de retourner
voir Céline Céline
tous les jours et on lui dira qu'elle
peut vous rejoindre.
Et ok, merci.
J'avais un message à lui faire passer.
Peut être plus simplement, c'est tout.
Bon, je pense qu'on se parlera. Une fois
qu'on se retrouvera.
On se retrouvera sur.
Dites moi tout.
Très bien, merci.
Merci beaucoup, Hélène.
Hélène.
Merci Céline.
C'est ce que je dirai à votre épouse.
Donc là, on repart
et je dis vous retrouver
les trois plannings et l'accord
en marche avec les si je lui dis non, moi
j'ai toujours pas confiance cette Lucie.
Il faut, que.
Dis je, en faisant un flop flop
avec mes chaussures mouillées.
Je pense qu'il faut qu'on se renseigne.
Amaryllis ou quoi ?
Ouais je crois aussi, mais ou.
Allez concerne
déjà la caserne, les gardiennes.
Est ce que vous pensez
ce que vous pensez
qu'elle peut avoir un rapport
avec le feu ?
Nous sommes venus.
Jusqu'au point d'interrogation.
La question à creuser,
on en est arrivé à méditer.
C'est beau, on peut y aller ça.
On peut aller à la caserne maintenant.
Mon dernier arrêt promis à Lucie ? Oui.
Je sais, il faudrait aller au piquet,
d'avoir une équipe.
Vous, vous allez vers la caserne du coup,
et devant la caserne,
vous voyez un groupe de bleu rouge pâle.
Je savais plus que ça.
Vous avait un peu loin et vous voyez.
En fait, ils sont devant la caserne.
Ils sont cinq, six cherchent et ils sont
en train de parler avec le gardien.
Alors vous. Vous qui êtes ainsi à.
L'école, Pierre-Alain,
on ne peut pas parler à Pierre-Alain.
Faut que les.
Pierres, deux autres non.
Je dis à. Ta maman je colle Pierre.
Les rouges, ils. Savent pas qu'on
leur chie dessus depuis qu'on est parti.
Peut être qu'ils en ont entendu parler,
mais à force.
Je pense qu'ils s'en. Foutent.
Vous, qu'est ce qu'on. A fait de contre ?
Rien ?
Oui, mais bon, on a un peu avec les.
Autres, ça marche toujours.
On a juste évité de dire qu'on
était avec eux, mais on n'a jamais dit.
On a dit qu'on était plutôt contre.
Par exemple, au maire de virer à Lara.
Oui, mais c'est simplement pour avancer.
Alors là, je me suis dit
Vous connaissez les Aigles rouges aussi ?
Oui. C'est quoi votre avis ?
Oui, ils veulent régner par la force,
la terreur et la milice.
Ils ont une influence quelconque, non ?
D'accord, donc si on s'approche
d'eux, ils peuvent rien nous faire.
Je ne sais pas,
sauf si vous avez des problèmes avec eux.
Et vous, vous en avez ?
Non. Qu'est ce qu'on va faire
si on va les vite ?
Et si on allait juste.
Se faire. Directement ?
Élixir ? Voilà, ça me paraît bien, non ?
Non mais moi et mes sbires.
Non, tout de suite.
Alexia,
c'est le carnet de la commande de Pierre
et on essaye de rentrer par une fenêtre
des toilettes de l'autre côté
sans se faire voir par les éléments.
Est ce que oui on cherchait une.
Dextérité, des toilettes.
Pas notre.
Alors il se trouve qu'il
y a une boutique de vêtements.
À côté de la caserne. D'accord.
Je vais pour acheter un costume.
Jean-Samuel si vous voulez dans mon.
Corps. OK.
Voilà, je souhaite un costume
de pompier.
Mais il faudrait mieux que ce soit vous
parce que
ils ont l'air
de préférer les bonnes femmes.
Ah oui, et je,
je me méfie un peu facilement.
Je sais pas.
Il faut, il faut,
il faut cacher la start up.
Là, il faut.
Que le start up.
Je sais pas. C'est faux.
Je suis comme tout un chacun
que les. Rouges ne vous reconnaissent pas.
À quoi ça peut être une tenue.
Une cagoule.
Quelque chose comme ça,
peut être une tenue de.
Pas de déminage, mais.
Quelque chose de féminin.
Radioactif, là ?
Oui, mais dans le pré, c'est
comme dans un magasin de fringues.
Ecoutez, j'ai un sarouel,
je peux rester comme ça en rouge, mais ça.
Ça va pas, non ?
Un foulard, peut être une perruque.
Et s'il y a des perruques dans ce magasin.
Il y a quoi dans le magasin ?
Et si on vous refuse des.
Breloques jusque là ? Oui,
bon sang.
Ouais, le foulard, pas assez pour une
barbe, tu veux pour acheter un foulard ?
Du coup, dans le magasin, oui.
Oui, oui, oui.
Tu veux un foulard ?
De quelle couleur ? Ah !
Je vous laisse choisir.
Rouge.
Est ce que rouge, c'est une bonne idée ?
Est ce que ça peut attirer l'attention.
Au rouge, mais un peu éteint.
Alors Bordeaux. Bordeaux ?
OK, tu prends un foulard qui devait lever
la couleur, ça vous fera ça siouplait ?
Est ce que vous prenez
l'ancienne monnaie dans les Hyérois ?
Pas de modèle.
Est ce. Que vous.
Aimez les pied de biche ?
Oui, j'ai des doutes.
Est ce qu'on pourrait faire un échange.
Avec.
Un pied de biche ? Non, non, non.
Est ce que
un badge du générateur ?
Ça vous intéresse.
Vraiment ?
Faire une poche, cela ?
Attendez mon.
Vieux torche. De luxe de ce podium.
Ah mais par contre là,
il faut plus que l'eau, la cloche,
le foulard et quelques iris.
C'est quoi des idées ?
D'accord ?
Peut être pas. Moi, je vais prendre.
Des piles de ce podium.
Neuf, ça vous intéresse ? Non ?
Vous avez quoi avec ?
On essaie de faire un déguisement
pour le carnaval.
C'est quoi le carnaval sur le nom
qu'on donne à une fête ?
C'est un truc familial.
On se déguise quoi ?
On met des tenues
qui ne correspondent pas, en fait,
pour essayer de changer d'identité.
Vous voulez vous déguiser ?
Madame, on cherche un costume pour madame.
D'accord. Est ce que vous avez
des suggestions ?
On a déjà un sarouel.
On s'est dit le foulard,
peut être un tee shirt à Hendaye.
Puis vous auriez ça peut être tee shirt
de toutes les couleurs.
Vous voulez dire oui, oui, oui, oui,
je peux vous faire ça.
Donc le tee shirt
et le foulard contre la torche,
je pense que là, il manque encore,
je l'achète.
Bon la monnaie est pas mauvais
avec des torchons plus.
Mais juste les recharges des torches,
ça vous intéresse pas ?
Non mais là on en a gros, on a trop.
Sur. Nous, on.
Se tourne les
juste.
Vous êtes très.
Long, alors moi je suis en train de dire
oui, vous savez, mais aussi.
Le. Lâcher.
S'il faut mettre un terme à mon agent,
nous allons vous en donner.
De l'arrivée dans le magasin
quand on arrive dans le magasin.
Mais non, je n'ai pas écrit.
Je bloque la porte. Je fais
écouter.
La torche contre le foulard,
le tee shirt et 20.
Et on est qui.
A pas donné une torche ?
Je ne peux pas me permettre
de vous donner de l'argent.
Bon allez pas juste à temps,
je donne la torche.
OK foulard.
Tu jettes le filtre,
je mange, je prends le filtre. OK
merci pour le luxe.
Le temps c'est acheté
et vous avez gagné un foulard
et un tee shirt eglantine.
Un foulard.
Et vous rentrez dans la salle.
Du sabotage ?
Ça c'est perdu.
Mais moi je peux.
J'étais en train de sauver le monde.
On était bien parti pour être chez nous
ce soir.
Donc alors très bien.
Du coup tu te change.
Du coup je me sens ok.
Et je prends une démarche de baba ceci.
OK. Ouais, je vais aller dans une
caserne, ça oui, ça marche.
Combien de soldats.
A ce genre de caserne ?
Il n'y a pas. Il y a les soldats
des Aigles rouges qui sont devant.
Il y a les gardiennes
qui sont les gardes de la ville.
Moi je suis, je suis pas là.
C'est quoi le plan ?
C'est alors.
En amont.
Là, elle se rappelle un flashback.
On discutait un flash back.
Il faut chercher des renseignements
sur le clan du Sablier et sur lui.
Si c'était ça le but,
ce n'était pas d'acheter un chandail.
C'est
c'était des renseignements sur Lucie.
Est ce que je peux avoir le chien
pour faire vraiment la bimbo
jusqu'au bout ?
Oui, oui. Flash back.
Ça oui, oui, parce qu'on l'a dit.
Il y avait Bougard revient sur
Eglantine en bobonne avec son chien.
Qui avance du cou vers la caserne
pour que je.
M'approche des soldats.
Puis il y a une grue
qui s'arrête qui dit bonjour,
je peux vous aider.
Yo, j'y viens pour la Réunion, là,
vous savez. 16 h
On a dit ceci, on en a parlé, je.
Puis puis
j'ai.
Parlé à. Sylviane, professionnelle.
J'ai parlé à Martine tout à l'heure.
Vous savez,
au niveau de la cabine abandonnée.
Là, qui nous a dit Yo ?
Je vois de loin la question.
À la caserne.
Tout à l'heure,
on boit un petit et puis on discutera.
Chiffons quoi ?
Alors me voici Martine ou va traiter des.
Je sais pas, mais
là on est occupé.
Là, on n'est pas vraiment accessible.
Je suis occupé à la même chose que vous.
Ça tombe à. L'eau.
Je viens pour vous dire
avec les aiguilles rouges.
Oui, bien sûr.
Mais de quoi
est ce que je peux voir autour des 100.
Jours par rapport, je peux vous dire.
Que. C'est pas fini.
Soyez cool.
Pour.
Moi, mais là, c'est fini.
Est ce que vous êtes
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants ?
Pas depuis 20 minutes.
Disons. Non, non.
Chiqué depuis toujours.
C'est sûr. Très chic de.
La clim.
Qui fait encore.
Un peu.
J'ai fait un premier choix et clean,
puis vous.
Qu'est ce que ?
Qu'est ce que vous voulez faire ?
Eh bien, je viens vous prêter
main forte dans les négociations
avec le rouge.
Quel nom au nom de Barbara ?
Elle peut avoir un.
Matin lutter contre le verbe.
Comique de répétition.
Oui, vous êtes
ou vous faites partie des personnes ?
Je fais partie.
Vous êtes peut être.
Une bienfaitrice de mari.
Exactement. D'accord.
Je n'ai pas encore entendu parler de vous,
mais.
Voilà, eh bien, c'est exactement moi.
D'écouter.
Soyez la bienvenue,
nous discutions. Merci.
Donc tu t'appelles des Aigles Rouges ?
Et puis. À Villeneuve.
Ça discute.
Puis il y en a qui commencent à
introduire des graines.
Je rabat le foulard bien sur. Même
on voit plus mes yeux.
C'est une autruche.
Et quand c'est dire,
c'est qui elle ?
Et du il y a une gardienne qui dit
c'est Barbara,
une bienfaitrice de notre village.
Elle a tenu
à participer à la discussion
et il commence à regarder.
Il a l'impression qu'il y croit.
Pas une seconde.
Puis ça risque d'être pas ton chez moi.
Je suis juste là. La discussion continue.
Il y a rien de bien d'intéressant
dans cette discussion.
Et bon.
C'est bien.
Et je peux.
Vous dire que le mec
qui. Eglantine, il faut se renseigner
sur Lucie.
Je me. Souviens
et peut être le clone du sablier.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Et dans la négociation, là,
est ce que est ce que l'un de vous,
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le SI ?
C'est celui qui.
Ne sait pas ?
Si vous avez entendu parler d'une certaine
idée du sportif,
ça vous dit quelque chose ?
Les Aigles rouges disent Ah,
je suis sportif, vous vous connaissez je ?
Fortiche !
Et vous ?
Je me disais bien que vous ressemblez
à quelqu'un.
Flashback.
Et là,
je le regarde fixement dans les yeux
et je pars doucement en moonwalk.
Et quand on fait du bateau.
Et aussi surtout, ne parlez pas de
je suis sportif.
Mais comment ?
Je sais même pas si je m'en.
Fais sur lui.
C'est un. Vrai moonwalk.
Ouais.
Et je disparaître
dans un nuage de matière.
Il s'avance un peu vers toi.
Les Aigles rouges
et les gardiennes les arrêtent et
et disant vous approchez pas.
Une bienfaitrice du village
sans autorisation.
Est ce qu'il y a une gardienne qui.
Se calme et te fixe tous de loin ?
Ouais. Pendant que tu s'éloigne.
Mais je m'éloigne en faisant.
De loin,
on voit que c'est la mère de Camille.
Est ce que.
C'est pas.
Surtout qu'il faut que je remonte
la colline en moonwalk ?
Et est ce qu'il y aurait par hasard
une gardienne qui serait
un peu plus proche de moi,
qui je pourrais encore un peu parler ?
Tu veux rester ou tu veux partir ?
Je peux faire du joueur, non,
tu vas dans le.
Groupe, ça tu. T'en vas, mais.
Non. Je.
M'en vais
donc c'est bien fait.
C'est super.
Alors Eglantine.
C'était pas très ouvert à mes chakras
désolé. J'ai fait ce.
Que j'ai eu des informations sur moi.
Pas grand chose à vrai dire,
c'était pas très intéressant.
Que voilà, vous
savez.
Une tortue.
La vache.
Alors là, j'ai un peu le sommeil.
Remettez. Pas de médaille verte.
Donc du coup, là, nous, on est avec Lucie
qui a vu une débandade.
Oh là là, y'a pas gagner des points,
mais moi.
Ça lui confirme un peu sa supériorité.
Sur mon compteur, on voit. Bien.
Enfin bon, enfin là, je suis désolé Lucie.
Vous voyez bien ce que vous voyez,
je vous assure,
il y a des fois ils valent le coup.
Ainsi. Que des. Vrais.
Donne vraiment une.
Preuve d'information
que c'est un malin, mais.
C'est juste sur leur
parce que vous lui parler de Flappy
et de Jenny dans un laboratoire,
mais en dehors c'est un crapaud, un.
Sensible crapaud.
C'est parce qu'ils ont.
Un crapaud vert, c'est incroyable.
Et en même temps,
je donne un petit coup de coude à Frédo.
En plus, ils ont cru que j'étais clean.
Je la regarde, on y va.
Vous partez du coup, donc
vous vous arrivez sur un endroit ou il y a
pas mal de véhicules qui sont arrêtés.
Lucie Vous avez sur le.
Chemin ou. Sur ?
En fait, c'est
un peu en périphérie de la vie de Lucie.
Elle vous amène, elle
vous fait rentrer dans un des véhicules,
vous dit Bon, bah voilà, on y va.
Du coup, on parfois élixir.
Oui, je suppose
qu'on va directement au laboratoire
pour vous voulez pas parler à Beaulieu
de ce que j'ai.
Pas si on peut l'éviter pour l'instant,
si on peut partir direct.
Ça oui.
On va aller vite. Très bien le bougre.
Quand vous faites le trajet,
ça vous prend une bonne heure
moyenne de trajet en voiture.
Et vous, au bout d'un moment,
vous commencez à reconnaître
un peu le chemin que vous aviez suivi
lors de l'épisode un,
quand vous étiez allée à pied
pour accéder.
Aux galeries souterraines ?
Oui, ouais, avec un grillage,
le grillage, un grillage.
Et pas longtemps après.
Du coup, Lucie s'arrête.
Vous descendez du véhicule, vous dit Bomba
le laboratoire est juste à côté.
Donc autant qu'on passe par ce côté
comme ça, on est sûr d'éviter Écolo.
Ça marche. Plus si.
Vous entrez dans la.
Donc, on est Alexia.
Vous êtes à dans le secteur sans calcul.
Ah ouais.
C'est bien le retour. De Jamie.
Est ce que
vous voulez directement aller voir Gaston
ou vous voulez faire quelque chose ?
Est ce qu'on va voir le parc ?
Je vois Céline
et Céline à.
Ah oui.
On va voir Céline.
On va voir
Céline va vous chercher un peu Céline.
Vous finissez par la croiser, vous dira
Vous êtes déjà de retour.
Vous ? Déjà.
Ça s'est bien déroulé au. Départ.
Vous allez aller
en toute sécurité à Gaia ?
Je ne peux pas vous en dire plus.
Que je me sens jamais plus petite.
Mais sachez que c'est bien passé.
Mais ça ne marche pas avec Hélène.
Non mais du coup, tout ce que vous êtes
allés faire dans le gaillard.
Non, non, je ne peux pas vous en parler.
Mais Hélène va bien, d'accord.
Et elle a droit à.
Merci à Julie de rire.
Vous n'avez rien de d'autre.
On aurait pu mentir,
on aurait pu dire oui et non.
En fait, pas du tout.
La tournée La Chose.
Mais bon, dommage, c'est
pas une opportunité.
Son visage s'illumine
d'un sourire quand même.
Et ce changement
qu'elle nous donne bague dans
son alliance de mariage.
On ne peut pas la définir.
Selon le sexe. Oui, merci.
Ah ouais,
mais vous voulez quelque chose en retour ?
Ce que vous allez péter à Gaillard ?
Est ce qu'on pourrait pour.
Sauver ce qu'on
a traversé comme ça ? Je lui ai dit parce
maintenant elle me
dit Vous voulez quelque chose maintenant ?
Si, si, si.
Elle vous fait dans.
Je sais pas trop
ce que je peux vous offrir.
Je ne sais pas. Vous avez quoi vous ?
Si vous avez besoin de moi,
que vous passez par Gaïa,
je saurai.
Je suis prête à prendre n'importe quoi.
Seule une petite question peut être ça
vous parle même ?
Peut être que je des sabliers ou ou
une Lucie ?
Bon, les gens, ça va pas dans la table.
La balle.
Vous l'avez jamais vu, je trouve.
Alors merci Céline.
Je pense que c'est le moment
d'aller voir Gaston en
avoir.
Gaston pense à moi moi,
je rentre chez nous.
Vous allez vers la salle de Gaston.
La salle a 4 à 4.
Ainsi Victor
qui est devant qui vous accueilli ?
Bonjour Victor.
Bonjour.
De retour, oui, c'est comme toujours.
Ce Victor
nous a dit de revenir.
On revient ?
Oui, mais je pense que vous allez revenir.
Si, plutôt que Bones a vite fait,
le tour est censé être prêt
seulement au bout d'une semaine,
il fait trois jours.
C'est pas prêt. Là
encore, dans quatre jours.
D'après les calculs de Gaston,
dans quatre jours minimum.
Oui, ne vous inquiétez pas,
on a trouvé quelque chose sur le chemin
qui pourrait l'intéresser.
Pour ça, on est venu. Il y a cette dame.
Voilà Lucie, Lucie
qui pense pouvoir vous aider.
D'accord, ce qu'elle nous a dit,
je suppose que ça ne coûte rien
d'écouter ce qu'elle a dit et je pense.
Que ça coûtera.
Et du coup, qu'importe.
Au bout de cinq minutes,
ce garçon qui dit oui, oui,
bonjour, c'est tentant de désactiver
toutes les machines à arrêter
des conneries.
Bonjour,
non désolé, c'est le gars encore prêt.
Mais vous inquiétez pas, on a fait
une rencontre sur le chemin, vous allez.
Accélérer le processus.
Qui se présente. Qui dit bonjour.
Je m'appelle Lucie
et je sais comment retrouver mon passé.
Gaston je dis bizarre quand même.
Et vous voyez les deux ?
S'isole un peu et qui commence à discuter.
Et Gaston qui a l'air comme un fou
et qui fait des réglages à tout va cool.
C'est un moment ou le n'est
pas à côté de Pierre.
Elle précise.
Que si c'est passé, alors.
C'est un délire.
Vite, ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'en.
Fait.
Lucie
a pour but tout simplement
de nous renvoyer dans le présent.
Ouais, c'est juste qu'elle.
Comment dire ?
Bah Voilà,
elle est sympa quoi ? C'est tout.
Mais non. Elle nous aime pas. Non,
elle vous aime pas.
En fait, elle avait peur pour moi.
Au début, elle s'est dit
Ah mais c'est qui ces gens là ?
Franchement, est ce.
Que moi. Vous êtes arrivé avec nous ?
Pourquoi elle aurait des raison
d'avoir peur de nous ?
Non, mais c'est
les gens qui sont craintifs comme ça.
Fin, je veux dire, tu vis dans le noir
tout le temps comme ça.
C'est les gens, ils développent des peurs.
Je pense que c'est normal
et de toute façon, là,
elle est en train de nous aider.
Elle va nous aider à retourner
dans le présent, ce. Qu'elle va pas.
Est ce qu'elle va pas vous faire partir,
vous et nous, et va nous laisser là. Bas.
Qui. Elle aurait pu vous laisser
dans le bon ?
Après.
Qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
pour l'acheter ?
Pour l'acheter quoi ? Pour ?
Elle va juste expliquer à Gaston
vous voyez.
Mais qu'est ce qu'elle cherche elle ?
Mais oui, c'est.
Pourquoi elle nous aide tout simplement.
La famille.
Je vous rejoins, on avait un peu.
Moins la famille et puis.
La famille.
Et puis c'est pour l'entraide familiale.
Et puis peut être moi
seul va venir visiter le présent.
Moi je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est le labo.
Souterrain.
Alors qu'elle travaille
sur la même chose que Gaston.
Pourquoi elle se cache ?
Gaston, il ne se cache pas.
Pourquoi on est venu pour venir.
Vous poser beaucoup de
questions et moi je vous dire
est ce que vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui peut vous ramener dans le présent ?
Ben oui. Gaston, Gaston.
Gaston,
il a dit Ah oui. Je d'un prototype.
Le Dr Gaston. Il m'a pas l'air
fiable à 100%.
Lucie, je ne l'ai vu de mes yeux vu.
Elle est venue. Elle m'a dit Salut.
Vous avez vu une espèce de boule
lumineuse, là ?
Non, non, une force.
Ingrid, qui fait partie d'une institution
qui travaille dans un cadre.
Paramilitaire qui terrorise les gens ?
Non, il fait partie d'une institution
scientifique notable à horizon.
Excusez moi, mais je l'ai fait sous
la houlette de Science Quit, peut être.
D'une organisation para.
Terroriste
de pire en pire.
Qui martyrise la population autochtone.
Certes, on est, on a un territoire occupé,
mais excusez moi, mais votre big boss
qui travaille à monter.
Nos. Autoritarisme
dans un régime autoritariste
qui maltraite ses citoyens.
Ils ne sont pas maltraités.
Regardez Céline là,
elle était contente tout à l'heure.
Enfin, mais enfin à 0 h 05, moi,
je suis du côté de Lucie.
Vous le dit ?
Oui, Lucie,
elle travaillait alors franchement,
les scientifiques
qui travaillent tout seul
dans un laboratoire souterrain, j'en
ai jamais entendu du mal personnellement.
C'est vrai que moi, ce.
Que j'en ai déjà vu,
c'est un général qui font les découvertes
qu'on ne veut pas nous dire.
Les scientifiques
tout seuls dans des souterrains.
Ouais.
C'est pas les grosses institutions,
ça c'est des balivernes.
On va pas commencer à croire ces gens là.
C'est
sur le Berlu qui sortent de nulle part.
Enfin Gloria, ce que vous en dites
lui rien.
Je pense qu'elle veut rentrer chez elle.
Non mais moi je.
Ben je veux essayer
ce qui est déjà en place.
Donc si cette Lucie a une
solution qu'on peut essayer
comme vous voulez, mais c'est maintenant
chose faite.
À côté de ça
tous ces imposteurs qui se font passer
pour des vrais scientifiques.
OK, dernier argument pour moi
vous avez envie de changer
le monde du spolié, mais tout ça est de
vos mieux.
Joséphine moi sur.
Un je l'ai vaut deux tu l'auras.
Et là on a un n'avoir de transfert
dans le passé,
je suis extrêmement pas clair.
Facile de passer un certain moment.
Quand j'ai parcouru déjà.
Au bout d'un moment, moi,
ça me casse la gueule.
Vous m'avez perdu à Rome.
Est ce que vous, si vous voulez.
Pas moi, vous m'avez convaincu
au techno autoritarisme ?
Voilà que moi, je me sens bien,
vous aussi, là pour vous.
Non, mais ça devient carrément fort là.
En plus, regardez là, elle a les yeux.
Là, mais alors
elle aurait envoyé une lettre machin.
Elle a envoyé rien.
Attendez, j'ai réussi.
J'ai pu créer une brèche dans l'espace
temps
qui m'a permis de voir le passé
le temps d'un instant.
Oui, c'est bon, la vue de votre.
Homme, ça rime ?
Non, je pense qu'on
a tout à gagner à aller avec lui.
Avec Lucia, Gaston qui s'exclame
d'un coup qui dit Mais c'est du génie !
Eurêka !
Puis qui pas ?
Vous avez du génie ?
Ça, c'est ma descendance, ça.
Regarde ce qui se passe et s'approche
de vous et vous dit
Je pense que c'est près.
Wow !
C'est comme la grosse fête.
On s'entraîne,
mais on est quand même content.
Est ce qu'on peut avoir une ?
Comment est ce qu'on pourrait être sûr
que ça marche avant de le tester sur moi ?
Parce que là, on envoie l'autre à lui.
Je me sens cobaye. Présent.
Et c'est tous en même temps.
Alors comme cobayes.
Gaston, lui, sait comment ça marche,
mais est ce qu'on pourra avoir une preuve.
Que ça va marcher ensuite ?
Elle aussi,
elle explique qu'elle l'a déjà fait.
Mais quand ça marche, on est tous dans
une pièce et on se rend tous ensemble.
Comme on est arrivé, c'est la même chose.
Vous vous mettez dans la queue,
c'est la queue dans laquelle vous
vous étiez arrivé.
Il faut se trouver la salle
à quatre, c'est le processus inverse.
D'accord, donc, on est tous.
Ah oui, on va retrouver des boules
d'énergie qui nous touchent et tout
est ok. OK.
Donc on est tous dans la même pièce,
on voit les choses en même temps. Il
vous êtes.
Est ce qu'on peut prendre juste quelques
petits trucs, quelques petits souvenirs.
Le bougre.
Justement,
qu'est ce que vous gardez sur vous
et qu'est ce que glissez dans le futur
dans les affaires que vous avez ?
Moi, j'ai rien. Est
ce. Qu'on a la recette du en.
Parlant ? Oui.
Ah oui, oui. Continuez à noter.
Moi je garde la recette. Évidemment,
on n'a plus la cape.
Et donc. On n'a plus besoin.
De ça, note madame Églantine.
Donc moi je bien sur la machette.
Donc c'est sûr.
Il y en a une qui me disait
fais ta gueule.
Je vous donnerai la recette quand on sera
arrivé à la barre, vous inquiétez pas.
Ça marche.
Super.
Non, je garde mon OK.
C'est ce que je garde, moi.
Est ce que j'ai d'autres choses ?
Pourquoi je les prends ?
Je les garde manger des batteries ?
Ah oui, l'argent aussi. Je garde.
Mais voilà, je garde Google
parce que tu gardes ta torche.
C'est la seule qui a encore une torche.
Ah oui, il faut des choses
pour préparer le futur.
Moi je voulais.
La torche et les recharges.
Moi j'ai ma pile une pile l'emmènent,
mais je sais pas si on fait les choses
comme une là dedans, vous inquiétez pas.
Ouais. Oui.
Je ne mets pas
Google dans la mallette. En.
Ce. Sur.
Un dernier petit tour, prendre des torche.
Pour le voyage. En fait, c'est plus là.
Qu'est ce que vous vous cachez
concrètement ?
Se cache.
Sous Gaston et va pas vous laisser partir
avec. La.
Question.
C'est ce qu'est ce Google
dans un salopette ?
OK, ça marche.
Bon, il faudrait un truc
qui me dit que c'est pas une bonne chose.
Je ne crois. Pas.
Après, on pourra.
Donc. Ça se teste.
Il faudrait, hein ?
Ça saute au test, ça de quoi ?
Puis ce test, c'est
notre parole contre celle des autres.
Oui, mais on va leur dire écoutez
le podium, ça brûle, ça fait du moral
et on le test, quoi.
Selon une réaction de Landolt.
Oui mais si ta société
elle est pas prête à te croire.
Mais prouve.
C'est de la science.
Lucie, elle n'a.
Pas ramené quelqu'un du. Futur.
Elle, elle a. Créé. Un paradoxe
ce n'est pas possible.
Ah oui, non, c'est pas.
C'est ça aussi.
Ça m'intéresse pas ça.
Comment vous imaginez les dégâts
qu'elle pourrait faire ?
Elle connaît tout ce qui s'est passé.
Ça va perturber la croissance.
La charcuterie,
sa progéniture.
Fin d'un n'a jamais été question
qu'elle vienne avec nous.
Nous avons maintenant.
Maintenant, j'ai compris, j'ai déjà
un chien.
C'est un peu dangereux je trouve.
Mais alors un humain.
Laisse tomber quoi ?
Google ne va pas se créer une.
Auditrice, le Monde
si pas le Monde sans casser des oeufs.
Mais on a jusqu'à demain.
La recette en.
Russie et on a une. Piste de pourquoi.
Ça fout la merde ?
On va voir les scientifiques,
on leur dit voilà ça.
Vous faites gaffe parce que.
Et là il y a la science.
Hypothèse test pour tester en mieux.
Ben oui, pour un test.
Il ne peut pas lancer notre industrie
de spoliant qui sera en plus un monopole.
Et à ce moment là.
C'est nous qui le sont. Pas.
Ils n'ont pas compris.
Que si il faut du spoliant.
Vert, oui.
Et si ça sert c'est OK.
Si C'est ça.
On y va, on y va. Non,
c'est le pétrole qui nous tue.
Non, c'est pas ce que je veux dire.
Le charbon, on y va. C'est parti.
Attendez, on ne peut pas aussi.
Je ne suis pas comme ça. C'est chose
qui. Va rester dans les annales du.
Monde. Super libéral.
Alors voilà, super.
Vous allez vous placer dans la cuve
du coup tous les deux.
Oui, nous on y va.
On s'agrippe à on serre la main.
Viens avec toi.
Lucie.
Là, je parle à Lucie.
Si dans le micro,
il faut lui parler à Lucie, Lucie a.
Plus dans le mitard.
Comment dire,
il faut que vous feignons secrète.
De rester dans la salle.
Cachez vous par là, là,
une fois que vous serez là bas,
on sera devant le fait accompli.
Puis c'est tout. Bah
voilà, j'ai pas d'autres.
Tu pars sans.
Ben non, elle reste cachée quoi.
Il y a des meubles dans la cuve neuve.
Est ce qu'on peut pas demander à quand.
On est venu quand. Vous arrivez,
si vous êtes sortis du lit ?
Un monde inconnu, moi.
Dans un bureau avant ça.
Est ce qu'on peut pas demander à Gaston
qui nous donne des petites indications
sur cette machine.
Ce truc ?
Oui, on n'a pas. On n'a pas écouté Gaston.
Gaston
Comment vous avez réussi à débloquer
votre votre prototype ?
Il explique en gros.
Un truc que je comprends rien.
Super.
J'aurais dit en fait
c'était la clé de voûte de machin est. OK.
Et en fait je n'avais pas compris que ça
cette ça ne marchait pas dans ce cas
dans ce cas là,
mais ça a marché dans l'autre sens.
Et du coup, l'huissier
m'a expliqué comment il fallait faire.
Du coup pour déséquilibrer le système,
je change pas quoi ?
Tu coupe. Et Claude ? Merci Gaston.
Est ce que vous voulez pas qu'on qu'on
amène un document dans le passé
qui pourrait être transmis en faisant
attention à ce qu'il soit bien conservé ?
Et quand vous éviterez
je ne sais pas qu'est ce que OK ?
Non mais très bien.
Je propose quoi du coup ?
Je sais pas de quoi.
Et vous n'aurez pas
une caméra sous la main
pour faire quoi ?
Une petite preuve
que le monde est en ruine.
Il y a des photos.
Il y a un iPhone, une photo.
Te donne une photo de. Moi.
Je pense qu'on a pas une fois.
Des journaux peut être
là, j'en ai pas sur moi.
Peut être que si vous allez raison,
vous pourriez en trouver
un peu pressé.
Parce que là on va se réchauffer
par des angles rouges, vont nous.
Mettre en prison.
Non mais ça ira
la photo et ma bonnette la photo.
Prenez une photo avec votre montre.
Le 6 mai dans le cul, alors non.
Par contre,
qu'est ce que vous faites, Lucien.
Alors que c'est lui ?
Si elle vient avec nous. Alors non.
On vote en démocratie.
Mais on ne va pas ramener Gaston.
On ne va pas ramener quelqu'un de futur
avec nous, c'est pas possible.
Je parle à Gaston,
je sais pas pourquoi pas.
Mais vous imaginez le paradoxe
que ça va créer par quoi ?
On a déjà créé un peu en changement ici.
C'est surtout.
Qu'elle a passé. Sa grimace.
Ecoutez moi, ce que Lucie m'a expliqué,
c'est qu'elle vient du passé aussi
et qu'elle s'est transportée dans le futur
et qu'elle était en train
d'essayer de reconstruire pour.
Nous comme nous.
Du tout, pas du tout.
Avant nous, Lucio
l'a rencontré ici, nous a jamais dit ça.
Mais parce qu'elle m'a dit Vous l'avez
rencontrée dans son laboratoire
ou elle a essayé de faire une machine
pour rentrer chez elle ?
Ouais. Non, non. Non, non. Non, non.
Non. C'est la descendante de Pierre-Alain
et qu'elle
essaie de l'aider à rentrer chez lui.
Il y a Lucie.
Elle s'énerve, dit
Vous pouvez pas tenir vos sbires là.
Vous. Spiralée bien me soule.
C'est quoi ces conneries ?
Pierre Messmer, sbire, c'est les pires.
Je suis désolée, Lucie.
Est ce que je réponds moi,
je fais ce que je peux.
J'ai de.
La chance.
Mais non.
Faut qu'on force Gaston à nous renvoyer.
Et tant pis pour un.
1860.
Il y a Frédo qui te met une énorme tarte.
Si tu perds un. Point de
ça va pas. Bien là.
On Franky. Qui ?
Pierre-Alain et moi,
je lui fais la cloche.
Attendez un.
Échec critique.
Non, c'est pas comme ça.
Il n'y a pas de sbires.
C'est quoi ces conneries ?
Maintenant Gaston,
il ne faut pas ramener cette folle là.
Non, non, non, on ne peut pas ramener.
Vous imaginez ce qu'elle pourrait faire
avec tout ce qu'elle sait ?
C'est grâce à elle que vous pouvez rentrer
quand même.
Oui, d'accord pour ça, merci bien madame.
Oui ça il n'y a pas de soucis.
Mais imaginez.
Elle baise avec son arrière grand père.
Ah bah ouais je suis crue.
Mais bon, à un. Moment donné quoi ?
C'est ça les paradoxes, c'est vrai.
Bon, vous avez pas. Vu Futurama.
Un livre. Sur. Le judo ?
Vous dites que c'était pas comme ça
parce qu'il ne faut pas.
De littérature française, je. Sais pas.
Donc je suis vraiment l'histoire,
parce que.
Tout ce que j'ai, c'est quelqu'un qui dit
non, non, il ne faut pas la ramener.
Elle vient de Hollande,
c'est la descendante de Machin,
mais elle a jamais dit que c'était la
descendante de Machin et elle de son côté.
Elle m'a ramené une théorie qui fonctionne
complètement et qui résout mon équation.
Je pense qu'elle a passé.
Vous pensez que si.
Elle était de notre époque,
elle aurait les connaissances
pour faire du voyage dans le temps ?
Mais je n'en sais rien.
Mais tout le monde sait
que si elle a les connaissances
pour faire du voyage dans le temps, c'est
pas déconnant
qu'elle c'était voyager dans le temps.
Ah oui, mais pas. Qu'elle vienne du passé.
Oui, mais la faire va revenir
dans le temps par elle même.
En fait, elle a pas besoin
de nous maintenant, a priori.
Et pourquoi elle va rentrer avec nous
alors ?
Mais pour le sommet de la machine
challenge ?
Oui ça.
Mais moi je le dis
parce que c'est pas facile.
Alors elle te dit c'est pas facile
à fabriquer une machine de matériaux ?
Oui, d'accord,
mais après viens voir Gaston.
Dans deux semaines,
il tapote et Pia hésite.
Elle vient nous rejoindre ?
Oui, ou en. L'an 1200 ?
Oui, autant dire que c'est
pas Gaston.
Il ne faut pas laisser les gens
voyager dans le temps.
Déjà,
il faut arrêter vos conneries de voyage.
Pas vous nous avez déjà kidnappés,
c'est sûr.
C'était la première erreur.
Il faut arrêter maintenant.
Je vous renvoie pas chez vous.
Si, parce qu'on
essaye de réparer quand on fait erreur.
Gaston
Et puis on vous a bien rendu service, on.
Arrête les bêtises.
Oui, d'accord, j'essaie de réparer, oui,
mais pas avec.
Elle. Elle a laissé pas de réparer.
Non mais elle, c'est une nouvelle erreur.
Gaston la vous mettez dans un merdier.
Sauf que nous
on était con comme des quilles.
Donc on vous envoie dans le passé. Mais
elles ont l'heure, on voit pas chez elles.
Pourquoi elle vient pas du passé. Gaston.
Bien du puisque.
Vous en savez, mais parce.
Que nous, à notre époque.
On pas voyager dans le temps.
Le dire, c'était tel qu'elle l'a fait.
Vous avez vu ? Oui.
Parce qu'elle vient de maintenant.
Est ce qu'on voit
comment déclencher le rouet ?
Ce qu'on peut débloquer, c'est.
Gaston qui peut lancer cette optique.
À la place, pendant que lui,
maintenant, il parle avec Gaston.
Elle a des
connaissances que, à notre époque, on pas.
On n'avait pas les bases,
on. S'envoie nous même.
Ouais, comme on n'a pas les bases,
on peut laisser Frédo gagner.
Enfin.
La médaille,
ça peut durer encore un grand.
Moment.
Gaston, il vous dit bon,
qui veut retourner dans le passé ? Moi
mais je vous dis Gaston, à l'époque,
la romaine, c'est une connerie.
Pourquoi ?
Parce
qu'elle ne vient pas de notre époque.
C'est je ne sais pas.
Comment vous le prouver.
Je ne sais pas.
Vous n'avez pas changé quoi ?
Ça va créer des paradoxes.
Ça se voit que vous avez pas
des films de science fiction ?
Je ne vais pas vous renvoyer, vous, non,
ils vont me parano.
Parce que vous avez que.
Vous, vous avez des connaissances
dont vous avez peut être changé.
Le monde aussi.
Non, non, Lucien. Sera bien lui.
On va juste continuer notre vie
tranquillou. Vous inquiétez pas, pas.
Juste voir la Joséphine.
Moi, je suis pour que Lucie.
Mais si en plus.
Franchement,
je vois pas la différence entre.
Le lieutenant
en riant un peu quand. Même.
Votre objectif, c'était de nous renvoyer
et qu'on puisse
éventuellement vous aider un. Peu
à éviter.
C'est vrai que
vu que
nous, on peut arriver en.
Catastrophe maintenant. Moi.
C'est bien de.
Dédramatiser un Là. Je parle à Gaston.
Gissing penche vers lui jeudi.
La Lucie, là, on ne sait pas.
C'est pas de Walvis,
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle peut faire.
Action, réaction,
elle pourrait ruiner nos efforts.
Lucie répond de loin, dit Je viens de 2023
et j'ai aucun problème avec le fait
qu'on arrête
de produire du podium.
Moi, je trouve ce horrible.
Mais voilà gagné.
Argument.
Je suis désolé Monsieur, mais
vous venez de perdre votre joute
argumentaire.
Gaston
Bine myope, Scotty A.
Envoie moi dans le passé
Gaston.
Mais la bonne année non pas oui.
La bonne année, on rigole pas.
Se connaissant, on meurt d'un truc.
Je ne sais pas qui imagine. 2029.
Attendez bien en 2017, on se revoit nous.
Est ce que vous avez bien
une photo du Protocoles
des Sages de Sion
dans l'autre de protocole ?
Vous avez tout faux
pas car. Moi j'ai tous mes papiers.
Bien.
C'est pas une.
Photo de moi,
je n'ai plus mon nom, j'ai plus mon texte.
Mais cette façon, j'ai jamais
réussi à le lire.
C'est pas facile.
J'ai vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
difficulté sur cette discussion
de renvoi à Lucie dans le passé ou pas.
Ils ont fait un sondage
dans le. Temps, à savoir.
Est ce que Lucie retourne dans le passé
ou pas ?
Le Château a dit que
oui, c'est vrai. Dans le passé,
j'étais, c'est bon, j'étais bougon.
Mais oui, Lucie est
franchement bonne patronne.
Donc vous rentrez tous les cinq
dans la cuve.
On est un peu sévère.
Du reste.
S'il y a plusieurs il.
Il ne.
Peut commencer à entendre du bruit.
En non.
Votre vision de défendre votre camp
ne vous répond plus ?
Oh, jamais je viens répondre.
Des flashes de lumière
se font de plus en plus rapides.
Tu voudrais que vous ayez déjà
vécu cette expérience ?
Vous êtes bien conscient que votre corps
ne s'habitue sûrement jamais.
Une fois que vous, une fois de plus,
vous êtes pris de nausées.
Mais cette fois, vous n'avez pas peur.
Vous êtes même rassuré.
Les flashes se mettent à ralentir.
Vous reprenez doucement vos esprits,
tous allongés au sol, la salle de stockage
à quatre s que vous ne connaissez,
baignés d'une lueur rouge.
À peine le temps de vous redresser
qu'un bruit de sonnette se fait entendre.
L'éclairage revient à la normale,
les portes de la salle se déverrouille
avant de s'ouvrir
sur les couloirs du complexe Elixir.
Voix s'élèvent pour
Un certain regard.
On y retourne.
Mais du coup, oui, c'est vrai
qu'on est encore ici avec nous.
Vous êtes tous dans la salle.
Il y a également Bouge et Lucie.
Vous avez quelques. Surprises.
Au lieu de vous que vous avez transporté.
Donc maintenant, on va faire
un petit petit prologue à toute l'histoire
pour savoir un peu
qu'est ce que deviennent vos personnages
après ces aventures ?
La première chose que je vais
vous demander, c'est vos relations à vous.
Quatre. Qu'est ce que ça va devenir ?
Est ce que vous ne connaissez pas
à l'origine.
Qui se connaissait ?
Je connaissais, mais de.
Voilà une relation tumultueuse.
Bah on peut décider de voir genre
une fois
en allant à la date de disparition.
Voilà. C'est ça.
Juste une rencontre insupportable
à chaque fois, je suppose.
Putain, qu'est ce qu'on devient ?
On va faire un an. Voilà.
Sinon,
on s'écrit un peu des textos le lendemain.
Non, mais après.
Trois mois, ma réponse, elle va.
Dépendre de
tout ce que je fais, ce que je veux.
Ils vont faire en fait.
Alors
je ne peux pas répondre cette promesse.
Tu peux dire à partir de demain là
comment tu vois les autres,
parce que toi, tu veux rentrer chez toi.
Tu vois en soit, tu peux complètement
reprendre son train de vie
lorsqu'on parlera jamais de moi,
il y a des choses que je veux faire.
Oui, mais ça, on va voir un truc.
Mais d'un point de vue relation,
tu veux tisser des liens.
Ouvrir à une traduction de Joël.
À un an et à personne que je veux
complètement oublier ?
Non, en fait,
j'ai presque envie de me surveiller.
Lucie, tu
et les autres, c'est cette époque.
Ben ça va quoi ?
Je leur tiens pas d'animosité en tout cas.
Vous êtes tous pote.
En gros, il y a des gens qui veulent pas
s'entendre.
Oui, non, non, non, c'est cordial,
c'est courageux, hein.
C'est d'être très ami avec un oui entier.
Non pour pour relation commerciale.
Voilà ce qu'ils font.
Vont développer le podium.
Je que moi je vais relancer mon chantier
le plus vite possible.
Donc je voudrais bien que la cci
arrête avec ces travaux.
Et là la cci termine elle s'en fout
un peu.
D'accord. Est ce que vous allez.
Voir que l'avenir est ailleurs ?
Si tu veux, c'est qu'ils sont.
Ravis de se dégrader.
Et moi
je serai de chacun de vos chantiers.
POF. Jamais.
Pas un problème, un problème.
Parce que là
ce qu'on va devenir c'est que la Cci
et la nouvelle entreprise vont j'imagine.
FLA, fla. Fla, fla, fla.
Fla, po.
Un financeur incroyable
de l'archéologie du projet Nouvel Horizon.
Bonne nouvelle, c'est le nouveau.
Horizon, quoi. Alors les fouilles.
C'est super comme ça.
Et venez, on va faire
une conférence de presse bientôt
pour parler de à quel point l'archéologie
c'est génial et à quel point la Cci.
Tout au logo.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et Flahaut génial !
OK c'est pas moi, c'est moi.
C'est comme ça que je vois le futur.
Chapeau à beaucoup
soutenir les femmes aussi dans la vie,
dans la recherche, pour trouver un
emploi ou même sans flatter.
J'ai faire un.
Petit tour de table rapidement. Gloria
ton site de fouille,
tu le reprends ou tu l'arrête ?
Bah non,
je l'arrête et je vais prospecter ailleurs
parce que j'ai vu ce que c'était.
Alors je dirais que j'ai pas assez de sous
pour continuer
la fouille
et j'aimerais bien aller. Moi,
je veux continuer de
je ne sais pas.
Je pense que je vais faire un musée
sur l'archéologie du futur.
D'accord.
Je aligne les millions
de signaux.
Ils ont un fond génial.
La musique, c'est un musée.
Retournons sur l'archéologie future
qui va voir le jour à Horizon.
Je vois l'ouverture de la banderole
Là, Patrick, on coupe le ruban.
L'important. C'est de fouiller.
Le site de fouilles est abandonné.
Finalement,
tu arrêtes de te battre là dessus.
Donc au final, le chantier de centrale
reprend comme c'était prévu à l'origine.
On a même pas eu besoin d'autobus pour ça.
La centrale sera construite à cet endroit.
Peut être augmenter un peu
la sécurité du générateur
comme ça.
Mais.
Et la secte de la lune noire du coup
ne pourra pas prendre personne.
C'est Dieu.
À intuition. La Lune.
Donc tu évite la création d'une secte.
Oh là là, là.
Un personne à la grenouille.
Même moi je ne sais pas si.
Bien. Alors
est ce que tu vas faire
ton troisième mandat ?
Tout était en cours de ton deuxième
mandat. Tu étais au début de ton année.
Est ce que tu vas à la fin de son deuxième
mandat, aller sur ton troisième ?
Ou alors tu pars à ta retraite
et tu essaies de vivre des beaux jours
tranquillement.
Je pense que donc
je vais pour le troisième mandat,
mais sauf que pendant le temps à voir
ce que va faire Eglantine, mais je pense
qu'on a vraiment une bonne boite
à créer un truc.
Une petite idée
qui raconte quelque chose quoi.
Donc là on va s'arranger, c'est ça ?
Donc tu continues sur son troisième.
Mandat ou sur mon troisième mandat ?
Mais l'arrête dès que ça part.
Là, c'est juste pour faire,
pour faciliter les prêts,
ok que ça facilite les choses quoi.
Pour huiler un peu le système.
Je suis clairement lubrifiant économique.
Peut être oublier une information
que tu avais eu lors de l'épisode deux,
mais tu finiras par perdre la vie
lors de troisième mandat.
Mais je vais pas le faire.
En fait, en 2030.
Si tu le fais, tu le fais.
Tant pis.
Maintenant, mais c'est.
Déjà trop tard.
Oui, en 2030, j'abandonne.
Je suis super riches,
les gens riches ne meurent pas.
Mais du coup, il y aura une rue de raison
qui sera géniale.
Moi, je le disais la domination mondiale.
OK, d'accord.
Mais ta descendante, du coup
Lucie prendra le relais.
Super, je bosse avec elle. Super
chef.
Frédo, non ?
Fred, que
pose votre question ?
Qu'est ce que tu fais alors ?
Temps que tu es actuellement.
Concierge Est ce que tu continues à vivre
en tant que concierge ?
Carpentier qui te et ?
Oui, mais non.
C'est à dire que. Je.
Reste un temps parce que tout de suite
je vais voir
les scientifiques que je connais.
Parce que bon, les depuis autant de temps
que moi, tu reviens,
tu vois, tu connais les gens
et je leur explique quoi ?
Je leur dis là.
Vous êtes en train de travailler
sur une connerie
sans nom, ils sont pas en train
de travailler dessus.
Je dis qu'il y a une entreprise
qui est en train de se monter la Flappy.
Chapeau Flappy Flap ils sont bref,
ça va peut être changer de nom,
ils vont
et donc j'explique se dit voilà,
ils vont bosser sur le podium.
Il faut absolument pas les laisser faire.
Et donc j'ai explique
parce que ça va créer
du par du paranormal
et ça va faire une réaction de Landolt.
Et elle va être détruit.
Et j'ai une photo avec moi de
Duck action de Landolt.
Oui, de Landolt.
J'ai un autre truc que je ferai
d'abord dis moi ce qui se passe,
si ça sent bon, je peux le dire.
Je continue de travailler.
Combien de temps elle tient ?
Non, mais pas longtemps.
Genre Une ou deux semaines, j'en ai quand
je leur dis ça.
Et ensuite je deviens lanceur d'alerte.
Je crée un blog
sur lequel un blog et
page Facebook sur lequel je alerte.
Un truc qui n'existe pas.
Ça va.
Se développer.
Attention Flanby, ils vont détruire.
L'atmosphère avec. Le paranormal.
Après je suis concierge
donc c'est pas très bien rédigé.
Ça fait très que théorie du.
Complot,
voilà à quoi ça peut être. Complot.
C'est un comique sans voilà.
Mais il y a toujours cette. Photo du vois.
Cette photo que j'ai récupéré, c'est.
Le truc et j'essaye de l'aiguille.
Il y a des gens qui suivent, qui vont.
Oui, oui, voilà,
c'est aux yeux du grand public.
C'est vraiment une théorie du complot
qui a vu le jour.
Ouais, mais je l'ai.
Expliqué aux scientifiques de.
Dickson parce que tu veux créer une secte.
C'est jamais noir.
Du coup, jusqu'à la mort.
Alexia
Eh oui Monsieur, moi je suis pas bête.
Accident le protocole petit, mais du coup
le protocole politique ne verra pas
le jour tout de suite
parce que c'était vraiment ta mort
qui avait fait beaucoup de bruit en fait,
et qu'il y a et
qui avait ralenti énormément
les recherches sur le symposium.
Mais vu qu'il y a eu un accident
qui n'a pas fait de victimes, au final,
on s'est je dis chiant
mais c'est pas grave, c'est que tu dégâts
matériels ou ça s'est développé de fou
et au final, les accidents
sont allés croissant avec le temps.
On a maintenant
un équivalent du protocole.
Petit a fini par être développé.
Oui oui mais moi j'ai prévenu qu'il y
allait avoir des merdes avec le symposium.
Quand ils ont commencé à le faire,
ils ont pas testé ma théorie
même si j'étais un illuminé
genre Didier Raoult.
On a quand même testé que l'hydroxyde,
l'organisme quoi qu'il arrive.
Mais le.
Pont de la Lune, tout.
Le podium, c'est quand même développé
à un moment donné.
Oui, d'accord,
mais moi je reviens sur ton truc après.
Du coup, il y a eu beaucoup d'accidents
parce que du coup,
je n'ai plus de victimes que ça.
Cobra super.
Mais au final,
ça a permis de ralentir la production.
Ce parce que du coup,
ça a été jugé extrêmement dangereux.
Et en plus de lancements d'alerte
qui ont été testés par des scientifiques,
ça va essayer
d'être ralentis le plus possible.
Donc le podium, ça reste quelque chose
que j'utilisais beaucoup moins.
Donc c'est très probable que vous finissez
par éviter la catastrophe.
Et Bugarach ici est devenu chiant.
Ce que tu. Veux, toi, il a bien vécu.
Oui, c'est ça.
Il te très utile de voter. Là.
Ou tu as ton entreprise.
Chapeau ! Laisse.
Tu travailles,
tu restes sur la découverte de pétrole
ou tu rebranche.
J'ai toujours dit
que j'étais sérial entrepreneuse,
donc là, je vais mener Flappy.
Le pot.
Parallèle, ça fait flap yo entre bien.
Flappy tombe à l'eau
et pour les kilos, c'était voulu.
Ah ouais ?
Inscrivez vous sur le site.
De la pétition Un Point et
c'est dans le deuxième succès de Beppe
Grillo.
Peut être.
Vous réservez. Le.
Je scroll.
Y a toujours ma tête.
Aurait.
Été très drôle,
non ?
Du coup,
pour cette reprise, flop d'entreprise,
la peau du cou, elle a été lancée avec.
Oui Pierre-Alain,
ça n'a pas. Fait son truc.
On est 55 de marche. Marche de jambes.
Les profits de Max Weber. Actionnariat.
Actionnariat 50 50.
Après, ce sera lui. Si
votre entreprise Flappy
du groupe Why,
qui était sur la découverte de pétrole,
il y a l'entreprise Ta tôle.
En pâte à tôle.
De la racheter à 400000€.
400400.
Dérivant. Là depuis cinq jours.
Franchement j'ai appris des meilleurs
pour essayer
de négocier et du coup je leur dis c'est
2 millions, rien en fait.
Quel hommage !
C'est vraiment une entreprise
qui va partir en mode exponentielle.
Vous voyez les profits ? Tout ça,
vous le savez.
Comme moi, on a trouvé un super gisement.
On va continuer d'en trouver d'autres.
Vraiment, vous pouvez me faire confiance.
C'est un peu comme si j'avais une boule
de cristal pour voir dans l'avenir.
C'est un bon investissement.
Donc 2 millions ou rien, c'est rien.
Mais oui, allez y de. 200 millions.
Attend à quel moment ils demandent ça.
Est ce que c'est avant 2030 ?
Oui, ça Vendredi.
Je vais demander conseil à mon bon ami.
Mais oui.
Et oui, quand on sait. Rien, rien du tout.
On y va. Domination mondiale ?
Ah oui.
Oui, c'est vrai que du coup, s'il
y a un échange avec toi,
tu te rends compte que Flappy c'est
du bullshit aboyant derrière.
Ah oui, c'est full bullshit.
On a trouvé par hasard ?
On a trouvé par hasard un gisement,
mais en fait c'est rien de plus.
D'accord. Mais en plus de l'arnaque.
On vend 2 millions comme elle l'a dit.
Génial, mais c'est Flappy
qui veut acheter de l'acheter.
Flappy a 400000 je croyais flat pot non ?
4400000. 300.
En 400000 400 millions. Millions et.
Il vend encore. Voilà.
400 millions.
Rien. Il refuse, il refuse. Tant pis.
Heureusement, je.
Serais à la négociation pour.
Remettre à la virgule. Même
à la virgule, nous même.
OK et chapeau du coup se porte bien.
Oui par contre ok.
Mais du coup Flappy est au courant
qu'il y a un protocole petit tout ça.
Et donc en fait
il n'y a pas d'accident de spoliant
mais en fait ça va super vite
et tout le monde est dans le noir.
Vu qu'il y a beaucoup d'accidents
sur les autres entreprises.
Ah oui vous, ça se développe mieux ?
Est ce que vous voulez faire attention
quand même à ce truc de paranormal
et trouver une solution et y mettre
un peu de recherche sur ce sujet ?
Ou vous vous en foutez complètement ?
Moi je dirais bien oui,
mais factuellement.
C'est contre productif.
Parce que c'est hors
jeu. D'autant plus ralentir le délicat.
Je crée un article par jour, tu.
Étudies dans le paranormal.
Tous les trois jours ?
Peut être, mais bon.
On s'y fait.
Regarde a Gaïa Marie, c'était c'était.
Fleuri.
Il y avait trois plantes dans les dents,
les lampes là, non l'inverse.
Et ils étaient contents.
Franchement. Non.
Le tout, c'est de bien investir
dans du ouais.
Dans du vert. Responsable. Ouais. Ouais.
Enfin du lumière.
Du coup, on dirait du phare,
mais à l'inverse de l'obscurité,
tu vois, on dit allons nous,
on finance la lumière.
On finance la lumière, la lumière du jour,
on fait du greenwashing
pour les femmes en Chine.
La compagnie, quoi ?
Voilà,
tout va bien dans le meilleur des mondes.
Donc non, on parle pas de morale, c'est
un mot interdit chez nous.
Tabou, ça se développerait ?
Oui, ça se développe, oui. Une chose.
Mais moi, je suis embêté un peu parce que
ça semble, comme les peintures rupestres.
Encore plus que le bruit.
Mais du coup. On est tous encore plus la.
Donc particules
noires finiront par arriver.
Vous, vous n'avez rien, je vais.
Vous forcer
avec des protocoles de conservation.
Oui, si vous voulez.
Parce que là, moi. Mais.
Non rejoint sur mon.
Oui et non.
Elle fait les plateaux.
Et quand on lui dit vous êtes le.
Petit côté sympa,
mais c'est pas ce que j'ai dit.
C'est vrai que le retour est difficile.
Quand même assez.
Gros.
Vous vous arrivez à freiner
la production du podium mondial ?
Flipo Et ils vendent ça
comme étant du podium propre.
Mais qu'ils ne sortent pas du paranormal,
ça ferait de ce problème.
C'est tellement pratique que
ça se développe, surtout si c'est propre.
Sauf qu'en fait, ils mentent
ce qu'ils sont en train d'expliquer.
Nous sommes comme doigts.
Donc malheureusement,
les particules finiront par arriver.
Et le chaos n'est pas.
La conclusion du Gildas.
Tout est la faute du capitalisme.
Et Lucie
juste elle a rien fait de mal à noyer
personne.
Lui ça crée un état de fait.
Toi t'es pas au courant,
mais du coup avec Pierre-Alain on fait.
Tous les choix de Pierre-Alain sont Régis
par ce que ça va changer dans le futur.
Ah grâce à Lucie, oui.
Mais toi tu ne le sais pas,
mais du coup tu dis
Pierre-Alain est un génie
parce qu'il fait que des choix
et à chaque fois qu'il en fait un mauvais,
il revient dessus.
Lendemain.
Moi je suis pas mort parce que c'est ça.
Les et c'est la vieillesse.
Non ?
On crève la. Mais
un plus tôt dans le futur
on trouve comment.
On migre, spoliant l'immortalité.
Oh petite, en fait, je l'aimais pas trop
au début, mais allait bien.
Noël.
Ce sera la fin de ce jeu de rôles là.
On a gagné, on est devenu.
Il faudrait qu'ils conservent leur gagner,
mais ils sont même comme ça.
C'est clair que c'est tout le monde.
L'histoire s'est créée, elle s'est écrite.
C'est le signe de son. C'était bien.
C'est pas qu'une question de fric.
Embrasser.
Non, c'est une question de rendre le monde
meilleur. Ça
pour vous ?
Vous êtes 32 personnes ?
Je sais pas.
Moi, j'aimerais bien.
Il déjà arrivé à se dire
que j'ai accompli quelque chose.
Comment tirer profit de la situation ?
Moi, je suis mort à faire des vidéos
YouTube.
Certes, tu vois leur vie.
Je pense que surtout
tu peux vraiment avoir ce truc là.
Tu sais à la base que ton truc,
il est un peu moyen moyen de lutter.
Rentrer dedans ?
Oui et c'est là.
Bah ouais mais non,
mais on ne peut pas arrêter quoi ?
Maintenant tu me fais reculer.
Bah non, qu'est ce que tu veux
en fait c'est même au bout de 50.
Et non, on voit même plus le Pandora,
le machin, on ne. Sait ça.
Toujours pas, non ?
Le but, c'est d'aider les gens.
Puis même légalement,
aux premières déclarations que t'as fait
qui monte, tu peux pas revenir dessus.
Après c'est foutu comme par normal.
C'est
un truc de blogueur ? Oui, complètement.
Franchement, personne a prouvé
que ça existait comme source.
Ici dans le jeu.
Mais vous avez quelques questions
et ce n'est pas ma foi.
Je me jette je pour pouvoir voyeur.
Si jamais vous avez posé juste avant,
j'ai pas vu parce que j'ai fait le truc
reposter.
C'est quoi la réaction de Landolt ?
Ça, c'est un truc de fou.
J'ai oublié de réviser tout à l'heure
parce que du coup, on a mis du temps
à monter le studio.
Mais un groupe, j'ai expliqué
de ce que j'ai compris, c'est
deux solutions chimiques, donc liquides.
Je pense que dans l'air, c'est
pas possible, mais en gros, je me suis dit
ce serait flippant
si ça marche dans l'air. Bon,
tu mets mixe les deux qui ont la même.
Dans.
La même quantité des deux côtés.
C'est deux.
Je ne sais plus que c'est
les deux différentes.
Si vous cherchez la réaction de Landau,
je suis en train de
vous allez voir plein de vidéos
qui montrent ça. C'est le mari
mix, les deux,
ça fait une réaction et du coup, c'est
tout translucide comme de l'eau.
Et en fait, quand la réaction est finie
et qu'il y a une une des molécules actives
qui arrête d'exister dans la dedans,
ça change la réaction
et ça devient membre d'un groupe.
Mais en une fraction de seconde. Et.
C'est effrayant.
Regardez ce que vraiment une expérience
juste, qu'il verse une carafe
comme ça et au bout d'un moment juste,
tout devient noir.
Mais c'est quoi comme moule ?
Ça marche avec cette molécule ?
C'est un truc super basique,
du chlorure de sodium ? Non,
mais un type de réaction.
On fait une réaction. C'est
un type de réaction.
Ça s'appelle, une, une, une horloge.
À. Lyon, je sais plus un truc,
mais en gros c'est
une réaction qui met du temps à se faire
et quand elle est finie,
ça fait un truc d'un coup. Et
du coup, je me suis dit c'est
le paranormal, ça c'est ça.
Petit à petit,
vous en balancez dans l'atmosphère
et ah. Ouais, d'un coup ça ?
Ah oui, d'accord,
je sais pas. J'ai besoin, approchez.
Mais alors un jour, bam !
Et on la met.
Du coup, allez voir sur Internet,
c'est beaucoup, complètement visuel.
J'ai quand j'ai vu ça, j'ai été bluffé.
Je me suis dit Ouah !
Mais a priori, c'est des solutions
dans l'air.
Puis ça m'étonnerait.
Est ce qu'il n'y a pas une case ?
Certaines métaphores là, quelque part sur.
Sur le truc climatique,
avec les boucles de rétroaction.
Une chose comme ça, oui, c'était ça
le but.
Évidemment
J'ai fait
et j'ai fait un jeu de perspicacité.
C'est fait que j'ai. Fait deux.
1008 parce que si on veut régler le SI,
on veut régler le problème
du climat, on pourrait juste arrêter
de produire tous mes principes.
Et. Écouter.
Je ne suis pas le corps
du flacon.
Je suis désolé.
La musique était juste
un petit peu plus forte et.
J'étais
enregistre
peut être dans un film, dans un clip.
Mais bref.
C'est mieux.
Oui, on me parlait de trucs scientifiques,
justement.
Qu'est ce que vous avez relevé ou commun
comme truc scientifique, en somme ?
J'ai vu quelques trucs.
De la thermo synthèse chez Plantes.
La thermo synthèse, ça n'existe pas.
Et ça, ça m'a surpris qu'il y ait
pas au moins une plante qui fait ça.
Moi, je m'étais dit
il y en a bien une quelque part
dans un fini
qui fait juste avec la chaleur.
Mais maintenant tout ça c'est tellement
ça le délire des mitochondries,
tout c'est tellement ancestral.
Ouais mais je sais pas.
Je me suis dit il y a peut être un moment
ou il y en a une
shift.
Ce serait comme les distinctions
plantes, champignons, tueurs.
Je pense faire. Ça.
Je suis tombé sur un maître allemand,
Thomas Mann.
Vous l'aurez.
Un truc.
Complètement différent.
Mais je vais vous le mettre dans le cadre.
D'ailleurs, je vous mets en lien.
Un stock exchange de wall building
d'un gars qui disait
c'est un truc d'échange en haut
pour la création de Monde
et Singa qui me demandait ça
existe la thermo synthèse ?
Et si ça n'existe pas, comment ça pourrait
marcher dans un monde qui est vide ?
Et du coup,
il y a quelqu'un qui a répondu.
Il a dit non, ça existe pas.
Par contre,
on pouvait complètement l'imaginer
et il fait des schémas tout en expliquant
toutes les réactions chimiques
etc et au final en fait ce serait juste
tu prends une plante exactement
comme elle marche
et c'est juste la partie énergétique.
Elle prend des photons puis le remplace,
pas la partie énergétique
et le prendrait de la chaleur.
Oui mais je serais bien compris.
Ce serait pas si compliqué que ça à faire.
En fait, ça ne changerait rien à tout
le processus, à part ça.
Oui, mais sans ça,
il faudrait des cellules
avec des enzymes qui changent en haut.
Non, ça, c'est pour moi ça.
Un Avoir ça,
le photon, c'est une particule de chaleur,
c'est pas partie, c'est pas corpusculaire,
c'est chimique.
Déjà, c'est pas assez, pas annoncé
de la photosynthèse,
c'est de la chimie aussi.
Mais ouais,
pour moi, c'est décisif.
Je ne suis pas sûr que même après, je n'y
connais rien en radiologie végétale.
Mais pour moi, c'est pas juste.
C'est pas un petit changement dans
une cellule végétale qui va permettre ça.
C'est une structure totalement différente
des organites dans la cellule.
Totalement différents. Pas tant que ça.
En fait, il faudrait des enzymes capables
désassembler
la chaleur en gros.
En gros,
tu prendrai des molécules d'eau chaude.
Je vais des assemble du choc l'énergie
en les refroidissant et du coup,
cette énergie, c'est pareil que l'énergie
du sang, des photons, de l'air, quoi.
Du coup,
ça deviendrait les panneaux solaires.
Plantes, quoi.
Je vois.
Là je vois que la radioactivité
qui libère de la chaleur
spontanément tu prends des atomes
qui contenant libèrent de la chaleur.
Et de la chaleur.
Je suis, je suis qui en biologie ?
Moi aussi, tout ce qui est organique,
je n'y connais rien.
Du coup, si vous êtes punky avec ça,
vous allez voir un peu
qu'ils ont dit sur ce truc là, sur tout
que j'ai envoyé.
Moi, je trouve ça très stylé, même si j'y
comprenais pas les trois cœurs.
Mais vous avez droit à ces jolies ?
Il y a ça.
Il parle aussi du coup de gens.
Ils disent voilà le plus simple.
Mais néanmoins, si on veut partir un peu
en couille, on peut partir sur la réaction
de la radioactivité, des rayons gamma,
des rayons infrarouges de tout
le monde
à chaque fois, des réactions chimiques
que ça devrait faire.
Du coup pour que ça fonctionne,
je trouve ça super stylé,
mais du coup c'est vraiment trop poussé.
Donc je dis ça, ça fait je
comme.
Quelque chose qu'on peut évoquer aussi ?
Je sais justement un peu tous ces trucs
là de comment gérer
des basses.
Ce n'est pas un paradoxe,
mais ces conséquences
et ces externalités négatives
justement de vue pas normales.
Plus simple.
Pas normal, pas normal.
C'est pas honorable.
Les conséquences négatives, les concepts.
Je suis désolé.
l'Etat du coup emploie des externalités.
Externalités négatives.
C'est ce que tu avais dit.
C'est ça ?
Mais du coup, ça veut dire que je sais
peut être un petit peu de quoi je parle.
Du coup, ce n'est pas nous
sortis des infos nous aussi.
Sur la question.
J'en sais les conséquences négatives.
Non, c'est.
Les choses externes,
les paradoxes ça oui non.
Mais en fait si
j'ai été long dans l'explication.
Mais en gros, quand a un
processus économique comme la production
ou l'utilisation
de ce podium
par exemple, qui a une conséquence
un tiers, tu as par exemple,
tu as une usine qui est sur un fleuve
et elle produit des chaises mais
aussi du mercure dans l'eau qui coule.
Externalités négatives
c'est le mercure dans l'eau.
Un impact, un impact économique sur tout
un pan de ma.
De tout ce qui est en dessous
du. Bénéfice.
Annoncé.
T'as le bénéfice des chaises,
tu métal l'inconvénient du mercure et
on a tendance aujourd'hui
à faire exactement ce que nous
on cherche à faire avec avec flat pot.
C'est oublier la partie externalités
négatives en disant non,
ça rentre pas dans notre calcul
économique, c'est un peu de gens.
Notre système économique évalue
seulement les externalités.
C'est pas vraiment ça, mais certes,
il y a un gros focus sur les externalités
positives, sur les
sur la production directe
et pas sur les externalités négatives.
Et du coup, c'est une manière de voir
les la
pollution fait, c'est de le comprendre
comme une externalités négatives
et du coup de se dire ok, mais il y a
un calcul économique à faire
dans chaque production humaine de se dire
on voit très bien la production,
donc c'est la production chaise.
Maintenant regardons l'autre
production négative,
on dire les pollutions
et ça peut être des pollutions sonore,
ça peut être.
Ça peut vraiment être
tout ce qui peut être négatif
et qu'on peut se dire tiens,
on peut essayer de chiffrer ça aussi
et d'essayer de faire un calcul économique
en voyant.
Est ce que votre activité économique
est plus intéressante que les externalités
ou est ce que.
C'est le bilan carbone ?
C'est un peu ça.
C'est le terme de bio carbone de.
Vie, quoi.
Tu prends vraiment le truc ?
C'est tu peux bien faire un film ?
Je sais pas qui montre comment sauver
la planète et que tu tournes partout dans
l'avion.
Ouais mais là tu vois,
c'est justement ces tubes.
Tu peux essayer d'évaluer
se trouve une externalité.
Est ce qu'il
faut faire zéro film avec solution ?
Moyens, mais tu vois ça, mais en fait
un calcul économique des deux côtés.
Plutôt que de dire
on voit le positif
mais on voit le négatif
et on quantifie pas le négatif.
Donc il y a pas de demi
d'euros derrière le négatif.
Là on pourrait dire
ok, ça rapporte ça, mais ça coûte 100
en pollution quoi.
Donc ça, c'est tout.
Il y a tout un courant comme ça
qui essaye de
de dire je.
Suppose que les entreprises
qui font du green washing,
elles se concentrent plutôt sur
réduire les émissions dans leur
production, mais toujours en ignorant
les externalités négatives. Du coup.
Après la problématique des externalités
négatives, c'est que tu peux choisir.
C'est ultra dur de tout quantifier
parce que l'usine
qui verse son mercure
dans le champ libre, ça ?
Mais ça, c'est qui qui déverse des
pollutions dans un fleuve et peut dire OK,
qu'est ce qui compte ?
Est ce que c'est juste ?
Ah ouais, la pollution
ça abîme les poissons ?
Et tu calcule que ça quoi ?
Tu dis juste avec les pêcheurs, ils ont un
ils ont des conséquences négatives
et donc du coup leur activité elle baisse.
Est ce que tu calcules aussi ?
Ah oui, mais il y a des enfants
qui souffrent du mercure dans l'eau,
même si tu peux compter aussi.
Mais attends, il y a des plus.
Il y a des oiseaux migrateurs qui tuent,
ont fait tatouer une pyramide de trucs
ou tu peux en fait rapidement
arriver à l'infini.
Chaque action humaine
peut avoir une infinité. De.
Externalités négatives et du coup,
c'est peut être plate à cette tension là.
Et on le voit justement
sur tous les trucs de projet.
Aujourd'hui,
quand on parle des grands projets,
tu peux les bassine
ou les projets là aujourd'hui discipline.
Mais tous, tous les projets en ce moment
en France. Ailleurs.
Machin à chaque fois y a des études
d'impact et ces études d'impact là.
Une partie c'est de voir
qu'est ce qu'on va ?
Qu'est ce qui va arreter avec ça ?
Oui mais d'essayer de.
Ce projet là, c'est aussi critiqué
parce qu'en fait céder
c'est pas des innovations c'est
des vieux trucs qui datent des années 60.
Mais.
Certainement. Pas
quelque chose. Que cela. Met.
Mais aussi à la question a quel point
est ce que tu pousse ces analyses là ?
À quel point est ce que tu fais rentrer
ce calcul économique en négatif ?
Ah oui, c'est ce que des pays comme
justement le Pakistan réclament
après les inondations.
C'est une inondation directement liée
à la crise climatique.
Mais en fait les gros pays pollueurs
ont payé pour non réparation.
C'est ça en fait le débat.
Ça c'est les débats.
Contact direct avec des victimes
qui se ressentent comme victimes,
mais à plein de trucs.
Les victimes, elles, n'ont pas de voix
d'oiseaux migrateurs.
Il va pas,
il n'y a pas porter plainte, quoi.
Donc c'est d'essayer de mettre un prix
pour tous ces trucs là.
Après, il y a plein de débats sur oui,
mais en fait, mettre un prix, c'est
ça ne marchera jamais tant que tu restes
dans cette dynamique là,
tu trouveras toujours un truc pour que ça
fasse 1€ de plus du côté bénéfique.
Et bon bah du coup on dégage tout ca.
Voilà,
c'était ma petit, mon petit cucul
un peu long.
Petite question dans le chat,
il y a grand m qui demande les végétaux.
Tu utilises plus la photosynthèse.
Du coup,
ils devraient peut être être blanc.
C'est très probable.
J'avoue que je suis pas très fort
là dedans, mais je suppose que oui,
la photosynthèse, elles ont plus de raison
d'être vert,
ils devraient mourir ensuite seul le truc.
Mais bon.
Mais si on part du principe qui mute et
utilise le terme de synthèse à la place.
Ah oui,
c'est vrai,
on peut imaginer Vert Héritage, c'est
un peu au pif qu'il soit vert.
En fait je n'en sais.
Rien, mais.
Ça produit des molécules
qui font que cv fait.
Je veux dire la thermo synthèse pourrait
aussi faire du vert ou du roumain.
Moi je vote pour un pigment
qui au contraire capterait beaucoup
la chaleur.
Donc s'il y a encore du soleil,
même si je le vois plus
à ce moment là, on peut imaginer des
plantes qui seraient noires,
absorbe à fond
la chaleur.
Et ça des panneaux solaires
qui sont carrés aussi avec de petits
miroirs. C'est ça ?
Ça parait ce que ça changerait
pas aux couleurs des plantes sous l'eau
qui sont rouge vif, rouge,
sans pas que le.
Noir absorbe la lumière, pas la chaleur.
C'est une conséquence que ça ?
Oui, c'est une conséquence.
Mais dans le monde que tu as imaginé,
c'est juste qu'on voit plus la lumière.
Oui, mais du coup, pour moi,
c'est ce qu'on avait imaginé.
C'était une fréquence dans l'eau
qui passe plus
vite. Peut être qu'en fait
les plantes seraient de couleur
en dehors du spectre visible.
C'est le truc V ou du coup,
pour nous, ça semblerait vert noir, blanc
ou il n'y aurait pas de couleur.
Rouge en gris.
Et en fait,
si on regarde avec un filtre spécial.
C'est peut être. Ça. C'est déjà le cas.
C'est déjà le cas d'ailleurs.
Ouais quand tu
regardes, ouais, quand tu regardes,
je crois que c'est les fleurs
particulièrement
que tu la garde sous filtre
ou je sais pas quand il y en a
certaines, c'est complètement ok.
C'est juste que nous on ne voit pas,
mais ils ont déjà vu ce genre de truc.
Une autre question de grand thème, c'est
ce qui est pertinent avec les sabliers
un jour, une brigade temporelle plus tard.
C'est qui ce savoir ?
Oui, en gros,
c'était une moyenne temporelle.
Mais le grand thème, au passage.
Une brigade temporelle.
Oui, c'est quelque chose
que je n'ai pas eu le temps de manger.
Pas eu assez d'épisodes
pour pour ficeler ça.
Mais normalement, ça allait être des gens
qui avaient essayé de vous
vous empêcher de changer l'avenir.
Mais du coup, bon,
bah fallait bien couper.
Ils ont échoué.
Cela n'a pas changé.
Venez !
Vous avez enquêté sur la débilité.
Il faisait bien quoi ?
On appelle ça.
OK. La cupidité finie,
comment il était au courant ?
Alors ?
Bon, vous avez quand même
fait beaucoup de bruit. Bon.
Si on vient du passé.
C'est du. Passé.
Oui, c'est nous même. La photo.
Merci.
Vous avez peut être
une discrétion.
Mais du coup c'est bizarre.
C'est bizarre que le mec nous ait
pris en photo et c'est tout.
Si vous voulez nous arrêter.
Mais je dis bien que si c'est
un groupe qui entend parler de vous,
qu'il dise
quoi ? Attends, c'est dangereux ça ?
Et qui commence à enquêter sur vous
pour savoir qui vous êtes vraiment
ou juste
parce que c'est des bruits de. Couloir.
Tout seul en un contre quatre.
Il est peut être juste
faut qu'on étudie un peu le truc.
Qu'est ce qu'on va faire ?
Et c'est ça que j'allais amener.
Mais du coup, on en épisode
n'était pas possible.
Du coup, là, là,
on avait en fait aucun moyen de prendre.
C'était juste pour vous dire,
vous saurez faire ça.
On a forcé.
On a cassé.
On vous avait forcé. Tu avances.
J'ai été envoyé l'Agence
Pas l'arme secrète
ou pire, c'était impressionnant
les ce qui se foutait le couteau,
mais la que la balle.
Que les agents qu'on. Mérite, c'est sûr.
C'est sûr, ça aurait dû me refroidir
de lancer une boite avec toi.
Mais non, la cupidité, ça ça domine.
Oui, ça crée des amitiés. C'est
pourquoi il a une tête effrayante
genre c'est un demi monstrueux,
c'est juste essayer de me choper.
En fait, il est venu avec une tête
toute accueillante et tout pour pas.
Et ca oui, que vous le soupçonnait
de quoi que ce soit.
Ça a bien marché.
Oui, mais du coup après en fait,
envoyé là bas,
il a peur de vous et même il vous déteste
parce qu'on est persuadé que vous allez
le tuer.
Détruire son monde fait, c'est un peu
un ninja, le type j'essaie lui lancer
un truc qu'il a fait genre de dos.
Il est un peu surhumain.
J'avais un temps,
je n'avais peut être pas envie.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais parce que bon, il y a aussi un moyen,
un moment.
Ou. Moins.
À partir de l'épisode trois, je savais
qu'il allait falloir bouffer des trucs.
C'est à dire que si on avait fait
huit épisodes sur certains
mois, je trouvais que tu
et il y en aurait eu un autre, non ?
C'est quoi les conséquences que t'as tuer
un mec dans la rue, dans le village
à ton avis ?
Ah non, je ne l'aurais pas tué,
je l'aurais assommé.
Tu ferais pas si tu jettes une barre de
fer dans la tête de quelqu'un dans la rue.
Très contente d'être assommée.
Je l'ai pas
grand que les conséquences, elles
auraient pu être sur toi puisque sur.
Les grands thèmes tu dis
je pensais que lui était même leur chef.
Ouais, connais
pas du tout,
il n'y avait pas de lien entre les deux,
mais je comprends le doute.
Et il y a une autre question de Mister
Game.
C'est questions à notre économiste.
Il y a t il
des entreprises qui ont vendu des millions
car reconnus comme révolutionnaires ?
Le futur ?
Je suppose que oui. Bah oui,
tout le temps.
C'est le principe.
Est ce qu'il
y en a qui étaient des grosses arnaques ?
En gros.
Il y en a tout le temps.
Il y a même des boites
ou des gens qui sont persuadés
qu'ils bossent
pas dans des trucs d'arnaque.
Et en fait au dernier moment
ça balance que c'était basé sur des trucs
type un drone, des choses comme ça,
une grosse boîte
à tout le monde et vraiment
que c'était des analystes qui sont là.
Oui, c'est super,
super boîte.
Investissez dedans
tout ça.
Je sais plus en quelle année c'était.
Je crois que
je sais plus.
C'était aux Etats-Unis ça, mais.
Dans un magazine s'appelle Social peur.
Le dernier numéro, il est sur justement
les milliardaires, ce genre de choses.
Et donc il cite notamment
toutes les entreprises
qui vendent à ces milliardaires
des solutions.
L'avenir donc non, ils ont du futur,
des îlots de contributeurs.
Exacts.
Et c'est hyper intéressant
comme comme dossier.
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un. Plus.
Haut situé dans une économie ou t'as
des personnes
riches, individuelles, plus tu vas aussi
dans une économie de la démesure.
Tu peux aussi
ou il suffit que ce soit la fantaisie
d'une personne pour que ça.
Mais c'est vraiment l'arnaque
à la petite semaine.
Sauf avec des avec des milliards.
Ca c'est vraiment
le même principe et c'est un peu
les trucs de Ponzi.
C'est
il n'y a rien de plus basique qu'un Ponzi.
C'est quoi.
Un Ponzi ?
C'est quand tu te dis
ah tiens, c'est une file de 1000
dans trois semaines,
je te donne 1100 bitcoins.
Non, parce que je pense,
mais après je dis Tiens,
si tu me tiens, ça,
je dis ça à tout le monde.
Oui, c'est.
Une pyramide, il.
Faut chercher, mais la. Méthode,
c'est autre chose.
C'est un système de vente, mais qui fait
un peu, mais c'est un peu la même chose.
Je en gros à chaque tournoi.
Sur du vent.
Si tu en fais tu.
Tu gagnes du temps.
Faire rouler un truc à la boule de neige.
Tu vois, tu ou tu rembourses
avec de l'argent que tu y gagne.
Plus de gens qui rentrent dans le système,
c'est fini. C'est ça.
Et il y a plein de système ou ça marche
avec des gens qui sont riches,
vraiment des gens.
T'es ou tu dis ?
Ils doivent avoir
une connaissance financière,
ils ont les capacités
d'avoir des avocats, des machins.
Ils s'ennuient.
Ça vous dit quelque chose ?
Mais ça, ça marche quand même
et c'est destructeur.
Plus de pouvoir dans des personnes,
plus tu vois des trucs comme ça.
C'est impressionnant quoi.
Pas aussi impressionnant de tourner
si on est en.
Crise à la.
Et comment tu fais pour valoriser
une entreprise, une startup ?
Comment tu fais pour la valoriser ?
Ouais,
j'arrive pas cela est valorisé
à hauteur de 2 millionsd'euros,
mais sans doute ça sort.
Ça en fait, c'est comment est ce que toi ?
Comment est ce que toi tu penses que
il y a plein de mécanismes ?
C'est des externalités, mais. Ça peut être
une valorisation, ça peut être.
Quelqu'un veut acheter un certain
montant qui va ?
On est d'accord.
Si quelqu'un tu achètes à ce moment là,
on sait que ça vaut ça.
Après aussi, combien de thunes a été mise
dans ton truc ?
Et puis à des analystes aussi
qui vont dire ça vaut ça un peu,
mais c'est du au doigt mouillé.
Gratuit.
Tu sais, c'est ça le truc.
C'est tu sais jamais vraiment combien
un truc vaut là aujourd'hui, on dit
Facebook,
ça vaut ça, mais demain il vaudra ça.
Et après demain, il y aura ça parce que
c'est toujours. Un.
En fait, c'est vraiment le l'économiste
aujourd'hui.
Là, c'est vraiment
un système d'information ou tu essayes
de tout comprendre.
Ou est la valeur produit de la valeur
d'avoir des informations ?
C'est vraiment un système d'information
et de transfert de l'information.
C'est un prix, c'est une information et
chaque
fluctuation, c'est 4 millions de personnes
qui annonce avec un peu plus d'en savoir
un peu moins et c'est comme ça que ça.
C'est pour ça que les prix
fluctuent sur c'est sur les actions
et les trucs comme ça.
Donc c'est tout.
Donc du coup, tu peux vendre un truc
à 200 millionsd'euros
si tu arrives à persuader de quelqu'un
que ça vaut 200 millions, tu as, s'il
n'y a pas d'autres que ça, quoi.
C'est vraiment de tout ça.
Ça reste
vrai dans tous les
tous les cas de figure donc
le convaincre.
Mentir,
c'est très important pour devenir riche.
Peut être un peu,
oui Bah oui finalement finalement.
Bon. Moi je vois pas spécialement
votre question dans le chat.
Je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là.
Deja ça a duré plus longtemps que prévu.
En fait une dernière
tu avais dit que ce serait plus court
mais aurait commencé plus tard.
Ouais mais tu as, je regarde le temps
dans les cours de ouais.
Mais en fait c'est juste que
sur la session de test,
en gros ça a duré 2 h au lieu de 2 h 30.
J'ai rajouté toute la phase
avec Lucie dans le laboratoire souterrain.
Ah oui,
c'est beaucoup plus large.
C'était beaucoup de discussions derrière.
C'est dire qu'à la base, lucide pas venir.
Non, en fait ce laboratoire
souterrain de base était un mirage trias
et vous était pas allé dans l'épisode
d'avant.
Comment. On aurait fait pour ?
En fait, il.
Avait dit Tu avais dit à Gaïa,
il y a un complexe scientifique
et du coup,
je tiens à votre part. C'est là.
Au début, c'était pas large, pas très.
Clair.
On aurait dû suivre la piste
de la raffinerie ou je sais pas quoi
finalistes.
Un autre truc était pas loin
le village des Résidences aussi.
Sauf que du coup, il fallait qu'on
bouclons un épisode que prévu.
J'avais mis de côté façon.
Il était pas partant pour rien.
Il serait pas les vacances. Web,
j'ai bien compris.
C'est quoi le village des éco ?
Ça me faisait rêver dans.
Les pires scénarios.
Et au boulot, c'est.
C'est
un peu, imagine le moine tibétain. OK.
Ouais, tu vois donc pas ça.
C'est pour ça que je vis dans la forêt.
Qui vit en communion avec la nature
et tout être très zen
etc et qui
du coup ont appris à vivre sans le.
Ah oui, sans le siphon de l'écholocation.
Avec les bâtiments,
c'est le village du goût.
Et non.
Pas qui fait souffrir de l'un
et qui fait avec ses gros sabots.
Tellement au niveau, rien
regard de l'autre.
Il aurait été aveuglé par nos torches.
Et nulle part ça.
Juste un feu de forêt.
Mais il fond.
OK non mais pas un steak à feu.
Votre avis.
N'est ce pas d'infos ?
Mais ça, c'est
un peu un peu pour cuisiner.
C'est un peu en lien avec l'expo,
évidemment du Quai des savoirs.
Je te dit ce serait cool de foutre
un incendie, mais même là.
J'en. Ai.
Je suis noué depuis l'Occitanie.
Juste pour parler de ça
parce que je me suis dit c'est vrai
que c'est dur de combattre un feu.
Alors imaginons combattre un feu
qu'on ne peut pas voir.
Ouais, ouais.
C'est vrai, c'était perturbant.
Comment on fait ?
The Crew, qui vous est arrivé
à. Combattre un feu tout court ?
Comment on fait ? Mais
si en plus, on ne sait pas ou
il est bon, on s'avance,
on se brûle et en fait, c'est là.
Qu'il faut aller. Maintenant,
il faut faire le tour.
Pour savoir jusqu'ou ça va.
C'est chaud, c'est le cas de le dire.
Mais aller sur le feu est
bon. Là, mon bon va, on va clôturer ici.
Donc merci d'avoir suivi ces quatre
épisodes de braise de ce podium.
C'était super cool,
on a vraiment passé un bon moment.
On est un peu triste, ça dure pas
huit épisodes, mais bon, c'est comme ça.
Toujours est il que les quatre épisodes
qu'on a fait, nous,
on est super fiers et on est très content
de ce qu'on a réussi à faire.
Je suis très content de l'histoire
que j'ai réussi à mener
et je suis très content de
ou les joueurs ont réussi à me.
Tout ça parce que quand même,
c'était quand même très cool.
Vous avez eu des bonnes idées,
l'air de rien,
vous vous rendez pas compte,
mais vous avez beaucoup créé des choses
indirectement, notamment le fait
que les Aigles rouges soient méchants.
C'était pas prévu à la base, hein ?
C'est juste gaffe avec les rouges.
Si c'était méchant.
Je reste culotté. Il est.
Moi je, sans
son autoritarisme. Là.
Je m'étais dit c'est des gens un peu.
Bourru, quoi.
Un peu strict quand même, oui,
mais qui veulent le bien vivre ensemble.
Ça, c'est le titre. C'est que vous l'avez
pris.
Plutôt mal, donc plutôt.
Mal. Du coup, c'est forcément mauvais
si c'est strict.
Et du coup, je me suis dit OK,
je vais partir dans l'autre sens.
On est un peu fébrile. C'est le début.
Oui, les complots
des rouges qui veulent détruire tout ça
à partir de vous, il y a un peu,
il y a plein de choses comme ça ou
de petites idées.
Je me suis dit OK, je vais partir.
Vous vous ?
Du coup,
vous vous en êtes pas rendu compte
que vous avez en partie écrit l'histoire ?
Histoire
même une réponse réponse des trucs à côté
desquels on est passé aussi.
Puis il y a aussi des trucs
que j'ai pas eu le temps d'écrire.
Du coup, je me
suis engagé dans un.
Truc qui.
On n'a pas grimpé la montagne.
C'est dommage.
Mais bon, la. Montagne, volcan.
Volcan même,
ça aurait pu samedi après 12 h.
T'as vu prendre ?
Mais non, dans cette merde. Bon.
Un grand merci d'avoir suivi.
On remercie toutes les équipes
qui ont permis que tout ça soit faisable.
On remercie aussi le CNC
qui quand même qui nous aide à financer.
OK on remercie mais il y a un escalier.
Laurent Odoul Ronan Larzul.
Désolé si je écorche les noms
qu'on me les a donné.
Une fois, je les ai juste notés.
Donc il faut prendre.
Désolé à vous
si jamais vous voyez ça pour vous.
Merci quand même.
Jean Carbonel, Nicolas
Papillon et Daniel Chartier
à la Régie, Nicolas
Bonneau, Hugo Bustamante et L'image sont
Agate Delplace et Clément Morineau.
Et évidemment, les quatre jours
autour de table qu'on ne présente plus.
Donc, n'hésitez pas à aller voir Pierre
Savelli.
Président de cette. Offre, pour toujours.
Aller voir ce qu'ils font sur leur chaîne,
y aller, commente dans le chat.
Notre ami.
MJ. Oui, oui, ça oui.
C'est David. Dans le point d'exclamation.
Willow, tu fais des lives
des fois sur Twitter, beaucoup, souvent.
Allez voir.
Les. Live de quoi ?
Tu vois des choses ? Un duo de choc.
Voilà depuis quelle aventure.
On se retrouve sur ta chaîne.
Pas si longtemps.
Ouais, pour faire.
Ce qu'ils font,
c'est la Régie.
Ou la Régie.
C'est c'est comme un truc de.
Meilleure
parce que j'ai grandi. Avec le film.
Mais avec la tête. Des gens
se dissolvent comme ça.
Le générique générique.
Avec des mimes.
Donc on se retrouve dans pas si longtemps,
avant un peu plus d'un mois sur sa chaîne.
Oui, un autre projet
un peu marrant à danser.
Dans un peu plus d'un mois, dans deux
mois, début mai, début mai, c'est
oui, c'est fermé.
C'est le 25 juin 1 peu plus d'un mois
pour la Fête de la musique.
Ouais. Voilà la fête. De la musique.
Sur ma chaîne YouTube,
on fera un petit concert
scientifique.
Les musiciens. De ceci.
Alors voilà comment ça marche.
Une guitare.
Asseyez vous.
Le. Son, le son.
Qu'est ce qu'une onde sonore ?
Non mais voilà,
on va faire un petit concert, c'est sympa.
Est ce qu'on
aura aussi un autre truc
qui arrivera un peu plus tard ?
Mois d'août dans l'été.
Mais ça vous l'annoncera
plus tard avec ce widow
charge ou
chargeur, qu'est ce que vous avez prévu ?
Vous debo sur Twitch, sur YouTube ?
Eh bien moi je serai dans un événement
dont j'ai oublié le nom.
Mais c'est comme. Skype.
Une semaine
de chantier d'Arte
pour parler de 2050, le futur.
Et qu'est ce que ça nous réserve ?
Alors là, pour le coup,
on ne sera pas dans un rôle.
On va, on va jouer un JDR, ça
encore ensemble.
Ouais.
L'équipe de choc.
La même chose, c'est le social à la mode.
On essaie de sait.
Drôle parce que le but, c'est quand même
pour de vrai.
Cette fois ci,
je pense de ne pas cramer le monde.
Ouais, on va essayer.
Mais mes conseils sont lâchés
ce soir, comme le montre ce qui se trame.
Non, non.
Non. En fait, c'est vraiment important
la sobriété.
Il faut faire attention.
Ce sera une fleur, c'est ça ?
Non, mais on verra.
Justement,
il y a plein de scénarios de l'Adem.
Qui évoquent.
Le futur en 2050.
Et est ce qu'on part
plutôt sur de la sobriété
ou est ce que c'est
un contrôle via les régions nations
des trucs de consortium ?
Est ce que par plein de schémas
différents,
est ce que c'est plus l'innovation
et la sobriété ?
Et du coup,
il y a plein de scénarios comme ça.
Et d'essayer de parler de ces
différentes sécheresses, de
ces différents
scénarios, de ce que ça recoupe. Et
bien voilà, avec le dernier rapport
du GIEC aussi, sur lequel on va revenir
avec plein d'invités.
Ce sera en public à la Gaîté-Lyrique.
Ah ouais, dans le coin,
allez y voir dimanche.
Pas celui là, celui d'après.
Je sais plus combien.
C'est quelle ville à la Gaîté-Lyrique.
À Paris.
Évidemment, il y a chose que vous ici,
c'est le quatorze, c'est le quatorze.
Donc le quatorze, c'est ça ?
Oui, avec plein de gens,
on aura un envoyé spécial aussi.
Pierre Girard en direct de Normandie,
il y aura tout
et c'est un leader qui sera animé
par fibre optique.
Ouais. Ça motive pas mal. Extrêmement bon.
Et moi je.
Si vous avez aimé ce que j'ai écrit,
dites vous que moi, je débute dans l'idée
par rapport à fibre et je me suis beaucoup
inspiré de de sa façon d'écrire.
Donc, si vous avez apprécié
ce que j'ai écrit, vous allez apprécier
ce que Fibres ont fait
parce que ce sera juste mieux.
Voilà.
Vous allez
voir que ce serait bien de mettre.
On verra
un retour, mais ça.
Se voyait.
Était pas mon truc.
C'est vous avez
trop drôle.
Ecoutez.
Moi, je vous donne rendez vous
le 15 mai pour la suite de Mission Archéo.
Donc le prochain reportage sur Free arrive
le 15 mai.
Et dès ce soir sur Twitch aussi.
Ouais, je suis tous les mercredis soir,
les mercredis à 19 h sur Twitch.
J'anime avec du Cape Cod
qui est mon compagnon
et l'auteur des scripts de la chaîne.
On joue à jogger surf
mais version archéo. Donc
Street Street View quoi.
On a mis en place des cartes
avec des sites archéo.
Donc nous, ça nous permet aux fans.
Je sais.
Je commente positivement.
Non mais c'est cool
parce qu'il y a des pays en soi.
On reconnait facilement Italie, Grèce.
Et puis il y a d'autres pays
ou on découvre carrément les
sites quoi ?
C'est des sites quand même connus,
sites, amis en tourisme.
Voilà
très bien et pas très bien.
Mais bon ça ne.
Plus rien dire.
On a.
L'impression
qu'on.
Va faire tout noir. Ça va être.
C'est vrai que ça va. Faire tout moi.
C'est le processus de. C'est.
Votre foutue usine là.
4 h pour trois jours,
sinon c'est le bordel.
Allez passer une bonne soirée
à la prochaine.
Un séjour sur cette chaîne
ou sur les chaînes de tous les autres ?
J'ai autre regard.